THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE.
THE SENATE BUDGET BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE ON EDUCATION AND
ALSO THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
FINANCE.
THE THE PURPOSE OF THIS HEARING
THIS MORNING IS TO DISCUSS MANY
BUT CERTAINLY NOT ALL AS WE WENT
THROUGH THE. COMPILING OF THIS
SCHEDULE BUT MANY OF THE ISSUES
THAT ARE UNIQUE TO SPECIAL
EDUCATION FINANCE IN OUR STATE.
WE WILL HEAR HOW SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING RATES VARIES.
FUNDING RATES VARY WIDELY ACROSS
THE STATE AND ALSO HOW THAT
IMPACTS INSTRUCTION AND
SERVICES.
TO SOME OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
STUDENTS. WILL ALSO LEARN ABOUT
TRENDS IN THE TYPES OF
DISABILITIES BEING IDENTIFIED
COSTS OF SERVICES THE CHALLENGES
OF.
PROVIDING A HIGH QUALITY FREE
APPROPRIATE EDUCATION.
PUBLIC PUBLIC EDUCATION. THIS
HEARING WILLEXPLORE CHALLENGES
FACED BY LARGE AND SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CELTA'S THAT ARE
FUNDED AT LOW RATES DISTRICTS
THAT SERVE STUDENTS WITH LOW
INCIDENCE. DISABILITIES AND
THOSE PROVIDING PRESCHOOL FOR
STUDENTS WITH EXCEPTIONAL NEEDS.
LAST YEAR WE SAW SIGNIFICANT
LEGISLATIVE ATTEMPTS TO INCREASE
FUNDING FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION IS
A MEMBER OF DONAL. ARE SO
MEDICATION CHAIR HE INTRODUCED
AB THREE TWELVE. WHICH WOULD
HAVE EQUALIZED EDUCATION FUNDING
AT THE NINETIETH PERCENTILE AND
CREATED A FUNNY MECHANISM FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION PRESCHOOL.
AS A MEMBER OF OUR TEAM AND I
INTRODUCED A B. FOURTEEN FORTY
NINE WHICH WOULD HAVE ADDED A
SPECIAL EDUCATION GRANT.
TO THE LCS PFAFF BASED ON THE
PERCENTAGE OF STUDENTS WHO ARE
SEVERELY DISTURBED DISABLED.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN ITEMS SP
TEN SEVENTY ONE TO PROVIDE A
PERMANENT ONE TIME ADJUSTMENT TO
SUPPORT. SPECIAL EDUCATION
RELATED SERVICES FOR PRESCHOOL
CHILDREN WITH EXCEPTIONAL NEEDS.
BUT NONE OF THESE FIVE FOR BOTH
THOSE WERE ULTIMATELY SUCCESSFUL
AND I THINK WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO TODAY IS CONTINUE THESE
CONVERSATIONS AND DEVELOP SOME
SOLUTIONS TO MANY OF THESE LONG
STANDING FUNDING ISSUES. ALL
WITH THE GOAL OF BETTER
SUPPORTING STUDENTS. WITH
EXCEPTIONAL NEEDS AND ALSO ALL
THE GOAL.
TOWARD OF SUPPORTING THOSE
SCHOOLS THAT SERVE THOSE
STUDENTS. WITH EXCEPTIONAL NEEDS
SO. I WANNA THANK EVERYBODY FOR
BEING HERE TODAY WE'VE GOT A A
VERY FULL AGENDA SO I I REALLY
WANT TO KEEP IT ON TRACK ON
TIME.
AND.
LOOK TO SEE IF A CINEMA MCCARTY
CHAIR OF THE BUDGET SEVEN
ASSEMBLY SIDE WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
SOME OPENING REMARKS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR JUST A
FEW OPENING COMMENTS FROM THE
ASSEMBLY SITE I FIRST OF ALL ARE
SIMPLY AT CHAIRPERSON MISTER
O'DONNELL COULD NOT BE HERE IS
IN HIS DISTRICT SO. ASSET DIE AT
TAKE THE LEAD FROM THE ASSEMBLY
SIDE AND WHEN I THINK OF COURSE.
LEADERSHIP IN THIS TOGETHER BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY ARE
PRACTITIONERS OUT THERE TODAY
WHO ARE GOING TO HEAR FROM A
LITTLE BIT WE APPRECIATE YOU AND
YOU'RE SHARING YOUR PERSPECTIVE
ON WHAT'S REALLY HAPPENING IN
OUR SCHOOLS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
KNOW LOTS BEEN HAPPENING IN OUR
SCHOOL SYSTEM THE LAST FEW YEARS
CERTAINLY A NEW FUNDING PROPOSAL
LCS PFAFF ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM.
OUR OUR CERTAINLY OUR CURRICULUM
WITH A COMMON CORE.
THAT WE HAVEN'T REALLY HAD DONE
A LOT AS FAR AS THAT OUR SPECIAL
ED FINANCE SYSTEM WE HAD A MAJOR
REFORM OF COURSE TWENTY YEARS
AGO. A LOT HAS CHANGED AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO SEE WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THIS AND HOW IT'S
REALLY IMPACTING OUR SCHOOLS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA HAVING A
MEANINGFUL DISCUSSION AS FAR AS
SPECIAL EDUCATIONFINANCE. AS
WAS NOTED THIS DISCUSSED AS LONG
OVER DUE THERE'S BEEN SOME
PROPOSAL LAST YEAR'S PRODUCT
HOLISTIC LOOK ON THE OVERALL
FUNDING STRUCTURE. SO THAT
CERTAINLY THE THE THE GOALS IN
THE OUTSET TODAY AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO A ROBUST HEARING
THANK YOU.
SO I ONE WE HAVE RAIN ANDERSON
FROM ELIO COME UP AD AND GET
PREPARED FOR HIS OVERVIEW
HISTORY OF SPECIAL EDUCATION
FINANCE IN THE STATE. AND IF
THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEES WHO LIKE TO MAKE SOME
OPENING REMARKS WOULD LOVE TO
GIVE AN OPPORTUNITY MISTER
THOMAS.
WELL I JUST THANK THE SENATOR
ALLEN. IN THE ASSEMBLY WORKING
TOGETHER ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE.
.
I MEAN SHOULDN'T HERE FOR SIX
YEARS AND WATCH AND OTHER
DIFFERENT HEARINGS ON
DISCUSSION.
WE KNOW WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE.
AND WE KNOW THE VALUE OF DEALING
WITH. CHILDREN WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS EARLY ON AN EARLY
COGNITIVE DEVELOPMENT CAN HAVE
GREAT RESULTS LATER ON THEIR
LIFE. SO WE CLEARLY KNOW WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE. THE ISSUER I
THINK WE'VE FALLEN DOWN IS IS IN
THE FUNDING OF IT.
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO DISCUSSIONS
AS WE GO FORWARD AT THIS I THINK
IT'S A. BIPARTISAN ISSUE.
BECAUSE THESE ARE SOME ARE MOST
VULNERABLE IN THE STATE THAT WE
CAN INCREASE THEIR QUALITY OF
LIFE NOT ONLY FOR THEM BUT FOR
THEIR FAMILIES SO LOOK FORWARD
TO THE DISCUSSION.
YOU SENT OVER A CENTER CAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WANT ALSO
THINK YOU WANT THEM LOOKING FOR
TODAY'S HEARING.
AS A PEDIATRICIAN ACTUALLY
SERVES AS A MEDICAL CONSULTANT
FIRST.
MY LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICT A SEXY
UNIFIED. WE WORK TOGETHER AND
WORK TOGETHER WITH OUR SCHOOL
NURSES SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGISTS ARE
TO TRY TO ADDRESS. HEALTH ISSUES
AND MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES FOR
CHILDREN WHO. ARE IN SCHOOL
CLEARLY THE SPECIAL ED SUCH
OCCASIONS VERY IMPORTANT PART OF
THAT WE ALSO HEAR HAPPENED
SENATE SELECT COMMITTEE ON SOME
SPECIAL NEEDS AND RECOGNIZING
THAT.
.
SPECIAL EDUCATION IS ONE OF THE.
BUCKETS IN WHICH CHILDREN GET
SERVICES BUT OFTEN NOT
COORDINATED WITH OTHER PARTS NOT
BECAUSE A SPECIAL ITSELF BUT
BECAUSE THE DIFFERENT. PARTS OF
ALWAYS TALK TO EACH OTHER THE
OTHER THING I THINK IN TERMS OF
SINS WERE FOCUSING ON FINANCING
IS.
REALLY LOOKING AT HOW.
YOU KNOW DIFFERENT SOURCES OF
FUNDING INCLUDING LOOKING AT
WHERE CAN WE GET.
FUNDING FOR HEALTH SERVICES ARE
DELIVERED PARTICULARLY TO
CHILDREN OF WHICH HALF OF ALL
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN ARE ON.
THROUGH THE MEDICARE PROGRAM AS
WELL AND I KNOW THAT MANY OF US
HAVE WORKED TOGETHER LOOKING AT.
MEDICARE.
PAYMENTS FOR. EDUCATION BASED.
HEALTH SERVICES SO WIDE BEGIN
LOOKING FOR TWO DISCUSSION
TODAY.
THE CENTER.
TWENTY.
SO I WANT TO COMPLIMENT.
SENATOR ALAN FOR.
AND ALL OF THE THE COMMITTEES
THAT ARE WORKING TOGETHER THIS
VERY IMPORTANT SUBJECT.
ON THE FATHER OF A SIXTEEN YEAR
OLD HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT TEN. IN
ON CAMPUS QUITE OFTEN AND IT IS
A CONVERSATION THAT JUST AVERAGE
PARENTS EVERY DAY.
TALK ABOUT.
AND IT'S OFTEN THE SUBJECT THAT.
.
THE LEGISLATURE DOES IT BUT.
FRONT CENTER.
THE CHALLENGES JUST GENERAL
EDUCATION BUDGET CHALLENGES.
EVERY YEAR WE WE GRAPPLE WITH
IN A PARTICULAR ARE SPECIAL
NEEDSSTUDENTS MANY OF WHOM ARE
IN FOSTER CARE.
WHICH IS ALSO A PART AND PARCEL
TO THIS CONVERSATION O. YOU
KNOW AS BUDGETS OF A ONE SHARE
IT'S A. TOPIC THAT'S ON THE
FRONT PAGE THIS YEAR AND I KNOW
SENATOR ALLEN'S LEADERSHIP IS AS
BEEN TREMENDOUS AND I KNOW. MY
COLLEAGUE IN THE ASSEMBLY MISTER
MCCARTY SHARES THE THE GOLAN THE
MISSION TO TRY TO. MAKE SOME
BUDGETARY SENSE OUT OF THIS
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY
THE MORE WE INVEST IN THESE KIDS
SOME THE BETTER OFF THEY'LL BE
SO I'M LOOKING FOR THE HEARING
THAT THE CONVERSATIONS SO THANK
YOU FOR COMING IN. CENTER.
OKAY SO TO KICK US OFF WE'RE
GONNA HAVE RYAN ANDERSON FROM
THE LA EL WHO IS OUR FISCAL
POLICY NOW ANALYSTS IT'S GONNA.
TALK IS ABOUT THE HISTORY OF
SPECIAL EDUCATION FINANCE GIVEN
OVERVIEW OF THE CURRENT SYSTEM.
MISTER ANDERSON. IN MORNING RYAN
ANDERSON LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WILL BE SPEAKING THIS
MORNING FROM A HANDOUT THAT WAS
INCLUDED IN YOUR PACKET AND FOR
THE PUBLIC THAT'S IN ATTENDANCE.
THEIR EXTRA COPIES OF THIS
HANDOUT ON THE SERGEANT'S DESK.
THE FIRST PAGE OF THIS HANDOUT
WE JUST HAVE SOME BRIEF
BACKGROUND. ON WHAT IS SPECIAL
EDUCATION. AND SPECIAL EDUCATION
IS A SERIES OF POLICIES LARGELY
SET BY FEDERAL LAW. WHICH STATE
THAT PUBLIC SCHOOLS MUST PROVIDE
SPECIAL SUPPORT TO ALL STUDENTS
WHO HAVE DISABILITIES THAT IT
IMPACT THEIR LEARNING.
NOW THESE DISABILITIES RANGE
FROM THE RELATIVELY MILD SUCH AS
SPEECH IMPAIRMENTS TO THE
RELATIVELY SEVERE SUCH AS
DEAFNESS OR VISUAL IMPAIRMENTS.
AND FOR EACH CHILD THAT IS
IDENTIFIED WITH THE DISABILITY.
THEIR PARENTS THEIR TEACHERS
THE SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS MEET
AT LEAST ANNUALLY TO DEVELOP
WHAT IS KNOWN AS AN.
INDIVIDUALIZED EDUCATION PROGRAM
OR IBP THIS IS A LEGAL DOCUMENT
WHICH SPECIFIES THE SPECIFIC
SERVICES EACH INDIVIDUAL STUDENT
REQUIRES. IN ORDER TO. MAKE UP
THAT DIFFERENCE OF WITH THE
GENERAL EDUCATION POPULATION.
NOW THESE SERVICES ARE PROVIDED
IN MAINSTREAM CLASSES WHENEVER
POSSIBLE AND THE LAST POINT ON
THIS FIRST PAGE. IS A IS A GRAPH
THAT.
CHARTS THE MOST COMMON
DISABILITIES BY GRADE. AND THE
FIRST THING TO POINT OUT HERE IS
THAT MOST CHILDREN IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION. AND SPECIAL EDUCATION
MAKES UP. ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS. OF
THAT SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND ABOUT SIXTY PERCENT
HAVE ONE OF TWO. OF RELATIVELY
MILD DISABILITIES IN THE EARLIER
GRADES THAT'S PRIMARILY SPEECH
IMPAIRMENT SUCH AS STUTTERING
THE LATER GRADES IS PRIMARILY
SPECIFIC LEARNING DISORDERS.
SUCH AS DYSLEXIA.
ON THE SECOND PAGE. OF WE HAVE.
INTRODUCTION TO THE BASIC
CONCEPTS THAT DRIVE SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING THIRD TWO
PRINCIPLES I WANNA HIGHLIGHT
HERE. THE FIRST IS THAT SPECIAL
EDUCATION STUDENTS ARE.
CONSIDERED GENERAL EDUCATION
STUDENTS FIRST THAT MEANS THEY
RECEIVE A INSTRUCTION THE SAME
CURRICULUM OFTEN FROM THE SAME
TEACHERS IN THE SAME CLASSROOM
AS THEIR PEERS WHO DO NOT HAVE
DISABILITIES. AND THEY GENERATE
THE SAME FUNDING TO THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA TO
SUPPORT THOSE ACTIVITIES.
NOW IN ADDITION TO THE GENERAL
EDUCATION CURRICULUM. EACH
STUDENT'S I EP SPECIFIES ITS
SERVICES THAT IMPOSE EXCESS
COSTS.
NOW TO COVER THOSE EXCESS COSTS
WE HAVE A SHARED RESPONSIBILITY
BETWEEN THREE DIFFERENT FONTS
FORCES. FIRST THE STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS PULLED
DISTRIBUTE CATEGORICAL FUNDING
WHICH CAN ONLY BE SPENT ON IP
SERVICES. AND THEN THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THAT
CATEGORICAL FUNDING AND THE
REMAINING COST OF THOSE SERVICES
IS COVERED BY LOCAL GENERAL
PURPOSE FUNDS SO THAT THESE ARE
FUNDS REDIRECTED FROM OTHER
SOURCES IN MANY CASES LCF.
BUT THE INTENT OF THAT LOCAL
GENERAL PURPOSE CONTRIBUTION IS
TO ENSURE THAT SCHOOLS HAVE AN
INCENTIVE. TO KEEP THEIR SPECIAL
EDUCATION COSTS AS LOW AS IT IS
IS POSSIBLE AS WHILE STILL
PROVIDING ADEQUATE SERVICES.
THE SPECIFIC SHARE OF THESE
COSTS IS REPRESENTED IN THE
FIGURE ON PAGE TWO THAT'S THAT'S
IN THE MOST RECENT DATE IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN SIXTEEN. THAT
SHOWS THAT THE LOCAL GENERAL
PURPOSE CONTRIBUTION NOW MAKES
UP THE MAJORITY OF EXPENDITURES
IN SPECIAL EDUCATION SERVICES
WHO SPENT SIXTY PERCENT IN THIS
YEAR.
NOW THAT SHARE HAS CHANGED AWFUL
LOT OVER TIME IT'S BEEN GROWING
FOR MANY YEARS WE'LL TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHY THAT IS.
BUT FOR NOW WE'RE GOING TO FOCUS
ON THAT SLICE LABELED STATES
SPECIAL EDUCATION. AND THAT
SLICES HAS GONE THROUGH AT LEAST
THREE SIGNIFICANT CHANGES IN
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY.
ON PAGE THREE WE TALK ABOUT THE
EARLIEST HISTORY OF A STATE
SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING. OUT
IN THE EARLY TWENTIETH CENTURY.
CALIFORNIA AND DEVELOPED A
PATCH WORKS A SERIES OF
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS EACH
TARGETING. A SPECIFIC DISABILITY
AND A SPECIFIC TYPE OF SERVICE.
FOR SUPPORTING THAT DISABILITY
PATCHWORK SYSTEM HAD SEVERAL
PROBLEMS FIRST IT WAS NOT
INCLUSIVE OF ALL STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES SECOND. IT WOULD IS
VERY COMPLICATED THERE ARE MANY
RULES THAT HAD TO BE FOLLOWED
AND MASTERED. AND THIRD IT HAD
SOME INCENTIVE PROBLEMS NAMELY.
SCHOOLS HAD AN INCENTIVE TO
IDENTIFY STUDENTS WITH WHICHEVER
DISABILITY. WAS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE BEST FUNDED PROGRAM AS
OPPOSED TO WHICHEVER DISABILITY
OR PROGRAM BEST SUITED THEIR
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS.
TO ADDRESS THESE PROBLEMS THE
STATE INTRODUCED A SOMEWHAT
SIMPLIFIED SYSTEM STARTING IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY. THIS IS
COMMONLY KNOWN AS THE J. FIFTY
SYSTEM AFTER THE COMPLIANCE
DOCUMENT THOSE ASSOCIATED WITH
IT. THE SYSTEM BASICALLY SAID
INSTEAD OF HAVING A DISABILITY
SPECIFIC TYPE REGIME WE'RE GOING
TO FIND BASED ON THE GENERAL
TYPE OF SERVICES THAT SINCE
RECEIVED.
SO UNDER THIS SYSTEM SCHOOLS
RECEIVED ONE RATE FOR SERVING
STUDENTS IN A SPECIAL DAY CLASS
ANOTHER RATE FOR SERVING.
STUDENTS IN A MAINSTREAM
ENVIRONMENT. ANOTHER IMPORTANT
CHANGE THAT WAS MADE AT THIS
TIME WAS THAT THE STATE
DEVELOPED. A SPECIAL EDUCATION
LOCAL PLANNING AREAS FOR CELL
PHONES.
NOW THAT SELL THE MODEL STILL
EXISTS EVEN THOUGH WE NO LONGER
HAVE THE J. FIFTY MODEL.
CALIFORNIA HAS ABOUT A HUNDRED
FORTY OF THE SELFLESS THEY TEND
TO FALL IN THREE GENERAL
CATEGORIES. THE MOST COMMON IS A
CELL BUT THAT REPRESENTS A
COLLABORATION BETWEEN A JOINING
SMALL AND MID SIZED DISTRICTS.
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION.
AND THESE ENTITIES WORK
COLLABORATIVELY ON PROVIDING
SPECIAL EDUCATION TO ALL
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES AND
THAT SERVICE AREA. AT SOME SOAP
IS A REPRESENT A SINGLE LARGE
DISTRICTS SO DISTRICTS SUCH AS
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED SERVICE OUR OWN
SYLLABLES. IN THE FINAL CATEGORY
OF SELFLESS SERVICE ONLY CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND THIS IS.
CATEGORY IS DIFFERENT FROM THE
OTHER CATEGORIES IN THAT IT IS
NOT RESTRICTED TO A SPECIFIC
GEOGRAPHIC AREA SO. IN SOME
CASES THE TRUTH THESE CHARTER
SELFLESS INCLUDE MEMBERS FROM
NOW. UNDER THE SIMPLIFIED.
J. FIFTY SYSTEM THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED THE SAME TIME WE
START WITH SOAP WAS.
IN THIS STATE AGAIN IDENTIFIED
SOME PROBLEMS WITH THE SYSTEM
AGAIN AND IT WAS QUITE
COMPLICATED FOR. SUPPOSED TO
FILL OUT THE AND MASTER THE
ASSOCIATED COMPLIANCE DOCUMENTS
THEY CAN THEY WERE SENT
INCENTIVE CONCERNS AND IN
PARTICULAR.
THERE IS A CONCERN THAT.
BASED ON THE FUNDING RATES
PROVIDED A SCHOOLS HAD AN
INCENTIVE TO A SERV SPECIFICALLY
STUDENTS WITH SEVERE
DISABILITIES AND A SPECIAL DAY
CLASS ENVIRONMENT WHERE THE
FUNDING RELIEF. MORE CLOSELY
MATCH THE COST OF PROVIDING
THOSE SERVICES AS OPPOSED TO
SERVING THEM IN A MAINSTREAM
ENVIRONMENT WHERE THE FUNDING
WAS NOT SUFFICIENT.
TO ADDRESS THOSE INCENTIVE
PROBLEMS AND ALSO TO. ADDRESS
THE COMPLEXITY THE STATE
INTRODUCED ITS CURRENT SYSTEM.
IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT THAT
SCRIBED ON PAGE FOUR. SINCE
SYSTEM IS COMMONLY REFERRED TO
AS A P. SIX OR TWO AND IT'S IT'S
BASED PRIMARILY ON ONE FACTOR
WHICH IS OVERALL STUDENT
ATTENDANCE.
SO AGAIN FUNDING IS DISTRIBUTED
TO SELL PLAYERS UNDER THIS
SYSTEM. IS DISTRIBUTED BASED ON
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF STUDENTS
THAN HE'D SELL. SERVICE
REGARDLESS OF HOW MANY OF THE
STUDENTS.
HAVE DISABILITIES OR WHAT.
SPECIFIC SERVICES THOSE STUDENTS
RECEIVE.
US. AND ONCE A SUB OF RECEIVES
THE TOTAL FUNDING AMOUNT THE
SOAP THAT MAKES A DECISION ABOUT
HOW TO ALLOCATE THAT FUNDING
BETWEEN ITS INDIVIDUAL MEMBERS.
SO THE EIGHTY SIX TO TWO HAS
ACHIEVED MANY OF ITS INITIAL
PROP.
POLICY GOALS IS MUCH SIMPLER
THAN THE SYSTEM THEY REPLACED.
AND ALSO UNDER AB SIXTY TWO
WE'VE SEEN A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS WITH SEVERE
DISABILITIES WHO ARE SERVED IN
MAINSTREAM ENVIRONMENTS. IT'S
APPROXIMATELY DOUBLED FROM ABOUT
FIFTEEN PERCENT THE YEAR BEFORE
EIGHTY SIX A TWO TO ABOUT THIRTY
PERCENT IN THE MOST RECENT DATA.
HOWEVER THERE ARE SEVERAL
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN SHARED
ABOUT THE BASICS OF TO MODEL AND
WE OUTLINED THOSE CONCERNS OR
SOME OF THEM ON THE LAST TWO
PAGES OF THE HANDOUT.
SO THE FIRST IS THAT. THE
SPECIFIC RATES THAT ARE
GENERATED UNDER EIGHTY SIX TO
TWO VERY QUITE NOTABLY BETWEEN
SELFLESS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THIS IS BECAUSE WE. WE.
GRANDFATHERED IN.
A LOT OF THE INEQUITIES THAT
EXISTED IN THE PREVIOUS FNDING
MODEL WHEN WE. INITIALLY SET UP
THE EIGHTY SIX A TO MODEL.
CONSEQUENTLY IN THE MOST RECENT
YEAR.
STUDENT RATES RANGED FROM LESS
THAN A FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR
THE LOWEST FUNDED SUPPLEMENTS
HAVE MORE THAN NINE HUNDRED
DOLLARS FOR. THE HIGHEST FUNDING
SOMETHING.
TWO. MODEL IS THAT THE
UNDERLYING ASSUMPTION HERE IS
THAT OVERALL STUDENT ATTENDANCE
IS A GOOD PROXY FOR SPCIAL
EDUCATION COSTS THE IDEA BEYOND
THAT. LARGER DISTRICTS WILL
IDENTIFY MORE STUDENTS AND THUS
HAVE. MORE SPECIAL EDUCATION
COSTS THAN SMALLER.
DISTRICTS.
WE DO NO EMPIRICALLY THAT THAT
ASSUMPTION IS NOT TRUE THAT IN
IN FACT THE.
IDENTIFICATION RATE FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION VARIES QUITE NOTABLY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE SOME
SELFLESS IDENTIFY LESS THAN TEN
PERCENT OF THEIR STUDENTS FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION.
OTHERS IDENTIFY NEARLY TWENTY
PERCENT.
THESE RATES AT VERY FROM MANY
REASONS BOTH.
THE UNDERLYING INCIDENCE OF
DISABILITIES FAIRIES A
GEOGRAPHICALLY AND ALSO
PRACTICES AND.
INVOLVING HOW STUDENTS ARE
IDENTIFIED AND DETERMINED TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
VERY THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
BUT ANOTHER CONCERN IS THAT
SPECIAL EDUCATION COSTS RISING
MUCH FASTER THAN TOTAL FUNDING
UNDER EIGHTY SIX TO TWO. IN FACT
IN MOST RECENT YEARS MOST AREAS
OF THE STATE HAVE EXPERIENCED ON
THE ONE HAND DECREASING THEIR
TOTAL STUDENT ATTENDANCE WHICH
MEANS THAT THEIR TOTAL FUNDING
UNDER EIGHTY SIX OR TWO HAS BEEN
GOING DOWN. WHAT THE SAME TIME
IN THE THEY'RE EXPERIENCING AN
INCREASE IN THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION POPULATION?
TAKER LISTED AS BEEN DRIVEN BY
AN INCREASE. IN THE POPULATION
OF STUDENTS IDENTIFIED WITH
AUTISM.
CONSEQUENTLY WE'VE SEEN THAT
SHARE OF SPECIAL EDUCATION COSTS
THAT ARE COVERED BY LOCAL
GENERAL PURPOSE FINDING.
EXPAND QUITE NOTABLY IN THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS.
ON THE LAST PAGE READ UNTIL WITH
ONE FINAL CONCERN WITH EIGHTY
SIX TO TWO MODEL WHICH IS THAT
IT DOES NOT EXPLICITLY COVER. OF
THE POPULATION OF PRE SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES.NOW
AB SIX OH TWO IS BASED ON
ATTENDANCE AND KINDERGARTEN
THROUGH GRADE TWELVE BUT UNDER
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW SCHOOLS
ARE STILL REQUIRED TO OFFER
SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS. AND
CHILDREN WHO HAVE DISABILITIES
WHO ARE AGE THREE AND FOUR.
OF THIS POPULATION OF CHILDREN
WHO ARE THREE AND FOUR YEARS OLD
WITH DISABILITIES HAVE GROWN
QUITE NOTABLY IN RECENT YEARS.
BUT EIGHTY SIX OF TWO DOES NOT
RECOGNIZE THAT GROWTH IN THIS.
THOSE DISTRICTS HAVE NOT SEEN
ANY CORRESPONDING INCREASE IN
OVERALL FUNDING.
THAT'S THE END OF MY PREPARED
REMARKS BUT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU HAS CENTER MORE LIKE.
AND ASK QUESTIONS. YES WITH
INCEST. POSER CAME ON TIME
ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU RICHARD.
YES AND WHAT AGE FIVE.
WEEK WE HAVE THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION PER STUDENT
EXPENDITURES OF REASON. FASTER
THAN FINDING CAN YOU GO ONLY UP
TO FIFTEEN SIXTEEN SO.
HOW MUCH IS PROB NINETY EIGHT
FINDING RISEN SINCE THAT TIME?
IT'S ABOUT NINE BILLION OR TEN
BILLION.
I'M I'M AFRAID I DON'T HAVE TO
HAVE OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD YOU
ARE RIGHT THAT.
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN AND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN WERE BOTH PRETTY
POSITIVE YEARS FOR PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT I. EXPECT ONCE WE
GET THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
EXPENDITURE DATA WILL WILL STILL
SEE THAT.
THOSE EXPENDITURES HAVE
INCREASED AT LEAST AT THE SAME
RATE AS PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
IS INCREASED. SO YOU WOULD THINK
THAT THE THE TWELVE PERCENT TWO
PERCENT WOULD STILL BE THE SAME.
AT THE DIFFERENCE MAY VERY WELL
BE SIMILAR YEAH.
AND THEN. DO YOU HAVE ANY
STATISTICS ON. KERN SAID JUST
DROP OUT OF THE PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM WHEN YOUR KIDS HAVE.
DISABILITIES TO EAT DO WE HAVE
ANY DATA. AND NO WE DON'T HAVE
ANY DATE ON THAT.
IT IS AN INTERESTING.
ARYAN SPECIAL EDUCATION LAW
BECAUSE EVEN STUDENTS THAT IT
THATCHOOSE TO ATTEND PRIVATE
SCHOOLS ARE STILL ENTITLED TO
SPECIAL EDUCATION SERVICES
THEY'RE FUNDED THROUGH THE
PUBLIC SCHOOL DISTRICT.
SO IT'S IT'S.
OF LIKELY THAT FEW STUDENTS ARE
OPTING OUT ENTIRELY OF PUBLIC
SPECIAL EDUCATION.
DO WE HAVE.
DO WE KNOW HOW MANY OF THE
STUDENTS THAT PARTICIPATE ARE.
ATTENDING PRIVATE SCHOOLS. BUT
AS FAR AS I KNOW WE DON'T WE
DON'T TRACK THAT KATE.
WE KNOW THAT WE DON'T KNOW
WHETHER THEY'RE GETTING.
HIGH PRIORITY SERVICE OR NOT IF
THEY'RE NOT ATTENDING PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. AND AS FAR AS I KNOW WE
HAVE NO DATA SPECIFICALLY IN THE
POPULATION. DO WE KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT.
PRIVATE SCHOOLS THAT ARE FOCUSED
JUST ON CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES. YET THERE IS A
CATEGORY OF SCHOOLS WHICH
SOMEONE BUT CONFUSINGLY IS.
REFERRED TO AS NON PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND THESE ARE ENTITIES
THAT.
EXIST SPECIFICALLY TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES UNDER CONTRACT WITH
PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
THERE ARE A LOT OF THESE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND THEY
THEY PERFORM AN IMPORTANT
FUNCTION AND SPECIAL EDUCATION
TYPICALLY THEY THEY PROVIDE.
VERY SPECIALIZED SERVICES TO
STUDENTS WITH VERY SEVERE NEEDS.
AND SO YOU'RE SAYING THAT A LOT
OF THOSE SCHOOLS RECEIVE. PUBLIC
FUNDING AS A LIKE A CONTRACT
SERVICE MEDIA IN MOST CASES THAT
MAKES UP THE MAJORITY OR ALL OF.
THE NON PUBLIC SCHOOL REVENUES
IS A CONTRACT WITH THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL AND DO WE KNOW OF ANY
SCHOOLS THAT TAKE NO GOVERNMENT
MONEY THEN.
I'M NOT AWARE OF ANY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR.
SIR.
THANK YOU THAT AFTER A FEW
QUESTIONS BOTH FOR DISTANCE SOME
SOME COMMENTARY FIRST.
I DO SHARE THE POINT YOU MAKE
ABOUT EQUALIZING AND IT'S
ROUGHLY THREE HUNDREDMILLION I
THINK THAT. IT'S YOU KNOW UNFAIR
IF YOU LOOK AT THE CHART SOME.
DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA AND
HAVE.
A REIMBURSEMENT RATE ESSENTIALLY
YOU KNOW THIRTY FORTY FIFTY
PERCENT GREATER. AND SO I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD ADDRESS
AND ALSO TO NOTE THAT SINCE.
THIS IS KIND OF A LEGACY
CATEGORICAL IF YOU LOOK AT THE
GROWTH IN LC AFFECT THE LAST FEW
YEARS. AT HUGE INCREASES BUT IF
YOU LOOK AT THE STATUTORY COLA.
MINIMAL SO. IT COMPOUNDS THAT.
THAT INEQUITY GOING FORWARD AND
THAT I DIDN'T WANT TO GO BACK TO
THE TO THE CHART YOU HAD A
NUMBER ONE AS FAR AS THE THE
COMMON. TYPES OF STUDENTS AS FAR
AS THAT DISABILITIES AND IN THIS
UP STRUCK ME FOR A COUPLE
REASONS ONE. I WAS A LITTLE KID
WAS IN A SPEECH CLASS I HAD AT.
THE ALL STAR STUTTERING ISSUE
AND SPENT THAT FROM KINDERGARTEN
THROUGH FOURTH GRADE BEING
PULLED OUT GOING TO THAT. SPEECH
THERAPISTS AND SENSE IT WORKED
UP TO FOURTH GRADE SO WHAT IT
SHOWS HERE IS ESSENTIALLY. MY
LIFE.
BUT BUT I I WONDER IF YOU SEE
THE HUGE HUGE GROWTH IN THE
LEARNING DISORDER POPULATION.
AND.
AND HOW IS THAT CHANGED OVER
YEARS AND AND ARE THERE ANY.
PROMISING TRENDS TO TO START
EARLIER BECAUSE IT LOOKS LIKE IT
IN THE DISORDER PEACE IF YOU
LOOK AT GRADES K. THROUGH. TWO
WE DON'T SPEND A LOT OF MONEY WE
SPEND A TON OF MONEY FROM GRADES
THREE THROUGH TWELVE SO WHAT DO
WE DO AS FAR AS. DOING EARLIER
INTERVENTION I KNOW THAT.
CERTAINLY A PRE K. IS A PRETTY
PROMISING.
THAT BASICALLY REMEDY AND SHOWS
THAT KIDS GET A QUALITY. PRE K.
ENVIRONMENT YOU CAN LESSON THAT
THE TRACK FOR SPECIAL ED DOWN
THE ROAD SO MAYBE CAN ENLIGHTEN
US THERE.
YEAH THE IT IS AN INTERESTING
STORY WITH SPECIFIC LEARNING
DISORDERS WHAT OFTEN HAPPENS IS
THAT IT'S DIFFICULT TO. DIAGNOSE
A SPECIFIC WARNING DISORDER
INTEL ITSELF HAS BEEN EXPOSED TO
RELATIVELY.
HIGH LEVEL CURRICULUM BUT A LOT
OF THESE DISORDERS ARE SPECIFIC
TO. THE CHILD HAS DIFFICULTY
LEARNING HOW TO READ OR LEARNING
HOW TO DO MATH AND SO.
OFTENTIMES THESE GO UNDIAGNOSED
AND TELL THE LATER GRADE
SPECIFICALLY FOR THAT REASON. IN
SOME CASES A CHILD IS IDENTIFIED
AS NEEDING SPECIAL SUPPORT
BEFORE HAND AND THEY JUST DON'T
HAVETHE NAME FOR IT YET. SO
SOME OF THESE CHILDREN ARE
LABELED AS HAVING A DIFFERENT
DISABILITY AND EARLIER GRADES
AND AND THAT WOULD SPEAK TO WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF. EARLY
IDENTIFICATION.
IMAGES LATER ON THAT.
IT IS DISCOVERED THAT THE
APPROPRIATE NAME FOR THE
DISORDER IS FOR INSTANCE
DYSLEXIA.
OF COURSE THE LAST DECADE OR SO
WE'RE HEARING MORE AS FAR AS.
THAT ADHD AND TO AND THOSE
ISSUES OR WHAT CAN YOU TELL US
AS FAR AS THE.
THE TRENDS DISABILITY GROUPS AS
FAR AS WHICH ONES ARE GROWING
WHICH ONES ARE ARE DECLINING.
WHETHER THAT FISCAL IMPLICATIONS
FOR THESE.
YEAH THE.
A VERY BRIEF SYNOPSIS IS THAT.
THE RELATIVELY MILD
DISABILITIES THAT ARE CALLED OUT
HERE SO SPEECH IMPAIRMENTS AND
LEARNING DISORDERS HAVE BEEN
ABOUT FLAT FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
AN INFECTED DECLINED A LITTLE
OVER THE LAST. TEN YEARS WHERE
IS THE INCIDENCE OF ALL OTHER
DISABILITIES HAS INCREASED AND
FOR THE MOST PART THAT INCREASES
BEEN DRIVEN BY A SINGLE CATEGORY
WHICH IS AUTISM.
THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE DIAGNOSED
WITH AUTISM. AS I I BELIEVE
ABOUT TRIPLED OVER THE LAST.
TEN OR FIFTEEN YEARS IT'S BEEN.
A. SIGNIFICANT ENOUGH THAT BY
ITSELF THE CATEGORY OF AUTISM
ACCOUNTS FOR MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT OF THE GROWTH IN
THIS SPECIAL EDUCATION
POPULATION OVER THE LAST TEN
YEARS.
OKAY. AT FISCAL EVEN ASKED ABOUT
THAT.
.
THE STUDENTS WHO HAVE AUTISM
TEND TO REQUIRE RELATIVELY
SEVERE.
INTENSIVE SUPPORTS. THOSE
INCLUDE ONE ON ONE PAIR
PROFESSIONAL AIDS A SPEECH
THERAPIST PHYSICAL THERAPIST. IF
YOU LOOK AT.
EMPLOYMENT IN THOSE SPECIFIC
AREAS OF THE LAST TEN YEARS IN
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS THEY'VE
INCREASED BY ABOUT TWENTY
PERCENT ACROSS THE BOARD. THAT'S
CERTAINLY REFLECTED IN THE
EXPENDITURE AREA AND HAS BEEN A
SIGNIFICANT COST DRIVER FOR
THOSE DISTRICTS BUT IT'S
PROBABLE THAT BEFORE THE
INCREASE IN AUTISM THE SAME TYPE
OF STUDENTS WERE. CATEGORIZED
IN.
GENERAL. DISORDER AND NOT
NECESSARILY. CATEGORIES AUTISM
BUT THEY WERE RECEIVING SPECIAL
ED SERVICES.
YOU KNOW IT'S A GOOD QUESTION I
THINK THE UNDERLYING QUESTION IS
WHY HAS THE INCIDENCE OF AUTISM
BEEN INCREASING DOES THIS.
REPRESENTS AN ACTUAL INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF OF STUDENTS WHO
HAVE AUTISM UP PER SE OR DOES
IT.
REPRESENT A CHANGE IN HOW WE ARE
IDENTIFYING AND DIAGNOSING.
AUTISM SUCH THAT. STUDENTS WHO
USED TO BE IDENTIFIED WITH
SOMETHING ELSE ARE NOW
CLASSIFIED AS AUTISM.
RESEARCH REALLY HAS NOT.
A SOLIDIFIED AROUND A SINGLE
ANSWER ONE ONE THING TO NOTE IS
THAT THIS RECENT TREND IN AUTISM
IS NOT UNIQUE TO CALIFORNIA IN
FACT IS NOT UNIQUE TO THE UNITED
STATES.
MOST HIGH INCOME COUNTRIES HAVE
SEEN THE SAME SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE OVER A NUMBER OF YEARS
AND RESEARCHERS WHILE THEY'VE
SPENT A LOT OF TIME ON THIS
ISSUE. STILL APPEAR TO BE SET.
UP IT STOPPED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR A COUPLE
QUESTIONS.
UNDER THE FEDERAL ID HE A.
THE FEDERAL COMMITMENT TO
SPECIAL EDUCATION SUPPOSED TO BE
FORTY PERCENT AND WERE HOVERING
AROUND SIXTEEN PERCENT. I'D LIKE
TO KNOW IF WE WERE FULLY FUNDED
WHAT WOULD THAT MEAN IN TERMS
OF.
AGGREGATE DOLLARS AS WELL AS
PERCENTAGE.
YES SIR I I BELIEVE IN.
.
IN THE MOST RECENT DATA THAT I
HAVE AVAILABLE IS FROM A FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN AT THAT TIME.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PROVIDED
CALIFORNIA A LITTLE OVER A
BILLION DOLLARS FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION COSTS THAT
REPRESENTED.
A LITTLE LESS THAN TEN PERCENT
OF.
OF TOTAL SPECIAL EDUCATION
EXPENDITURES IN THE STATES SO
ROUGHLY SPEAKING WE'D BE TALKING
ABOUT AN INCREASE ALONG THE
LINES OF THREE OR FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS AND FEDERAL SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
AID IN ORDER TO GET THE THE
FORTY PERCENT.
THAT BE A BIG DIFFERENCE WHEN
IT.
I BELIEVE.
MANY MANY SCHOOLS WOULD BE
HAPPY TO SEE THAT INCREASE YES
THAT'S A CIVIL RIGHTS ISSUE.
I. I.
DON'T.
FEEL COMFORTABLE SPEAKING ASIDE
A LOT AND I WILL THEN IT IT IS
THAT OKAY YEAH I'M.
QUICK QUESTION QUESTION NUMBER
TWO YOU WERE SAYING HOW IT DOES
TO POPULATIONS LIKE HOVERING
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN TEN TO TWENTY
PERCENT. SO SOME. ARE THERE SOME
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT ARE MORE
AGGRESSIVE IN TERMS OF TRYING TO
IDENTIFY STUDENTS SIR AS HAVING
SOMEONE I ONE OF MYCHILDREN WAS
SPECIAL NEEDS. AND IT'S A VERY
IF YOU'RE NOT SOPHISTICATED TO
NAVIGATE THAT PROCESS IS VERY
DIFFICULT SO I WONDER IF THERE'S
A DISPARITY AMONG.
LIKE SCHOOL DISTRICT EDGES.
AT. SOCIAL ECONOMIC LEVEL SO
PEOPLE WHO MAYBE OR ARE.
DISADVANTAGE ECONOMICALLY DON'T
HAVE THOSE TOOLS TO NAVIGATE THE
SYSTEM IS THERE ANY ANY DATA ON
THAT ONE WAY OR THE OTHER.
.
WE WE CERTAINLY BELIEVE THAT ONE
RESENT THE INCIDENCE OF STUDENTS
IN SPECIAL EDUCATION FAIRIES IS
THAT.
INDIVIDUAL SCHOOL LEVEL
POLICIES FAIRY AND DOES MAKE A
BIG DIFFERENCE IN IDENTIFICATION
BUT IT'S VERY HARD TO
DISENTANGLE THAT FROM THIS OTHER
QUESTION OF DOES THE UNDERLYING
INCIDENCE OF DISABILITIES FAIRY
I'M I'M NOT. AWARE OF ANY
STUDIES THAT SPECIFICALLY
ATTEMPT TO DISENTANGLE THOSE
TWO.
WHAT ABOUT IT HELD? AT WHAT
ABOUT THERE HURDLES FOR PARENTS
IN AT TWO NAVIGATE THE SYSTEM.
IT'S CERTAINLY.
IT IN MANY CASES A VERY
DIFFICULT SYSTEM FOR PARENTS TO.
SAID NAVIGATE PARENTS OF COURSE.
OFTEN COME IN WITH NO EXPERTISE
ARE FAMILIAR. WITH THIS.
WITH THIS AREA AND AS I THINK
YOU'LL LEARN FROM SUBSEQUENT
PANELISTS EVEN.
TEACHERS AND ADMINISTRATORS
HAVE DEATH DECADES OF EXPERTISE
STILL GET TRIPPED UP. SO I I
THINK THAT CERTAINLY IN AN ISSUE
IS SOMETHING THAT.
.
THAT HAS BEEN A LONG STANDING
ISSUE IN SPECIAL EDUCATION RIGHT
THANK THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
ACTUALLY WILL FOLLOW UP ON SOME
KIND OF CEREBRAL FAVE COURSE
I'VE BEEN ON THE AND AS A.
PHYSICIAN AND PEDIATRICIAN WHO
TAKES CARE OF CHILDREN WHO HAVE.
DISABILITIES.
WITH PARTICULAR FOCUS ACTION
CHILDREN'S LEARNING DISABILITIES
AND HEROES USE.
AND.
I'VE. SOMETIMES THERE ARE THERE
ARE SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES FOR
FAMILIES AND TRYING TO GET
SPECIAL EDUCATION NOW. ACCORDING
TO A FEDERAL LAW THAT ID A.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE REQUIRED.
TO PROVIDE. THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION SERVICES BUT THERE CAN
BE MANY BARRIERS IN FRONT OF
FACT.
KIND OF WE'VE LOOKED AT.
RACIAL DISPARITY SOCIO ECONOMIC
DISPARITIES.
AND TERMS OF. PEOPLE TRYING TO
GET IN CHILDREN AND FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND RECEIVE SPECIAL
EDUCATION SERVICES I MEAN THEY
WOULD ALSO NEED TO BE ADJUSTED
FOR AN INDEPENDENT EVALUATION
OF.
THOSE. CONDITIONS. BUT.
SO I THINK THAT THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT DEFINITELY NEEDS TO BE
LOOKED AT.
.
THE OTHER QUESTION I GUESS YEAH
YOU.
AND YOU HAVE YOUR REPORT
EARLIER REPORTED FIGURE TO ON
SPECIAL EDUCATION SERVICE
SCRIPTS AND A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT. CONDITIONS. YOU KNOW
THE WAY WE'RE DOING THE
FINANCING IS BASED JUST ON
ATTENDANCE. RIGHT.
AND.
SO BUT.
DEPENDING ON WHAT CONDITIONS
THEY HAVE.
THERE MAY BE DIFFERENT BECAUSE
YOU JUST REFERRED TO AUTISM
BEING VERY INTENSIVE RIGHT. YOU
MAY HAVE A SPEECH DELAY WHICH
SPEECH THERAPIST YOU CAN HAVE
LOTS OF THE YOU CAN HAVE SUCH
CHILD WHO HAS SIGNIFICANT.
MENTAL HEALTH PHYSICAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS.
.
YEAH I KIND OF THE WAY IT'S ALAN
MOTION SERVANTS OF FORCE SO HOW
DO YOU JUST FOR THAT DURATION
FACT ACTUALLY LANCE YOUR
QUESTION THEN IS IS THAT.
.
THE MOST EXPENSIVE TWENTY
PERCENT.
OF OF KIDS WHAT PROPORTION
SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING
ACTUALLY GOES TO THE MOST
EXPENSIVE TEN PERCENT MOST BEST
OF TWENTY PERCENT. OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION THIS EXPENDITURE.
YES SIR THE THE FIRST ISSUE THAT
YOU RAISED A SON RACIAL
DISPARITIES THIS IS A LONG
STANDING.
.
ISSUE IN SPECIAL EDUCATION THE
THE. THE.
A SHORT DESCRIPTION IS THAT.
GENERALLY SPEAKING AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS TEND TO BE
OVER IDENTIFIED. OF RELATIVE TO
THEIR SHARE OF THE POPULATION IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION AND ASIAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS TEND TO BE
UNDER IDENTIFIED.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. MONITORS
SINCE THE MOST RECENT.
REAUTHORIZATION OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
EDUCATION ACT BUT A REMAINS AN
ONGOING CONCERN.
ABOUT THAT AND THE QUESTION ON.
ACTUALLY I THINK WE WILL BE
CAREFUL I MEAN I RELEASE IT TERM
UNDER AND OVER DATA SIDE I CAN
BE. THAT TYPE OF LANGUAGE COULD
BE MISINTERPRETED.
DYING THAT WE HAVE PEOPLE ARE
REFERRED TO ACTUALLY DON'T NEED
IT ARE PEOPLE SO I I I I. MEAN
ALL WE CARE I KNOW THAT'S NOT
YOUR INTENSIFIED CAREFUL HOW YOU
KNOW I I APPRECIATE THE
CLARIFICATION YEAH SO.
I I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE SECOND
PART OF WHAT I SAID RELATIVE TO
THEIR SHARE OF THE POPULATION
SO.
IF EXAMPLE.
.
TWO PERCENT OF THE OVERALL
STUDENT POPULATION IS I
IDENTIFIED AS HAVING AUTISM.
BITES OF ONE PERCENT OF THE
ASIAN AMERICAN POPULATION OR
THREE PERCENT OF THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN POPULATION THAT THAT
WOULD BE. OF WHAT I'D BE
REFERRING TO IS UNDER OVER
REPRESENTATIVE BUT THAT IN
ITSELF DOES NOT NECESSARILY MEAN
THAT THERE'S A PROBLEM BECAUSE I
POSSIBLE I WOULD NOT USE ARTISAN
IS EXAMPLE BUT YES WE UNDERDOG
MISS AUTISM AND THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND LATINO COMMUNITY.
SELL ME SOME OTHER EXAMPLES FOR
HALF SURE SURE. YEAH I DID YOU
ACTUALLY AT THAT. DID YOU
ACTUALLY LOOK AT THE DATA ON
AUTISM THAT I KNOW NOTICED AND
NIGHT YEAH YEAH.
TO MAKE THE OTHER OTHER
REFERRALS FOR SPECIAL ADS WHERE
WE'RE SEEING THIS PHENOMENON IS
DESCRIBING ANSWER THAT'S NOT
AROUND AUTISM'S I REALIZE YOU
PRACTICE PICKING EXAMPLE TALK
YEAH. I APPRECIATE THE
CLARIFICATION.
THE SECOND QUESTION ABOUT.
ADJUSTMENTS UNDER THE STATE'S
FUNDING A MODEL FOR A SPECIFIC
TYPES OF DISABILITIES AND FOR
THE MOST PART THE STATE DOESN'T
DO THIS.
THERE ARE A FEW EXAMPLES.
.
FOR EXAMPLE.
THE STATE DOES PROVIDE SOME
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING FOR
STUDENTS WITH WHAT ARE REFERRED
TO AS A LOW INCIDENCE
DISABILITIES THIS IS A CATEGORY
INCLUDING. A STUDENTS WERE DEAF
AND HARD OF HEARING THOSE WHO
ARE BLIND OR VISUALLY IMPAIRED
AND THOSE WHO ARE ORTHOPEDIC
CLEAN PAIRED. EACH OF THOSE
STUDENTS. GENERATE SOME
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING BUT THAT
THIS IS A VERY MODEST.
I BELIEVE IN THE MOST RECENT
YEAR ADEQUATELY TO ABOUT. FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS FOR. EACH
STUDENT THESE STUDENTS TEND TO
REQUIRE.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS OF
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT SERVICES IN
THIS ADJUSTMENT AS.
.
IT IS NOT PARTICULARLY NOTABLE
OF FOR THE MOST PART HOWEVER
FUNDING IS BASED ON TOTAL
STUDENT ATTENDANCE WAS MEANS
THAT WE ARE NOT ADJUSTING EITHER
FOR THE OVERALL INCIDENCE OF
DISABILITIES. OR THE INCIDENCE
OF SPECIFIC DISABILITIES AND AS
YOU KNOW.
THAT.
HAS SIGNIFICANT FISCAL IMPACTS
CERTAIN DISABILITIES REQUIRE
MUCH MORE INTENSIVE SUPPORTS.
AND IF A SCHOOL DISTRICT
PARTICULARLY A SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICT HAPPENS TO HAVE. AN
UNUSUALLY HIGH INCIDENCE OF
STUDENTS WITH OF RELATIVELY
SEVERE DISABILITIES I CAN HAVE
SIGNIFICANT FISCAL IMPACTS. ON
THE OTHER HAND RESEARCH DOES
INDICATE THAT WHEN.
GOVERNMENTS PROVIDE SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING BASED ON THE
SPECIFIC INCIDENTS OF DISABILITY
IS. A SCHOOLS DO END UP
IDENTIFYING MORE STUDENTS FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION THEY DO
RESPOND TO THAT OF FISCAL
INCENTIVES. AND THEY CAN HAVE
NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON AN
INDIVIDUAL STUDENTS ACADEMIC
OUTCOMES. BEING CLASSIFIED AS A
STUDENT WITH DISABILITIES OFTEN
MEANS.
BEING FACED WITH LOWERED
EXPECTATIONS WILL FOR EXAMPLE
WHICH CAN RESULT IN THEIR
ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE SUFFERING
SO IT IS IT. IS A CAREFUL
BALANCE THAT HAS TO BE STRUCK
BETWEEN PROVIDING ADEQUATE
FISCAL SUPPORT IN ENSURING THAT
THERE ARE NO INAPPROPRIATE
INCENTIVES. VIOLENT MEN FOLLOW
UP ON THAT I MEAN.
I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
BUT I THINK IN TERMS OF THAT BUT
I I I I FIND IT INTERESTING
POLICY APPROACH TO SAY THAT
WELL.
INSTEAD IF APPROPRIATE FUNDING
BASED ON NEED.
WHICH YOU KNOW WE WE CAN LOOK AT
HOW WE CREATE INCENTIVES ARE
JUST INTENSE BUT. THE OTHER BUT.
.
THAT WORD ACTUALLY ALLOW. THIS
CERTAIN RATE MAYBE GETTING. US
SINCE YOU ACTUALLY NEED SERVICES
CROWDED OUT BY SOMEONEELSE BY
OTHERS WHO MAY HAVE HIGH
DEMANDS.
AND AND I THINK WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT YOU KNOW SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICT TALK ABOUT SOMEONE IS
REALLY EXPENSIVE.
OR NOT THAT SIMPLY SAY HIGH
INCIDENCE. BY TALKING ONE OR
TWO.
NOT TALKING ABOUT.
SUDDENLY THEY GOT A HUGE NUMBER
RATE IN FACT ACTUALLY IS
INTERESTING BECAUSE HE POINTED
OUT THAT OF THE THREE IS THE
THREE THINGS THE STATE ACTUALLY
DOESN'T JUST MINUTES ORTHOPEDIC
IMPAIRMENT.
HE SAID.
A NIGHTLINE EXACTLY IMPAIRED
RIGHTS AND AND IF YOU ADD THOSE
TWO UP ACCORDING TO YOUR CHART.
OR THE IMPAIRMENT REPRESENTS
POINT TOO AND THAT DEFINITELY
LINE REPRESENTS LISTEN POINT OF
FIVE SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
STATE JUST MEANT FOR
ESSENTIALLY.
A FRACTION BUS ABOUT. YOU KNOW
LIKE A QUARTER OF A PERCENT OF
THE STUDENTS OF THE OF THE TOTAL
POPULATION WE CAN RECALCULATED
FOR PERCENTAGE OF. THOSE IN
SPECIAL ED SO.
SO REALLY IT'S I MEAN BIZZARE
THEY THEY MAY HAVE.
TO NAVIGATE NEEDS AN EXPENSE
WISE BUT I THINK IT'S. I THINK
IT IS IMPORTANT TO LOOK AT.
WHAT PORTION?
WE SHOULD LOOK AT WHAT ARE THE
INCENTIVES ARE DISINCENTIVES BUT
WHAT PORTION. OF THE NEED IS
BECAUSE WHAT'S KNOWN FOR TWO.
IF YOU HAVE A SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE FACED WITH
NINETEEN THIS IS SOMETHING WE
SEE IN HEALTHCARE TO WRITE ITS
ADVERSE SELECTION WHAT HAPPENS
IS THAT YOU HAVE ONE DAY OFF YOU
VERY EXPENSIVE PEOPLE. AND THAT
CAN CROWD OUT AND IF YOU'VE GOT
JUST GOING TO DO IT BASED ON
POPULATION YOU JUST HAVE TO TAKE
ACCOUNT OF VARIATION RIGHT SO IF
YOU HAVE ONE VERY EXPENSIVE
PERSON. ACTING COMPLETELY BLOW
OUT YOUR ENTIRE BUDGETS FOR ALL
SPECIAL ED IS THE ONLY BEING ON
YOUR TOTAL POPULATION. ESTIMATE
NOTICE YOU KNOW THE FACT THAT
YOU DON'T COUNT THREE AND FOUR
YEAR OLDS. ARE THE OTHER THING
IS I DO NEED TO. TO TO CLARIFY
SOME STATEMENTS YOU MADE BEFORE.
I MYSELF AM A HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL STUDIES
EPIDEMIOLOGY YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT
AUTISM AND AUTISM RATES I THINK
DOES NOT ACTUALLY FOR LIKE THE
CURRENT SCIENCE.
THERE'S A GROWING BODY OF
RESEARCH SHOWING THAT THE
INCREASE IN AUTISM RATES IS DUE
TO. OF IDENTITY HELP.
DIFFERENCE IN DIAGNOSIS CHANGES
IN THE DSM. ACTUALLY AND IT WAS
ONLY IN NINETEEN NINETY ONE
WHERE TO PARK ADVOCATION YEARS
APART EDUCATION ACTUALLY SAID
TO.
CHILDREN ALSO QUALIFY FOR A
SPECIAL EDUCATION AND ACTUALLY
SEEING A KANTANA RISING
DIAGNOSES. BECAUSE OF THAT.
PROBABLY YOU KNOW WE CAN TALK
YOU CAN TALK ABOUT DIFFERENT
TENANTS ARE THERE'S BEEN
RESEARCH DONE FOR EXAMPLE IN
ENGLAND.
THEY'VE ACTUALLY GONE BACK AND.
REASSESS THE SAMPLE POPULATION
USING A STANDARDIZED MEASURES
LOOK OF CAT TRACTORS AUTISM AND
IDENTIFY AND ACTUALLY FOUND OUT
THAT THE DOLLS WHO WERE
DIAGNOSED WITH AUTISM BEFORE
WHEN THEIR CHILDREN X. WE HAD
DIFFERENT SECRETARIAT. ACTUALLY
HAD THE SAME RATES AS THE
CHILDREN SO.
BASICALLY EMPHASIZING THAT
PROBABLY VEE SAYS PEOPLE ALWAYS
HAD AUTISM WE JUST HAD DIFFERENT
SETS OF CRITERIA AND THOSE HAVE
CHANGED OVER TIME SO YOU GO INTO
A STANDARDIZED. DIRECTORY AND
THEY WOULD SEND EXAMPLE THE
POPULATION AND WE EVALUATE THEM.
IT'S YOU KNOW YOU GET THE SAME
RATE FOR OLDER PEOPLE THAN A
CHILL AS THE CHILDREN SO I THINK
THAT.
YOU KNOW THAT THAT THE BODY OF
RESEARCH IS MOVING IN THAT
DIRECTION I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
THAT STATEMENT. THAT YOU MADE
EARLIER.
AND THE CENTER.
ACTUALLY FOR THAT DOCTOR. DOCTOR
THANK YOU DOCTOR YES.
I THINK SO MUCH ON THE INCENTIVE
QUESTION.
ANOTHER. ISSUE THAT I
POTENTIALLY SEE IS THAT.
DISTRICTS THAT DO A REALLY GOOD
JOB WITH SPECIAL ED WILL TEND TO
ATTRACT FAMILIES WITH KIDS WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS.
BUT THEN THEY'RE NOT REWARDED
FOR THAT ACTUALLY ENDS UP
STRAINING THEIR BUDGETS AND SO
THAT MIGHT REDUCE THE INCENTIVE
TO. REALLY PROVIDE EFFECTIVE
SERVICE IN THE FIRST PLACE IS
THIS I DID ADMIT THAT YOU SEE
PLAY OUT.
I ATE CERTAINLY SOMETHING WE
HEAR ABOUT A LOT A IT'S. A IT'S
A DIFFICULT TO QUANTIFY.
BUT IT IS A COMMON EXPLANATION
FOR WHY THERE IS SO MUCH
VARIATION AND THE RATE OF
IDENTIFICATION BETWEEN SELFLESS
ACTS.
DO YOU.
HAVE ANY THOUGHTS ON HOW YOU
CAN ADDRESS THAT WLL THEN YOU
KNOW RUNNING INTO THE OTHER
PROBLEM WITH INCENTIVES OF.
DEALING WITH CLASSIFICATION.
WELL I I THINK THE STATE HAS
MANY OPTIONS FOR ALLOCATING
FUNDING.
.
BUT EACH ONE WOULD HAVE
DISSOCIATED STRENGTHS AND
WEAKNESSES I I MEAN. FOR EXAMPLE
WE COULD USE ONE OF THE METHODS
THAT HAD PREVIOUSLY BEEN USED IN
THE STATE EITHER FUNDING BASED
ON THE TYPES OF SERVICES THAT
ARE OFFERED. OR FUNDING BASED ON
THE TYPES OF DISABILITIES SOUND.
THOSE EXPERIENCES THAT THE
STATE HAD WITH THE SPECIFIC
SYSTEMS ARE MIXED BUT PERHAPS WE
CAN IMPROVE ON THE SPECIFIC
WEAKNESSES OF OF THOSE.
ALTERNATIVELY.
AT LEAST THEORETICALLY THE
STATE COULD. FIND THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION ON A REIMBURSEMENT
METHOD A FEW STATES USE THAT.
THAT RUNS INTO.
SEPARATE SET OF CHALLENGES
INVOLVING HOW DO YOU HIDE IT.
EXPENDITURE CLAIMS BUT.
AND IT'S IT'S POTENTIALLY THAT
COULD BE WORKED THROUGH I I
THINK THE LEGISLATURE WOULD HAVE
MANY OPTIONS FOR DEALING WITH.
WITH THESE ISSUES IF IF THAT WAS
A MAJOR CONCERN YES.
YEAH SOME ON PAGE FOR YOU YOUR
SECOND BALL IT SORT OF DOES A
GOOD JOB OF US IS UNDER THE
FUNDING. SYSTEM THE STATE
PROVIDES SELF AS WITH FUNDING
BASED ON TOTAL STUDENT
ATTENDANCE. REGARDLESS OF HOW
MANY STUDENTS ARE ENROLLED IN
SPECIAL ED. EDUCATION OR HOW THE
STUDENTS ARE SERVED.
THAT'S SORT OF THE CONCEPT THAT
I GET AN EARFUL FROM FROM MY
DISTRICT WITH A HIGH
CONCENTRATION.
OF SPECIAL ED STUDENTS.
FINALLY SAYING IT CREATES AN
UNFAIR.
BURDEN WHERE THEY'RE NOT GETTING
COMPENSATED FOR THE ACTUAL
NUMBER OF STUDENTS THAT NEED
SERVICES.
WOULD YOU SAY THAT AB SIX OF
TWO IS A GOOD MODEL.
WOULD YOU SAY IT'S A SUCCESSFUL
MODEL.
.
I. I I THINK THAT THE EVIDENCE
SUGGESTS THAT MAYBE SIX OR TWO
SUCCEEDED AT THE STATE'S INITIAL
POLICY GOALS WHICH WAS
SIMPLIFYING THE SYSTEM AND
SPECIFICALLY. ELIMINATING
DISINCENTIVES FOR SERVING
STUDENTS WITH RELATIVELY SEVERE
DISABILITIES AND MAINSTREAM
ENVIRONMENTS.
NOW WITH ANY POLICY AS BROAD AS.
FUNDING SPECIAL EDUCATION
THEY'RE ALWAYS GOING TO BE A
NUMBER OF COMPETING PRIORITIES.
END IN THIS IN THIS INSTANCE IT.
ONE AREA WHERE THE STATE MAY BE
HAS MOVED AWAY FROM IS. OF BEING
LESS PRECISE AND HOW IT TARGETS
SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING. FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION ME.
THAT IS CERTAINLY IN THE AREA.
WHERE'D BE LEGITIMATE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER ARE
THERE ALTERNATIVES THAT WOULD
IMPROVE UPON IT.
OF COURSE ANY OF THOSE
IMPROVEMENTS WILL COME WITH
THEIR OWN TRADE OFFS.
AND THAT ACTUALLY IS TO MY NEXT
QUESTION IS THE LA O.
RECOMMENDING. ANY SPECIFIC
IMPROVEMENTS BASED ON ALL OF
YOUR RESEARCH AND DATA. THAT ARE
FAIR.
WASTED I MEAN IF YOU WERE KING
HOW WOULD YOU IMPROVE THE SYSTEM
I GUESS IS MY QUESTION. AT THIS
AT THIS TIME THE LA OWES.
.
THE ONLY SIGNIFICANT LONG
STANDING RECOMMENDATION FOR
IMPROVING SPECIAL EDUCATION
FUNDING IS TO ADDRESS THE LONG
STANDING INEQUITIES IN EIGHTY
SIX TO TWO RATES SO FOR MANY
YEARS WE'VE BEEN. SUGGESTING
THAT THESE INEQUITIES ARE BASED
ON.
REALLY THAT SOME HISTORICAL
ACCIDENTS OR ARTIFACTS THAT
DON'T MAKE ANY SENSE ANYMORE AND
THAT AND WE SHOULD BE WORKING
TOWARDS.
AT LEAST REALIZING THE INITIAL
VISION OF EIGHTY SIX OR TWO
WHICH WOULD BE AN EQUAL PERSON
FUNDING RIGHT FOR ALSO
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
OKAY THANK YOU.
CAN I JUST WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON
THAT A LITTLE BIT.
I'M ONE OF THE THINGS THAT HAS
CHANGED SIGNIFICANTLY SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT. IS.
.
A MUCH GREATER DIVERSITY IN THE
TYPE OF SCHOOLS THAT EXIST IN
OUR SYSTEM.
AND.
I WAS WITHOUT THE GROWTH OF THE
CHARTER SCHOOL MOVEMENT. WHICH
HAS NOW IS NOW TO GETTING UP AT
A MUCH MUCH LARGER PORTION OF
OUR STUDENTS.
AND WHERE DOES THAT FIT INTO THE
CALCULUS. THERE ARE LOTS OF
RUMORS OF FLOW BACK BACK AND
FORTH FROM BOTH SIDES ABOUT THE
EXTENT TO WHICH THE DISTRICT
SCHOOLS IN THE CHARTER SCHOOLS
ARE.
TAKING ON A CERTAIN PORTION OF
THE SPECIAL NEEDS STUDENTS
THERE'S ALSO A LOT OF ARGUMENTS
MADE ABOUT THE SEVERITY OF THE
NEEDS. ASSOCIATED. IT SEEMS TO
ME THAT WITH THIS NEW SHIFT IN
THE WAY THAT WE'RE EDUCATING SO
MANY OF OUR STUDENTS. THAT THAT
ALONE AT ALL GIVES US THE THE
NEED TO REALLY EXAMINE THIS
ISSUE. OUT WHAT WE WERE DOING TO
TO TO REALLY LOOK AT WHETHER A
STRAIGHT PER PUPIL. ALLOCATION
REALLY MAKE SENSE ANYMORE.
IT IS A.
AN IMPORTANT QUESTION. BY A
THINK THE THE FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE
WITH CHARTER SCHOOLS AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION IS THAT A LOT OF
SPECIAL EDUCATION SERVICES
REALLY. DEPEND ON WHAT WE REFER
TO AS ECONOMIES OF SCALE.
RIGHT IT'S IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
TO PROVIDE. ADEQUATE SERVICES.
FOR A POPULATION OF.
WITH REASONABLE COSTS PER
STUDENT IF THAT POPULATION IS
VERY SMALL SO FOR INSTANCE. OF
THE POPULATION WHO ARE BLIND OR
VISUALLY IMPAIRED NEED VERY
SPECIFIC SUPPORTS AND SERVICES
BOTH AND STREETS INSTRUCTIONAL.
AND IN TERMS OF THE MATERIALS
ARE PROVIDED TO THEM. LARGER
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. A SERVICE.
I'D JUST BY VIRTUE OF THEIR SIZE
MORE OF THE STUDENTS AND THUS
HAVE.
REASONABLE ACCESS TO THOSE
MATERIALS AND ARE ABLE TO EMPLOY
A FULL TIME BASIS. APPROPRIATE
STAFF MEMBERS SMALLER DID SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. OFTEN STRUGGLE WITH
THAT AND CHARTER SCHOOLS IN
PARTICULAR TO SAY THAT THAT
WOULD BE.
I THINK THE MAJOR CHALLENGE
WITH CHARTER SCHOOLS.
.
FOR THAT REASON I SAY IT'S
POSSIBLE TO AN EVEN ABSENT ANY.
BAD PRACTICES AMONG CHARTER
SCHOOLS THAT PARENTS OF STUDENTS
WITH SUCH DISABILITIES COULDN'T
EASONABLY.
CONCLUDE THAT A CHARTER SCHOOL
IS OFTEN NOT THE BEST PLACE FOR
THEIR IMPRISONMENT WHICH.
BY ITSELFWOULD MEAN THAT THE
GROWTH OF THE CHARTER SCHOOL
POPULATION. WILL MEAN THAT THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHICH HAVE.
ADVANTAGES AND ECONOMIES OF
SCALE ARE LEFT BEHIND WITH MORE
OF THE STUDENTS.
THAT. FITS WITH SOME OF THE DATA
THAT WE'VE SEEN BUT IT'S IT'S
HARD TO. ACTUALLY TEACH OUT A
CAUSAL RELATIONSHIP THERE.
RIGHT SO I GUESS I'M TRYING TO
IN AND THIS IS THE MOMENT I WANT
TO ASK THE NEXT PANEL A SUBSIDY
SO ANOTHER HERE AND SAID LOVE IT
IF THEY WOULD COULD ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE BUT.
I'M SO INTERESTED IN THIS
HISTORICAL SHIFT I APPRECIATE
YOUR PRESENTATION.
BECAUSE IT SEEMS AS THOUGH THE
END OF THE NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT
REFORMS THE A B..
.
SIX OF TO OUR REFORMS.
TEAM TO ADDRESS A PROBLEM THAT
EXISTED RIGHT THAT THERE WAS A
THERE WAS AN INCENTIVE
ASSOCIATED WITH.
WITH. YOU KNOW OVERDIAGNOSIS
PERHAPS.
MORE SEVERE NEEDS BECAUSE
EVERYONE KNEW THEY GET MORE
MONEY ASSOCIATED WITH THAT. ADEN
BUT NOW GIVEN THAT THE SHIFT IN
THE WAY THEY WERE EDUCATING OUR
KIDS IN THE IN THE IN THE MIX OF
SCHOOLS THAT ARE THERE OPEN TO
THEM AS OPTIONS.
AND. I WON IT I I GUESS I GUESS
THE QUESTION IS IF WE'RE GONNA
IF WE WANT TO. REFORM MAYBE SIX
OH TWO TO MOVE A LITTLE BIT BACK
IN THE DIRECTION OF WHAT WE HAD
BEFORE NINETY EIGHT. AND HOW
WOULD WE CRAFT LEGISLATION TO.
TO NOT FALL INTO THE SAME
PROBLEMS THAT THEY WERE TRYING
TO FIX WITH SIX OF TWO IT MAY BE
AND THAT'S A BIG QUESTION. AND.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE A GREAT ANSWER
FOR NOW I'D LOVE THE ALIENS ARE
THINKING ABOUT THIS.
YEAH WE'RE WE'RE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE ON THIS AND
IN FACT WE HAVE BEEN.
WORKING.
WITH MANY OF. YOUR STAFFERS ON
EXACTLY THIS QUESTION FOR MANY
YEARS AND.
AND HAVE MANY THOUGHTS TO SHARE
I'M AFRAID IT'S IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO SUMMARIZE THEM.
IN MY COMMENTS HERE DECIDE TO
GET THAT I LOVE TO. CONNECT WITH
YOU OFF LINE AND TALK ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE I'M VERY INTERESTED IN
AND CERTAINLY INTERESTING
HEARING AS OTHER PALACE COME UP
THROUGH THE COURSE OF THE DAY.
IF YOU HAVE THOUGHTS ON THAT
ISSUE. ASSUME OR CITY THANK YOU.
FROM.
WHAT IS THE CURRENT TOTAL STATE
SPENDING ON SPECIAL EDUCATION?
I DON'T HAVE.
OBVIOUSLY THE SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN.
YEAR WHICH STILL IN PROGRESS I
ALSO HAVE NOT HAD A CHANCE TO
ANALYZE THE SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
DATA THAT JUST CAME OUT SO. THE
MOST RECENT DATA I HAVE IS FROM
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN AND THAT YEAR
WAS A LITTLE OVER THIRTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS THIRTEEN
BILLION.
AND SO.
IT AND AND THAT IS PRIMARILY
THROUGH THE STATE ALLOCATION OF
FUNDS THAT.
INOTES ACTUALLY THE MAJORITY OF
IT IS COVERED BY LOCAL GENERAL
PURPOSE.
IS CONTRIBUTIONS SO THAT THE
STATE.
ALLOCATION WAS ALL A LITTLE
LESS THAN FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
SO IT COVERED A LITTLE LESS THAN
FORTY PERCENT OF THOSE
EXPENDITURES. AND SO DID THE
NEWS. DOES THAT MEAN THAT
DOLLARS THAT THE STATE GETS
THROUGH. THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FOR MY THROUGH
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT. THAT
ARE ADMINISTERED BY OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT'S CORRECT.
.
AND SO YOU MENTIONED EARLIER
THAT.
.
UNDER THE FEDERAL ID A.
ACTUALLY I THINK IT WAS CENTER
WELL THAT THAT THAT INDICATED
THAT IT. IS IT IN THE LAW OF THE
FEDERAL ID A THAT THE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS SUPPOSED
TO FIND IT AT FORTY PERCENT.
YOUR COVER FORTY PERCENT OF OF
THE SPECIAL EDUCATION BECAUSE AS
I UNDERSTAND IT WHEN A WHAT IS
NOW KNOWN AS ID A WAS PASSED IN
THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES THERE WAS
ASPIRATIONAL LANGUAGE ATTACHED
TO THAT THAT. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT INTENDED.
I'M GONNA GET A LITTLE TACKY
HERE BUT AS I UNDERSTAND IT
THERE.
PLEDGE WAS TO PROVIDE FORTY
PERCENT OF THE AVERAGE OF PER
PUPIL EDUCATION EXPENDITURES IN
THE NATION I. I DON'T ACTUALLY
KNOW WHAT THAT FIGURE
CORRESPONDS TO.
IN TODAY'S DOLLARS A BELIEVE IT
IS A SOMEWHAT.
SOMEWHAT SMALLER AMOUNTS THAN
FORTY PERCENT OF TOTAL SPECIAL
EDUCATION EXPENDITURES BUT IT'S
CERTAINLY MUCH. MUCH GREATER
THAN. THE FED'S CURRENTLY GIVE
AND SO IS THERE ANY.
.
LANGUAGE AND AND THE FEDERAL LAW
THAT. WOULD.
GIVE THE STATE.
SOME KIND OF A LEGAL CLAIM FOR A
A RIGHT UNFUNDED MANDATE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS.
THE STATE HAS ANY LEGAL
STANDING TO THAT I BELIEVE IT
WAS JUST ASPIRATIONAL LANGUAGE.
OKAY.
.
I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY YOUR
COMMENTS EARLIER.
AS TO THE. OVER AND UNDER I
DIFFERENT IDENTIFICATION YOU YOU
WERE TALKING.
JUST AS THE PERCENTAGE OF
STUDENTS IN.
.
AND A DIFFERENT RACIAL GROUPS
WHETHER THEY'RE OVER UNDER THEIR
OVERALL GENERAL POPULATION IS
THAT CORRECT CORRECT OKAY SO
YOU'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT OVER
UNDER DIAGNOSIS. YES.
WAS NOT MEANING TO MAKE ANY
MEDICAL CLAIMS WE WE DON'T KNOW
IF DIFFERENCES IN REPRESENTATION
IN SPECIAL EDUCATION REPRESENT.
AND TO WHAT DEGREE THEY
REPRESENT DIFFERENCES IN THE
ACTUAL INCIDENCE DISABILITIES AS
OPPOSED TO. DIFFERENT PRACTICES
FOR IDENTIFYING DISABILITIES
ARE.
AND FINALLY I. DON. OFTEN HEAR
ANECDOTAL.
.
OPINIONS THAT.
THAT.
THAT THERE IS A HIGHER
INCIDENCE OF DIAGNOSES
ESPECIALLY OF AUTISM AND. HIGHER
SOCIAL ECONOMIC.
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO MORE ADVOCATES IN
ORDER TO. ADVOCATE AND
OBTAIN. THE EYEPIECE A IS THERE
ANY EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT THAT.
SO FIRST WE WE'VE. ALSO HEARD
THAT CLAIM OFTEN.
IT.
I'VE RECENTLY REVIEWED THE
LITERATURE ON THIS SIDE I WOULD
SAY IT'S MIXED.
OKAY THANK YOU.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER ANDERSON AND AS IT WILL
BE IN TOUCH MOVING FOR AND I'M
SURE OTHER MEMBERS WILL BE AS
WELL AS TO DO PROCEDURE
PRESENTATION I THINK YOU'VE
GIVEN US A LOT OF FOOD FOR
THOUGHT FOR THE NEXT.
WHICH IS JUST.
JAM PACKED WITH GREAT
PERSPECTIVE SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER EDISON LET'S CALL UP.
FRANCISCO ESCOVEDO IS THE
SUPERINTENDENT CHULA VISTA
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL DISTRICT.
BRAZIL THE PRETEND OF KEYS UNION
SCHOOL DISTRICT. ANNEMARIE
YELLOW ALSO IS THE DIRECTOR OF
SANTA CLARA COUNTY SELFLESS.
I JEAN CHRISTOPHE BECAUSE THE
CHIEF BUSINESS OFFICER OF
SIMMERED IN A CITY FOR A UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN. JANE ALSO I
SHOULD MENTION HIS SON.
I HAVE BEEN HIGHLY RECOMMENDED
FROM OUR CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICERS ASSIST
ORGANIZATION CASCO WHICH HAS A
VERY IMPORTANT PERSPECTIVE IN
THIS IS WE TRY TO MAKE. THE
WHOLE SYSTEM PENCIL OUT
FINANCIALLY.
THEY WERE ALSO CAN HEAR SOME
FROM SOME SOME EDUCATORS WHO ARE
NOT ON THE MINISTER OF SITES A
ROBBIE CRATES. WHOSE SPECIAL
EDUCATION RESOURCE TEACHER AT
DUBLIN UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
MARTHA PANDERING WHO'S A RETIRED
SPECIAL EDUCATION PARA
PROFESSIONAL. FROM TRIM TWIN
RIVERS UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
WE ALL KNOW THE PARISER ARE VERY
IMPORTANT PIECE OF THIS PUZZLE
TO. AND WE'RE VERY MUCH LOOKING
FORWARD TO HER TESTIMONY.
AND THEN KARINA LOOK QUEEN IS
APPARENT LEADER FROM THE SPANISH
LANGUAGE SPECIAL EDUCATION
PARENT SUPPORT GROUP FROM
PREVIEW COUNTIES WE'RE GONNA
HAVE A. AN IMPORTANT.
PARENTAL PERSPECTIVE TOO SO WE
REALLY HAVE. THE THE WHOLE GAMUT
OF PERSPECTIVES IN THE SYSTEM
REPRESENT THIS PANEL AND I'M
REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO IT.
OUT I'D LOVE TO START WITH
FRANCISCO SQUARE THOUGH. I WILL
PRESENT HIS TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU.
BUT A GREAT MORNING AND AND YOU
KNOW I WILL SAY GAVE KEVIN AND I
WERE COMMENTING THAT OFTENTIMES
THE POUR LA O. GETS ALL OF THE
QUESTIONS OF THE ENERGY FROM THE
MEMBERS.
AND AND AND HERE WE HAVE THIS
GREAT. RANGE OF OF LOCAL
PERSPECTIVES FROM EVERY LEVEL OF
THE GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE AND I
HOPE THE MEMBERS WILL. WILL
ENGAGE THEM AS WELL AS THERE'S A
LOT OF KNOWLEDGE HERE.
THANK YOU FOR THE GREAT MORNING
I'VE REALLY LEARNED A LOT FROM
THE QUESTIONS AND THE. DATA
SHARED MY NAME IS FRANCISCO
SQUARE THEN THE SUPERINTENDENT
OF THE TWO OF US ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
TO THE BASIS IS SOUTH OF SAN
DIEGO IS THE LARGEST LEMENTARY
DISTRICT IN CALIFORNIA.
WHERE?
WE SERVE OVER THIRTY THOUSAND
PRE K. US SIX KIDS.
WE HAVE FORTY SIX SCHOOLS OF
FIVE OF THOSE SCHOOLS ARE
CHARTER SCHOOLS BY THE WAY
DEPENDENT CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT
WE CONVERTED. A WE'RE ABOUT FIVE
MILES FROM THE BOARD OF MEXICO.
ARE WE SERVE A LARGE MILITARY
POPULATION.
WHERE APPROXIMATELY IN SOME OF
OUR SCHOOLS TWENTY FIVE PERCENT
OF THE STUDENT POPULATION ARMED
MILITARY AFFILIATED?
WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY THIRTY
FIVE PERCENT OF OUR STUDENTS FOR
ENGLISH LEARNERS.
FIFTY ONE PERCENT PARTICIPATE IN
THE FREE REDUCE UP PRICE LUNCH
PROGRAM. AND CLOSE TO ELEVEN
THOUSAND ARE DEAD FIVE
SPECIALISTS WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY THREE THOUSAND OF
OUR STUDENTS THAT ARE. OUR
SPECIAL ED STUDENTS UP. TO THIS
DAY IS IS IS A GREAT DIVERSE
PLACE WE BELIEVE THAT EVERY
CHILD IS AN INDIVIDUAL OF GREAT
WORTH NO MATTER.
YOU KNOW CHARLES ZIP CODE GENDER
COLOR DISABILITY WE EXPECT OUR.
STUDENTS TO PERFORM ABOUT THEIR
POTENTIAL.
WE'VE HAD GREAT SUCCESS IN DOING
THAT WE IF YOU LOOK AT THAT FIVE
BY FIVE DASH BOARD I'M SURE MANY
OF YOU HAD. A GREAT TIME
ENJOYED.
LOOKING THROUGH IT MANY OF OUR
ENGLISH LEARNERS AND SPECIAL LET
MATTERS A GREAT TIME WAS HAD A
GREAT TIME I KNOW THAT WITH
TIME.
AND WAS JUST IN A.
AT AT. BUT YOU'LL SEE MANY FOR
ENGLISH LEARNERS AND.
STUDENT FROM MOM POVERTY AT AT
THAT THE GREEN GREEN GREEN
SECTOR.
YEAH ONE OF ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT WERE SEEN THOUGH ALTHOUGH
WE'RE HAVING AN AMAZING ACADEMIC
SUCCESS WITH VIDEO FOR TARGET
GROUPS. ESPECIALLY POPULATION IS
THAT THE RED RED AREA WHICH IS
WHICH IS FOR US RIGHT NOW. A.
.
WE'RE A LEVEL OF URGENCY AND HOW
DO WE SUPPORT OUR SPECIAL ED
STUDENTS TRULY TRULY IS IT IS A
BIG ISSUE. LEVEL TERMS OF
ACADEMIC OUTCOMES OR ACADEMIC
OUTCOMES SICK EXACTLY EXACTLY
AND ONE OF THINGS THAT I'VE BEEN
HEARING THROUGHOUT IS IT IS
IMPORTANCE OF. OF SUPPORTING OUR
KIDS AT AT A YOUNGER AGE AND AND
ONE OF THINGS THAT I SEE IS
THAT.
BY THE TIME STUDENTS ARE
IDENTIFIED AND ARE IN SPECIAL
ED.
THEY'RE AT A FOURTH FIFTH SIXTH
GRADE LEVEL RIGHT AND I BUY THAT
THAT TIME.
THAT EARLY INTERVENTION IS NOT
THIS IS NOT MAKING THE INROADS
NECESSARY NECESSARY TO CELEBRATE
ACHIEVEMENT.
.
SO I REALLY WANT TO FOCUS ON ON
PRE K. BECAUSE I REALLY DO
BELIEVE INVESTMENT AS.
AT AN EARLY AGE. REALLY WILL
MAY MAKE A SIGNIFICANT INPUT.
JAB AT SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENT I
WANNA HIGHLIGHT TWO SPECIFIC
STUDIES STUDY FROM DUKE
UNIVERSITY IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN FOUND THAT THE
ATTENDANCE IN PRESCHOOL. REDUCES
THE LIKELIHOOD THAT A CHILD WILL
NEED OR NEED TO BE PLACED IN A
SPECIAL DAY CLASS BY THIRTY NINE
PERCENT. YOU KNOW THAT'S THAT'S
REALLY SIGNIFICANT. ANOTHER
STUDY BY THE NATIONAL FORUM ON
EARLY CHILDHOOD POLICY AND
PROGRAMS FOUND THAT HIGH QUALITY
EARLY. CHILDHOOD INTERVENTION
PROGRAM CAN YIELD. FOUR TO NINE
DOLLARS AND RETURN FOR EVERY ONE
DOLLAR INVESTED. IN I JUST WANT
TO SHARE WHAT.
REITERATE WHAT ASSEMBLY PERSON
I CHAVEZ SAID THIS IS THIS IS.
THIS NOT COMPLEX IT IS A COMPLEX
ISSUE SPECIAL LEAD WITH ALL. ALL
THE.
CHALLENGES BUT THE INVESTMENT
AND HOW WE NEED TO EARMARK
DISINVEST MATTER PRESCHOOL AGE
IS CLEAR IS CLEAR AND WE TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT TO THE MISTER.
WE HAVE ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED AND
TWELVE SPECIAL THAT.
PRE SCHOOL STUDENTS. ARE THE
VAST MAJORITY ARE IN SPECIAL DAY
CLASS ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN.
ONLY FORTY TWO ARE AN INCLUSION
CLASS.
WELL.
BUT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY TWO ARE
IN WHAT WE CALL COMMUNITY SPEECH
CLASSROOMS THE COST PER STUDENT
IS ABOUT TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER STUDENT WE. EXPAND
TO EIGHT POINT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS AND ONLY RECEIVE ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL FUNDS
WHICH. WE NEED TO COVER EIGHTY
EIGHT PERCENT OF OF THAT BECAUSE
IT IS A SIGNIFICANT.
SENT A SIGNIFICANT BURDEN YOU
KNOW. BECAUSE OF THE UNDER FOUR
FUNDED AT A SPECIAL ED PROGRAM
IT IT LEADS TO DECISIONS THAT I
BELIEVE. IS FAR FROM THE BEST
INTEREST TO STUDENTS.
YOU KNOW WE WE TEND TO PLACE
MORE KIDS A SPECIAL DAY CLASSES
RATHER THAN INCLUSION CLASSES.
THEM THE MONEY IS USED. MORE IN
A REACTIONARY BASIS RATHER THAN
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR FOR
OUR STUDENTS TO SERVE. OUR
SPECIAL ED STUDENTS AND. I'M
TALKING ABOUT GENERAL THAT
TEACHERS ARE GENERALLY TEACHERS
DON'T KNOW HOW TO HANDLE SPECIAL
ED STUDENTS NEED TO MAKE MORE OF
AN INVESTMENT. AT AT THE GROUND
LEVEL. AT THE GROUND LEVEL IT IT
ISN'T IT IS. ALSO SO CRITICAL
THEY JUST WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU
THAT. THE NUMBER OF PRE SCHOOL
STUDENTS THAT ARE BEING
IDENTIFIED.
HAS INCREASED SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND FOUR I INTO THE
VISTA LOAN.
OUR NUMBERS HAVE GROWN BY SIXTY
PERCENT SINCE TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN DUE TO THE INCREASE OF
REFERRALS. AND AN INCREASE OF
POPULATION OF COURSE YET THE
FUNDING HAS REMAINED STAGNANT.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
WE'VE OPENED THIRTEEN SEC
PRESCHOOL CLASSES SERVING AN
ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
ONE ADDITIONAL STUDENTS SO. WE
FEEL THAT WE CAN ADDRESS IT THIS
ISSUE OBVIOUSLY BY PROVIDING
FUNDING THROUGH A B. SIX ZERO
TWO BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY HOW WE
USE THE FUNDING. IS SO CRITICAL
WE NEED TO INVEST AT EARLY AGE
WE NEED TO INVEST. IN OUR
GENERAL ED POPULATION AND WE
NEED TO CREATE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENTS FOR KIDS YOU KNOW
CAN CAN ACCELERATE THEIR
LEARNING.
THANK YOU CRIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BRAZIL SUPERINTENDENT FROM.
HE'S UNION SCHOOL DISTRICT NOW
WHERE'S KEYS.
HE IS IS LOCATED ALONG THE
NINETY NINE IN BETWEEN NOW I
WOULD SAY SERIES MODESTO
INTERLOCK SO GREAT. ABOUT THAT
SAID CAN ALAN BERRY HILL COUNTRY
ABSOLUTELY ALL RIGHT.
WELL GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS AL
YOU BRAZIL AND I'M A FIRST
GENERATION IMMIGRANT AND A PROUD
PRODUCT OF PUBLIC EDUCATION.
I'M HERE TODAY REPRESENTING
SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS AS THE
PRESIDENT ELECT OF SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION AND I ALSO
SERVE AS A KEYS UNION SCHOOL
DISTRICT SUPERINTENDENT. THIS IS
A SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
STANISLAUS COUNTY OUR DISTRICT
IS LOCATED IN ONE OF THE LOWEST
FUNDED CELL BUS AND US RECEIVE
LESS FUNDING THAN OTHER
DISTRICTS. FOR NO APPARENT
REASON. HAVE A CHARTER SCHOOL
THAT ENROLLS FAR FEWER SPECIAL
EDUCATION STUDENTS THAN THE
TRADITIONAL DISTRICT PART OF IT
IS BECAUSE THEY FEEL THAT THE
SERVICES THAT TRADITIONAL
DISTRICT IS PROVIDING FOR THEM
ARE ARE. WHAT THEY WANT?
THE ENROLLMENT OF OUR CHARTER IS
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN
STUDENTS IN GRADES. KINDERGARTEN
THROUGH TWELFTH.
AND THEY HAVE LESS THAN TWO
PERCENT SPECIAL EDUCATION.
STUDENTS IN ADDITION TO THE
CHARTER ARE SMALL DISTRICT
CONSISTS OF TWO SCHOOLS AND
ELEMENTARY THAT SERVES TKD.
THROUGH FFTH GRADE WITH FIVE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY STUDENTS AND
THEN A SIX THROUGH EIGHTH.
MIDDLE SCHOOL SERVING TWO
HUNDRED FORTY ONE STUDENTS. WE
HAVE FIFTY THREE PERCENT ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS NINETY TWO
PERCENT SOCIALLY ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED OUR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES PERCENTAGES
FOURTEEN PERCENT.
OUR AND DUPLICATED COUNT IS
NINETY SIX PERCENT AND WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED
STUDENTS ENROLLED IN OUR
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS FOR WHICH WE
RECEIVE NO FUNDING.
ALONG WITH SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION WE ARE
COMMITTED TO ALL STUDENTS MOST
ESPECIALLY THOSE. IN NEED OF
SPECIALIZED SERVICES AS A RESULT
OF LEARNING DISABILITIES. THESE
ARE OUR KIDS SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS OPERATE AS A FAMILY.
EVERYONE KNOWS EVERYONE.
YOU FOR RECOGNIZING THE NEED FOR
A DEEPER LOOK INTO SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND FOR INVITING ME TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS HEARING ON
BEHALF OF SMALL DISTRICTS LIKE
MINE.
IT IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US ALL
TO LEARN FROM ONE ANOTHER.
SMALL DISTRICTS BECAUSE OF THEIR
SIZE DIMINISHED CAPACITY AND
OFTEN LACK OF ACCESS TO
RESOURCES. ARE IMPACTED BY
CHANGES IN LAW REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS AND INCREASE COSTS
AT A MUCH GREATER LEVEL LEVEL
THAN LARGER DISTRICTS. NOWHERE
IS THAT MORE EVIDENT THAN IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION. WERE DOING
SOME THINGS WELL RELATIVE TO
SERVING STUDENTS WITH
EXCEPTIONAL NEEDS BUT WE ALSO
HAVE SOME AREAS THAT NEED SOME
WORK.
WE ARE MUCH BETTER AT EARLIER
IDENTIFICATION FOR EXAMPLE WHICH
IS WONDERFUL BUT THE SYSTEM IS
NOT PREPARED FOR THE NEEDS NOR
THE COSTS.
I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT SEVERAL
AREAS A PARTICULAR CHALLENGE FOR
SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS TRYING
OUR BEST TO SERVE OUR STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES.
EQUALIZATION PRESCHOOL ACCESS
LOW INCIDENCE DISABILITIES
TRANSPORTATION AND CONTRACTING
WITH PRIVATE PROVIDERS.
EQUALIZATION FOR THIS EXAMPLE IS
IS A VERY SERIOUS HURDLE BY
LOCAL CELL PLAYING STANISLAUS
COUNTY IS ONE OF THE LOWEST
FUNDED IN THE STATE AS I SAID
BEFORE. AND THERE APPEARS TO BE
NO REASON FOR THOSE FUNDING
LEVELS.
MANY DISTRICTS ARE LIKE MINE ARE
IN INVESTING IN OFFERING
PRESCHOOL SERVICES WITHOUT STATE
FUNDING. EARLY SUPPORT IS KEY
BUT IT DOES COME AT A COST TO
THE DISTRICTS.
LOW INCIDENCE DISABILITIES LIKE
LARGER DISTRICTS WE HAVE MORE
STUDENTS BEING IDENTIFIED WITH
LOW INCIDENCE DISABILITIES SUCH
AS AUTISM. EMOTIONAL DISTURBANCE
AND WE ARE ALSO SEEN GREATER
EXTREMES IN BEHAVIOR.
IN BUTTE COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE THE
RATE OF STUDENTS IDENTIFIED AS
AUTISTIC IS DOUBLE THE STATE
LEVEL AND THEY HAVE SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT MORE EMOTIONALLY
DISTURBED STUDENTS THAN THE
STATE AVERAGE. ONE CAUSE MAY
VERY WELL BE AS A RESULT OF NOT
BEING ABLE TO FIND EARLY
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS I MEAN.
I'M SURE THERE ARE MANY OTHER
FACTORS.
MEETING THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS
WITH LOW INCIDENCE DISABILITIES
CAN BE CHALLENGING FOR SMALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT FOR SMALL DISTRICTS TO
FIND SPECIALISTS WHEN THEY'RE
ONLY A FEW STUDENTS NEEDING
SERVICES WITHIN THAT DISTRICT.
PARTICULARLY IN THE AREA OF
SPEECH AND LANGUAGE.
PRIVATE PLACEMENT. IS ALSO A
HUGE ISSUE FOR SMALL DISTRICTS
THIS CAN RUN INTO THE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS. AN STC CLASS FOR
EXAMPLE TO AIDS AND A TEACHER
OUT WITH LESS THAN PERHAPS THREE
STUDENTS IN THE CLASS CAN RUN
INTO THE COST OF ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IN THE CASE OF TWO SMALL
DISTRICTS OUT OF SIX MILLION NOW
YOU'LL BUDGET THEIR SPECIAL
EDUCATION COSTS WERE IN EXCESS
OF ONE MILLION. AND ANOTHER OF
FOUR MILLION BUDGET THEIR
SPECIAL EDUCATION COSTS WERE
WELL OVER FOUR HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND.
RELIANCE ON PRIVATE CONTRACTORS
SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS DO NOT DO
NOT HAVE THE CAPACITY TO HIRE
MANY SPECIALISTS. AND THIS MAKES
THIS VERY RELIANT ON CONTRACTORS
THE INCREASE OVERALL OF THE
NUMBER OF CHILDREN IDENTIFIED ON
THE AUTISM SPECTRUM COMBINED
WITH AN AVAILABILITY OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS OR RESOURCE
IS A SMALL DISTRICT IS LEFT WITH
HAVING TO CONTRACT OUT. MORE AND
MORE AT THE MERCY OF WHATEVER
CONTRACTOR CHARGES AND WHAT
SERVICES THEY'RE ABLE TO
DELIVER.
THE LACK OF EQUITY ONE STUDENT
HAVING AN AIDE FOR EXAMPLE PAID
BY A PARENT'S INSURANCE WHILE
ANOTHER STUDENT DOES NOT HAVE
THAT LUXURY.
AND THE MORE RESTRICTIVE
ENVIRONMENT SUCH AS OUTSIDE
INVOLVEMENT CREATES IT IS NOT IN
THE BEST INTEREST OF STUDENTS
NOR HIS OR HER CLASSMATES.
TRANSPORTATION WE ALL FACE.
PARTICULAR CHALLENGES WHEN IT
COMES TO TRANSPORTATION
ESPECIALLY FOR OUR RURAL
DISTRICTS WHILE WE WOULD ALWAYS
RATHER SERVE STUDENTS OURSELVES
WE MAY HAVE TO UTILIZE AS ALFA.
TRANSPORTATION FROM ONE OF MY
STUDENTS AS AN EXAMPLE IS
PROVIDED OUR DISTRICT AND
EXPENSIVE WELL OVER SEVENTEEN
ANYWHERE BETWEEN SEVENTEEN AND
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
ONE ZERO WE CHARGES ITS
DISTRICTS TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DOLLARS A ILE.
WITH THE BUDGET CONSTRAINTS
STUDENTS ARE OFTEN SUBJECTED TO
VERY LONG RIDES WHICH IS
STRESSFUL ON THEM AND THEIR
FAMILIES THERE ON THIS BUS FOR
HOURS.
WORKING WITH OUR CELL BY SMALL
pMORE RELIANT ON OURSELF AS IN
COUNTY OFFICES FOR SERVICES. WE
CAN'T PROVIDE IN MANY CASES
SERVICES FOR EMOTIONALLY
DISTURBED STUDENTS MUST BE
PROVIDED BY OUR COUNTY SELF UP.
HOWEVER WE ARE RELIANT ON THEIR
CAPACITY AND MAY HAVE TO WAIT
FOR SERVICES THIS IS NOT HELPFUL
OR APPROPRIATE FOR THE STUDENT.
THE ANNUAL SERVICES FOR ONE
CHILD CAN VERY. EASILY FROM
THIRTY TO FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
WELL WE HAVE A NEED FOR STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACROSS
THE STATE SMALL DISTRICTS HAVE A
GREATER STRUGGLE TO SERVE OUR
STUDENTS. BECAUSE WE HAVE EVEN
LESS ACCESS TO SERVICES OR
PROVIDERS.
ALSO IN MANY RURAL AREAS
JUVENILE HOUSE OF CLOSED DUE TO
THE LACK OF SUPPORT AND
UNFORTUNATELY FOR SOME OF OUR
STUDENTS THAT WAS THE ONLY PLACE
THEY HAD ACCESS TO SERVICES. IT
WOULD BE WONDERFUL TO HAVE SOME
SORT OF REGIONAL SUPPORT SYSTEM
IN PLACE.
IN SMALL DISTRICTS OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE OUR FAMILY WE
DON'T JUST KNOW OUR STUDENTS WE
KNOW THEIR PARENTS THEIR
SIBLINGS COUSINS OFTEN
GRANDPARENTS AND IN MANY CASES
WE MAY BE RELATED.
THEY ARE CHILDREN AND WE WANT TO
GIVE THEM THE SERVICES THEY NEED
WE ALSO WANT TO ENSURE THAT WE
ARE PROVIDING OUR TEACHERS AND
STAFF WITH THE SUPPORT THEY
DESERVE. AND ALL OUR STUDENTS
WITH THE EDUCATION THEY ARE
ENTITLED TO AND DESERVE IT. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ON THESE EFFORTS THANK
YOU ALL FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION THIS MORNING.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT MUST FEEL
ABBAS.
GOOD MORNING.
MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ADAM REVEAL OF US AND
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE SANTA
CLARA.
LITIGATION LOCAL PLAN AREAS OR
SELFLESS WHICH RESULT SERVE OVER
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND STUDENTS WITH
EXCEPTIONAL NEEDS AND IS
COMPRISED OF TWENTY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND THE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION. I
FIRST CENTERS SPECIAL EDUCATION
BECAUSE I WAS THERE MY BEST
FRIEND AND MY COUSIN. BEING
EXCLUDED FROM SCHOOL I WITNESSED
THE BATTLES OF THE FRUSTRATIONS
THEY AND THEIR FAMILIES FACE SO
THAT THEY COULD HAVE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES AS THEIR PEERS. I
STILL FEEL THE FRUSTRATION AND I
SEE HOW HARD EDUCATION
PROFESSIONALS STUDENTS OF FAMILY
STRIVES FOR EQUITY AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE FOR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES. TODAY I WOULD LIKE
TO TALK ABOUT SPECIAL EDUCATION
FUNDING AS IT RELATES TO
EQUALIZATION OF FUNDING. FUNDING
OF SPECIAL EDUCATION AT
PRESCHOOL AND FUNNY FOR STUDENTS
WITH SIGNIFICANT DISABILITIES.
IT'S BEEN OVER A DECADE SINCE
CALIFORNIA ADDED ANY MEANINGFUL
FUNDING INCREASES FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION EVEN THOUGH SCHOOL
DISTRICTS BASIC GROWING FINDING
NEED TO PROVIDE STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES AGES ZERO TO TWENTY
TWO. A FREE AND APPROPRIATE
PUBLIC EDUCATION. THE CURRENT
SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING MODEL
ALSO CALLED AB SIXTY TWO FUNDING
MODEL IS BASED ON THE AVERAGE
DAILY ATTENDANCE OF KATIE TWELVE
STUDENTS. HOWEVER.
WHEN A B. SIX THIRTY WAS
IMPLEMENTED THE FUNDING WAS
BASED ON PREVIOUS SPECIAL
EDUCATION EXPENDITURES BY SCHOOL
AGENCIES WHICH VERY THROUGHOUT
THE STATE WHICH CAUSED AN EQUAL
FUNDING. I OVERSEE FIVE SELFLESS
AND THE BASE FUNDING RANGES FROM
FOUR HUNDRED NINETY SIX DOLLARS
SECOND LOWEST IN THE STATE TO
SIX HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX
DOLLARS SIX HIGHEST IN THE
STATE.
THIS MEANS THAT FOR EVERY
STUDENT ROLLED IN SCHOOL WHEN
JUST RECEIVED FOUR HUNDRED
NINETY SIX FOR PEOPLE DOLLARS IN
THE OTHER DISTRICT RECEIVES SIX
HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX PEOPLE
DOLLARS TOWARDS OUR SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING. THIS
TRANSLATES INTO THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IN DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE
EDUCATION STUDENT THE FUNDING
EQUALIZATION OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION AFFECTS ALL DISTRICTS
INCLUDING BASIC A DISTRICT SINCE
I HAVE BOTH. ADA BASE LCF
INVESTIGATE DISTRICTS IN MYSELF
AS WORSENING THE SITUATION IS
DECLINING ENROLLMENT. PAIRED
WITH THE INCREASING ENROLLMENT
OF STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
WITH HIGHER LEVELS OF NEEDS AND
GROWING COSTS AS A RESULT OF THE
WAY THE STATE FUND SPECIAL
EDUCATION EACH YEAR. WE ENROL
MORE STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
AND EACH YEAR WE RECEIVE LESS
FUNDING TO SERVE THEM.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL EDUCATION
TASK FORCE OUTLINED REFORMS
NECESSARY FOR SUCCESSFUL SPECIAL
EDUCATION SYSTEM INCLUDING A
CALL FOR ADDITIONAL SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING. THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
HAS CONSISTENTLY RECOMMENDED
THAT THE LEGISLATURE PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL STATE FUNDING TO
LEVEL UP ITSELF WAS EIGHTY SIX
SO TO BASE FUNDING RATES.
EQUITY INADEQUACY OF FUNDING FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS IS OF
PARAMOUNT IMPORTANCE STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES HAVE LOWER
GRADUATION RATES HIGHER
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES LOWER
ATTENDANCE RATES AND HIGHER
EDUCATION POST SECONDARY
TRAINING PROGRAMS. IN REVIEWING
THE DASHBOARD DATA NEARLY TWO
THIRDS OF THE DISTRICTS
DIFFERENTIAL ASSISTANCE NEEDED
SUPPORT WITH THEIR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES. INCREASE FUNDING
WOULD ASSIST DISTRICTS WORKED TO
IMPROVE THE ACHIEVEMENT OF
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES BY
PROVIDING THE CURRICULAR
INSTRUCTIONAL SUPPORTS IN THE
LEAST RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENT.
UNDER FEDERAL LAW DISTRICTS MUST
PROVIDE SERVICES FOR
PRESCHOOLERS WITH DISABILITIES
BEING H. THREE IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN TO SUCCEED
NINETY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL GRANTS FOR PRESCHOOL. NO
STATE FUNDS FOR PRESCHOOL HIS
ALLEGED CATION AND SPENT FOUR
HUNDRED NINETY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR SERVICES FOR PRE SCHOOL AGE
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT INTENSIVE
EARLY INTERVENTION SERVICES SUCH
AS PRESCHOOL SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASES STUDENT WITH
DISABILITIES ULTIMATE
EDUCATIONAL SUCCESS. ALLOW
STUDENTS TO BE EDUCATED IN THE
LEAST RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENT.
PRESCHOOL PILOT PROJECT WITH THE
INCLUSION COLLABORATIVE AND IT
JUST BECAMEMY COUNTY EIGHTY
PERCENT OF THE STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES WHO ATTENDED THE
PILOT PRESCHOOL WENT INTO AN
INCLUSIVE KINDERGARTNERS GENERAL
EDUCATION KINDERGARTEN WITH
SUPPORT. ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA RESEARCH A REFERRAL
NETWORK IN THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDCARE PORTFOLIO IN THE
CHILDREN NOW DATA BUT ONLY IGHT
TO TEN PERCENT THREE TO FOUR
YEAR OLDS RECEIVE HEAD START OR
STEEP PRESCHOOL SERVICES. THREE
OUT OF EVERY FOUR CHILDREN WHO
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR STATE
PRESCHOOLER HEAD START ARE NOT
ABLE TO ACCESS THESE PROGRAMS
YOU TO LIMITED CAPACITY ISSUES.
PROVIDING FUNDING TO THE AB
SIXTY TWO SYSTEM FOR
PRESCHOOLERS WITH DISABILITIES
WILL SUPPORT THIS TYPE OF
SUCCESSFUL EARLY INTERVENTION
PROGRAM.
THE CURRENT AMOUNT OF FUNDING
FOR STUDENTS WITH SIGNIFICANT
HIGH COST DISABILITIES SUCH AS
AUTISM BLINDNESS DEAFNESS OR
SEVERE ORTHOPEDIC IMPAIRMENTS IS
FAR BELOW THE AMOUNT NECESSARY
TO PROVIDE THESE JEANS WITH A
FREE APPROPRIATE PUBLIC
EDUCATION. BY JUST ACCEPTING A
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY PERCENT
INCREASE IN STUDENTS WITH
MULTIPLE DISABILITIES A FIFTY
PERCENT INCREASE IN STUDENTS WHO
ARE HARD OF HEARING A TWO
HUNDRED PERCENT INCREASE IN
STUDENTS WITH AUTISM OVER THE
PAST TEN YEARS.
THESE STUDENTS ARE ALL OFTEN
NEED SIGNIFICANT SUPPORT SUCH AS
ADDITIONAL SERVICES EQUIPMENT
AND STAFF TO MEET THEIR
EDUCATIONAL AND RELATED SERVICES
NEEDS. THE CURRENT LEVEL OF
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING FOR
STUDENTS WITH SIGNIFICANT
DISABILITIES IS FOUR HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SEVEN DOLLARS PER STUDENT
WHILE THE AVERAGE COSTS ARE
ALWAYS HIGHER.
AN INCREASE IN FUNDING FOR
STUDENTS REQUIRING SUBSTANTIAL
SUPPORTS WOULD ALLOW DISTRICTS
PROVIDE THE STUDENTS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE ADEQUATE
PROGRESS THE TECHNOLOGY TO
SUPPORT MANY MORE STUDENTS WITH
LOW INCIDENCE DISABILITIES IS
QUICKLY ADVANCING BUT CAN BE
EXPENSIVE. HAVING THESE DEVICES
FOR THESE STUDENTS IS AN EQUITY
ISSUE SINCE WITHOUT SUCH SUPPORT
MANY OF THE STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES WOULD BE DEPRIVED
OF AN AVENUE TO SUCCESS. IN
CLOSING I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE TIME AND
WILLINGNESS TO HEAR FROM MYSELF
IN THE DISTRICT I REPRESENT.
YOU APPRECIATE YOUR PERSPECTIVE.
OKAY WARD WERE NEXT IN HERE FROM
JEAN CHRISTOPHE GOES WHO'S THAT
CBO OF SAN MARINO CITY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND ALSO.
MORNING CASTRO HAD TWO ICE
BREATH THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SOME THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE. AS WAS STATED ON THE CBO
FOR SAMMY DINO CITY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT I'VE BEEN
SERVING STUDENTS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA FOR TWENTY ONE YEARS.
SALMON AND DINO WAS A LARGE
URBAN DISTRICT LOCATED BETWEEN
LOS ANGELES AND PALM SPRINGS. A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT OUR AMAZING AND
RESILIENT STUDENTS WE SERVE
FIFTY THREE THOUSAND STUDENTS.
IN SEVENTY FOUR OF OUR SCHOOLS
AND THIRTEEN CHARTER SCHOOLS. WE
HAVE IT ON DUPLICATE ACCOUNT OF
NINETY PERCENT. ARE HISPANIC
POPULATION COMPRISES SEVENTY
FIVE PERCENT OF OUR STUDENTS
AFRICAN AMERICAN TWELVE PERCENT.
WHITE SIX PERCENT ARE FOSTER
YOUTH IS ALMOST ONE PERCENT AND
SPECIAL EDUCATION IS.
THIRTEEN POINT THREE PERCENT IT
IS MUCH LOWER IN OUR CHARTER
SCHOOLS.
.
AND NUMBER OF SPECIAL SPECIAL
NEEDS STUDENTS ARE INCREASING IN
OUR COMMUNITY AND THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND WE KNOW THAT
INVESTMENT IN OUR STUDENTS ALL
OF OUR STUDENTS IS. THE BEST
THING WE CAN DO FOR THEIR FUTURE
SUCCESS ALSO THE COMPLEXITIES OF
THE DISABILITIES IS INCREASING
WHICH REQUIRES HIGHER LEVELS OF
SERVICES. AT INCREASING COST OF
INVESTING INTO THEIR FUTURE.
ADDITIONALLY WE UNDERSTAND THE
IMPACT OF TRAUMA AND LEARNING ON
THE BRAIN. DUE TO EXPOSURE TO
CRIME AND HIGH POVERTY IN OUR
DISTRICT WE KNOW THAT OUR
STUDENTS DEAL WITH TRAUMA WHICH
AFFECTS LEARNING AND REQUIRES.
THAT TIER ONE INVESTMENT AND
THAT'S A BIG NEED IN OUR
DISTRICT WHERE WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO EDUCATE ALL. ADULTS
THAT INTERACT WITH OUR STUDENTS
WE ALSO HAVE HIGH MOBILITY IN
OUR COMMUNITY. SPC USD ARE
DISTRICT HAS BUILT ONE OF THE
LOWEST EIGHTY SIX OH TWO
FINDINGS WHICH EXACERBATES THE
DISPROPORTIONATE FUNDING
DISTRIBUTED FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION. AND THE HIGH NEED OF
SUPPORT AND SERVICES TO OUR
KIDS.
WE NEED TO ADDRESS HOW WE
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR GROWTH IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION YOU'VE HEARD
FROM A NUMBER OF FOLKS THIS
MORNING WHEN I GIVE YOU A REAL
LIFE EXAMPLE. WE DECREASE THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE STUDENTS
THIS YEAR IN OUR TOTAL
POPULATION. THAT'S ABOUT A FOUR
MILLION DOLLAR LOSS IN LC FF
WHEN THEY APPLIED. ATTENDANCE
RATE.
THEN.
WE ALSO LOST TWO HUNDRED TEN
THOUSAND ENTER AB SIX OH TWO
FUNDING BECAUSE IT'S BASED ON
OUR ENROLLMENT.
BUT OUR SPECIAL ED POPULATION
GREW BY ONE HUNDRED AND NINETY
EIGHT STUDENTS SO THAT'S FOUR
POINT TWO MILLION LESS. TO
PROVIDE SOME SUPPORT FOR
MULTIPLE NOBLE STUDENTS.
ADDITIONALLY OUR PRESCHOOL
SPECIAL EDUCATION POPULATION
GREW ABOUT SIXTY STUDENTS OVER
THE LAST TWO YEARS CONTINUES TO
GROW. AT WITH VERY LITTLE
FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE GROWTH
AND NEEDS OF OUR YOUNGEST
SCHOLARS AND YOU'VE HEARD. THE
RESEARCH ABOUT EARLY
INTERVENTION AND THAT IS WHERE
WE REALLY NEED TO MAKE THAT
INVESTMENT. AT A MINIMUM THE
STATE SHOULD PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
THE GROWTH IN SPECIAL ED THROUGH
AB SIX SO TOO HAD WE NOT LOSS AT
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND. YOU KNOW
IT'S ADDITIONAL DOLLARS TO SERVE
OUR YOUNGEST KIDS.
JUST AS THE NOTRE DISTRICT
CONTRIBUTES TO SPECIAL ED OR
INCREASES VARY BETWEEN THREE AND
THREE AND TEN MILLION PER YEAR
WE WILL BE ADDING THREE MILLION
IN POSITIONS FOR NEXT YEAR'S OUR
EARLY.
SECTIONS.
SOME OF THE THINGS OUR DISTRICTS
DOING TO ADDRESS.
SPECIAL EDUCATION WE HAVE
REALLY STRONG MULTIPLE TIERED
SUPPORT SYSTEM SPECIFICALLY IN
THE INTERVENTION AND SMALL GROUP
INSTRUCTION THAT TIER ONE IS
WHERE WE NEED TO FOCUS A LOT OF.
OF.
OUR RESOURCES AND THAT IS
TRAINING FOR ALL ADULTS THAT ARE
WORKING WITH THEIR KID DOES NOT
JUST SPECIAL EDUCATION.
WE NEED MORE.
AND ALSO OUR INSTRUCTIONAL
AIDES AS WELL. WE ARE WORKING.
CONTRACTING WITH WESTJET TO
PROVIDE A FULL PROGRAM
EVALUATION AS OUR GOAL IS TO
DELIVER SERVICES MORE
EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY. AND
WERE ALSO PREPARING OUR STUDENTS
FOR LIFE AFTER K. TWELVE
EDUCATION SO THAT THEY ARE SELF
SUFFICIENT REGARDING THEIR
DISABILITY. SO THOSE ARE SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT WE'RE WORKING ON
AS WELL AS THE APPROPRIATE
TRANSITION TRANSITION AND
STUDENTS BACK TO GENERAL IT.
WE DO HAVE ALSO VERY STRONG
RELATED. EDUCATIONAL RELATED
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
VERY STRONG MENTAL HEALTH
COMPONENTS AND.
WE HAVE A STRONG CRISIS
RESPONSE TEAM WHICH IS ESSENTIAL
IN OUR COMMUNITY SO THAT OUR
STUDENTS ARE IN A IN A PLACE
WHERE THEY CAN.
TEACHING AND LEARNING CAN OCCUR.
WE HAVE SEEN HUGE INCREASING
DEMANDS VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT
YOU'RE HEARING HERE SPEECH AND
LANGUAGE IMPAIRMENT HAS DOUBLED
AUTISM OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
WE HAVE A GROWTH IN AUTISM ABOUT
FIFTY STUDENTS A YEAR EIGHTY SIX
THIS YEAR ACTUALLY. OTHER HEALTH
IMPAIRMENT.
.
GROWTH AS WELL.
BUT OUR PRESCHOOL AGE WERE SEEN
ULTRA HIGH INCREASE IN AUTISM
SPEECH AND OTHER HEALTH
IMPAIRMENTS.
SO SOME OF THE STRATEGIES THAT
THE STATE COULD TAKE IS TO
PROVIDE STATE SUPPORT THROUGH
OUR EXISTING FUNDING SOURCES WE
HAVE EIGHTY SIX SO TO ONLY HAVE
A LC ABOUT. ALL DISTRICTS ARE
DEALING WITH THE COST THE RISING
COST OF SPECIAL EDUCATION AND
KNOWING THAT THAT INVESTMENT IN
OUR STUDENTS IS GOING TO PAY OFF
IN THE LONG RUN TO BE. REALLY
HELP OUR OUR KIDS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL.
WE WE NEED TO INTERVENE IN THE
EARLIEST STAGES OF OUR
CHILDREN'S LIVES. AND.
FUNDING TO SUPPORT THIS WILL GO
A LONG WAY. CONTINUOUS
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
TRAINING FOR BOTH GENERAL AND
SPECIAL ED TEACHERS AND
ADMINISTRATORS OF TALKED ABOUT
THAT ALREADY.
.
AND I THINK YOU KNOW I'VE
ALREADY TALKED ABOUT EARLY
INTERVENTION EVERYONE HAS TALKED
ABOUT THAT BUT WHEN WE LOOK AT
TEACHERS ENTERING THE
PROFESSION.
THE GENERAL ED TEACHER IS IT'S
SO IMPORTANT THAT TIER ONE
SUPPORT AND WHEN YOU THINK OF
ALL OF THE THINGS A NEW TEACHER
HAS TO BALANCE IN THE CLASSROOM.
WE LOOK TO IS THEY'RE PAID
APPRENTICESHIPS AND OTHER THINGS
THEY CAN WORK WITH EXPERT
TEACHERS BEFORE THEY TAKE ON.
THEIR OWN CLASSROOM IT'S A LOT
TO MANAGE BUT THAT'S THE BEST
PLACE TO START WITH THE
INTERVENTION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
THAT'S CERTAINLY TRUE.
THANK YOU.
I'M. OKAY.
ALSO MORE COMPACT QUESTIONS FOR
YOU COMING UP BUT. NOW WE HAVE A
GREAT CHANCE TO HEAR FROM.
A TEACHER. ESPECIALLY RESOURCE
TEACHER FROM DUBLIN UNIFIED BY
ROBBIE CRATES.
WE'RE WE'RE REALLY GLAD TO HAVE
YOU HERE MISS GRADES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ROBBIE
KITES AND I'M A MIDDLE SCHOOL
SPECIAL ED TEACHER IN DUBLIN.
PRESENT AT THE DUBLIN TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND VICE CHAIR OF
SPECIAL INTEREST THE TI.
I AM I AM THINKING FOR INVITING
ME TO TALK ABOUT THE REALITIES
AND IMPACT OF UNDERFUNDED
SPECIAL EDUCATION FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF A CLASSROOM
TEACHER. MY TEACHING CAREER OF
NINETEEN YEARS IT'S BEEN ONE
MONTH WITH A FOUNDATION OF
PASSION DEDICATION AND ADVOCACY.
ON THE DAUGHTER OF TWO
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC EDUCATORS WHO
HAVE INSPIRED ME ON MY PATH
TODAY. I STARTED MY SPECIAL
ARTWORK IN FIFTH GRADE WHEN I
APPLIED TO BE A READING
CLASSROOM BODY FOR SPECIAL DAY
CLASS. TWO DAYS A WEEK MY TIME
IN THAT CLASS OF THE AMAZING
TEACHERS THAT I HAD AT EDISON
ELEMENTARY IN ALAMEDA OPENED MY
EYES TO A DIVERSITY OF STUDENTS
SOME OF WHO I STILL CALL FRIENDS
TODAY.
MY TEACHING SCHEDULE WHEN I
FIRST STARTED INCLUDED A TEST
PREP A MENTOR TEACHER WHO MET
ME.
AND WORKED ON ALL MY A PIECE A
COOPERATIVE CO TEACHER SOMEONE
WHO ASSISTED ME WITH STUDENT
COUNSELING I WAS SUPPORTED.
NINETEEN YEARS AGO AS A NEW
TEACHER I DID NOT KNOW THAT
THERE WOULD BE A HUGE SHORTAGE
IN SPECIAL EDUCATION I WAS
EXTREMELY NAIVE. THAT WAS MY
NORMAL AS THE LEAD TEACHER FOR
MY DEPARTMENT NOW I DO NOT HAVE
THE SUPPORT AND RESOURCES TO
GIVE MY NEW TEACHERS. I CAN
COACH AND MENTOR BUT THE TIME
AND RESOURCES ARE NOT ALLOCATED
AS THEY WERE NINETEEN YEARS AGO.
I'M STILL IN MY SAME TEACHING
POSITION OUT MY SAME SCHOOL BUT
THE REST OF MY TEAM TURNS OVER
EVERY THREE YEARS ON AVERAGE.
THIS IS A CHALLENGING TEACHING
ASSIGNMENT. DURING MY FIRST TWO
YEARS I HAD TO LEARN FIRST HAND
WHAT THE COURSE WORK DOES NOT
PREPARE YOU FOR THE REALITY OF
THE DAY TO DAY GAPS IN SUPPORT.
AND THE BALANCING OF TEACHING
WITH THE SPECIAL ED PROCESS.
THEY'RE ALWAYS FISCAL FISCAL
CONSTRAINTS THAT IMPACT
ESPECIALLY TEACHER TO SPECIAL
EDUCATION CLASSROOM. BEFORE I
OPEN THE DOORS ON THE FIRST DAY
OF SCHOOL THERE WERE GAPS AND
RESOURCES FOR EXAMPLE. LAST FALL
MY DISTRICT WAS GOING THROUGH
THE PROCESS OF PURCHASING A NEW
CURRICULAR ADOPTION. I KNEW THAT
WE NEEDED THE SUPPLEMENTAL
RESOURCES TO ENSURE THAT MY
STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO THE
STANDARDS ALIGNED INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS THE GENERAL EDUCATION
STUDENTS HALF. HOWEVER THOSE
RESOURCES WERE NOT PROVIDED AS
PART OF THE PILOT. SOMETHING AS
SIMPLE AS ORDERING NEW MATERIALS
FROM THE APPROVED ADOPTION IS
EXPENSIVE BECAUSE THE GENERAL TO
TO RECEIVE THE CLASS SAT IN A
TEACHER'S EDITION. HOWEVER IS A
SPECIAL ED TEACHER I NEED
MULTIPLE GRADE LEVELS OF BOTH
THE TEACHER AND STUDENT
RESOURCES. AT GENERAL EDUCATION
TEACHERS STUDENTS ARE COUNTED
BUT MARTY'S OUR NEEDS ARE NOT
FACTORED INTO THE BELT. I ASKED
MY SCHOOL TEAM FOR AN ANALOGY
THAT PAINTS A CLEAR PICTURE OF
HOW IT IS TO DESCRIBE US AND
WHAT WE DO AND THE PHRASE
DUMPSTER DIVERS WAS THE BEST
IMAGE. WE LOOK WE USE AND FIND
SOMETHING AND WHAT OTHERS DO NOT
NEED TO SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS
SUCCESS HOW MANY CLASSROOMS AT
MY SCHOOL HAVE AN ALTERNATIVE
CURRICULUM. THAT NOT ONE PERSON
CAN ASSURE WILL BE THERE ON DAY
ONE. TOMMY DEPARTMENT SOLICIT
DONATIONS FOR THEIR BASIC
CURRICULAR NEEDS WHAT WE HAVE
COME TO KNOW IS THE REALIZATION
THAT IF WE DO NOT DO THIS WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE WHAT WE NEED ON
DAY ONE. AND IN NINETEEN YEARS
HAVE BEEN AT MY SCHOOL WE'VE
SEEN A RAPID INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS WITH AUTISM
AND OUR STUDENTS WITH EMOTIONAL
DISTURBANCE IP'S. THE REQUIRED
MORE COORDINATED SUPPORT AND
SERVICES YET ACCESS TO THOSE IS
CHALLENGING. WE NEED TO ENSURE
WE HAVE ADEQUATE SPECIALISTS
COUNSELORS BEHAVIOR SUPPORTS
INCLUSION SUPPORT PSYCHOLOGIST
AND TRAINING FOR THE GENERAL
TEACHERS. THAT YOU'VE HEARD
ABOUT BEFORE HE TOOK TO BE A FEW
OF THE ESSENTIAL RESOURCES FOR
STUDENTS AS DETERMINED BY THEIR
IP. OUR PROCESS IS THE TEAM IS
TO LOOK AT WHAT WE NOW HAVE HOW
WE CAN FULLY FUNDED PROGRAM THAT
CAME INTO EXISTENCE IN NINETEEN
FIVE OR NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE.
THAT WAS NEVER BEEN FULLY FUNDED
WE LOOK TO THE DISTRICT FOR
HELP.
WITH WHAT WE HAVE IN OUR OWN
COMMUNITY AND THEN WE GOT OR
SOMETHING.
MY DISTRICT IS ONE OF THE MOST
RAPIDLY GROWING DISTRICTS IN THE
STATE IF THE SUPPLY OF MONEY AND
ALL THE. ALL THAT GOES WITH IT
IS NOT KEEPING UP WITH THE
STUDENT DEMAND. EVEN THE EVEN
WITH THE GROWTH WE ARE
EXPERIENCING SPECIAL EDUCATION
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS CONTINUE TO
GENERATE MORE CHALLENGES TO
ADDRESS THE CHRONIC GAPS IN THE
FUNDING NEED. NEEDED TO INSERT
IT IS DONE SUCCESSFULLY. HOW DO
WE ENSURE THAT ALL TEACHERS ARE
TRAINED IN THE VARIOUS
DISABILITIES AND THE SUPPORTS
NEEDED FOR THE STUDENTS WE
SERVE?
HOW DO WE TREAT A TEACHER WHO
ALREADY HAVE THE CASE LOAD OF A
HUNDRED FIFTY STUDENT CONTACTS
BAILEY? HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT
LEGAL OBLIGATIONS ARE MET
WITHOUT THE TIME THE TRAINING
THE STAFF THE CURRICULAR
RESOURCES TO DO SO? WE HAVE A
LITTLE TIME FOR TRAINING AND
MINIMAL IF ANY RESOURCES ARE SET
ASIDE FOR TEACHER DRIVEN
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT. WE
HAVE NO FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR
THE NEED FOR INCREASED AID
SUPPORT TO ACCOMPANY THE
STUDENTS TO THE GENERAL
EDUCATION CLASSROOM. SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS ARE EXPECTED
TO MAKE IT HAPPEN WITHOUT
INCREASED SUPPORT TO DO SO.
WHEN THERE IS A GAP IN
PROGRAMMING A BREAK IN THE
CONTINUUM OF SERVICE A SHORTAGE
OF STAFF MISSING CURRICULUM OR
CHANGES TO PROGRAM DELIVERY.
THEY ALL SHARE ONE THING IN
COMMON A LACK OF FUNDING DESPITE
THESE HEART HURDLES WE MUST
CONTINUE AND NOT LOSE FOCUS. ON
MEETING THE EDUCATIONAL NEEDS OF
OUR STUDENTS. I STARTED THIS
MORNING SHARING WITH YOU THE
LITTLE PATH I TOOK TO BECOME A
VETERAN SPECIAL ED TEACHER. AND
LIKE TO I WOULD LIKE TO CONCLUDE
WITH A STATEMENT THE CURRENT
FUNDING FOR SPECIAL IT'S NOT
ADEQUATE THIS MUST IMPROVE AND
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL
OF OUR STUDENTS SHOULD BE JUST
THAT FOR ALL. THANK YOU AND I
WILL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU ALL HAVE.
THESE KINDS OF MUSIC YOUR SENSE.
YOU KNOW WE WE'VE BEEN LOOKING
AT HOW THE THE FINDING IS
ACTUALLY INCREASE BUT YOUR
BURDEN HAS INCREASED AS WELL AS
YOUR SENSES JUST A LOT MORE KIDS
TO. TAKE CARE OF WITH MORE
SEVERE NEEDS IS THAT.
WHAT'S HAPPENING OR IN MY
PARTICULAR STUDY ABSOLUTELY AN
INCREASE IN PERSON TO
GENERALIZE.
YEAH CRIME.
ARE THEY GIVEN MUCH IS BECAUSE
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A CHANCE FOR
DISCUSSION AFTER THE REST THE
PANELS GET TO TESTIFY. NEXT
WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO HAVE A
MARKET HENRY. WHO IS A PARA
PROFESSIONAL FROM TWIN RIVERS
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND WE
KNOW THAT THE PARIS AND A
PLAYING A REALLY IMPORTANT ROLE
IN THE PROVISION OF SPECIAL ED?
SERVICES ON THE GROUND IN OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND WE'RE
REALLY PLEASED TO HAVE YOU HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BEFORE I BEGIN AT THE SERGEANT
DOES HAVE COPIES IF YOU HAD A WE
GOT IN THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT TO BE. THE MORNING CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF MY NAME IS MARK
THE PENRY AND I WORK AS A
SPECIAL EDUCATION PARENT
EDUCATOR I WORKED AS A SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
EDUCATOR FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS
ON TWENTY EIGHT YEARS TO BE
EXACT.
I ALSO SERVED ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION FOR
TWELVE YEARS. AND CURRENTLY A
SERVICE THE CHAPTER
ADMINISTRATOR FOR CSAA'S ELK
GROVE AT CHAPTER. CSEA
REPRESENTS NEARLY TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES ACROSS THE STATE. AND
PARENT EDUCATORS MAKE UP ABOUT
THIRTY THREE PERCENT OF THAT
MEMBERSHIP.
I WOULD FIRST LIKE TO THANK YOU
FOR FOCUSING ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. FOREIGN AND FOR
INCLUDING THE CLASSIFIED SCHOOL
EMPLOYEE PERSPECTIVE.
EDUCATORS ARE DIRECTLY INVOLVED
IN THE SUCCESS OF IT OUT OF
SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS BUT
OFTEN OUR WORK IS BEHIND THE
SCENES. I HAVE BEEN ASKED TO
SPEAK ABOUT THE GROWING DEMANDS
ON SPECIAL EDUCATION AND THE
CHALLENGES. EDUCATORS EXPERIENCE
WHILE SERVING THE STUDENTS. LAW
REQUIRES THAT SPECIAL EDUCATION
STUDENTS LEARN IN THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENT BUT
THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH PEREZ.
TO ACHIEVE THIS GOAL. THE
INCREASING POPULATION OF SPECIAL
NEEDS STUDENTS DEMANDS MORE
PARENT EDUCATORS WITH REGULAR
TRAINING TO HELP THE STUDENT
SUCCESS GENERAL EDUCATION.
SPECIAL EDUCATION PARIS ARE
AMONG THE MOST DEDICATED
EMPLOYEES ON SCHOOL CAMPUSES
WORKING WITH SPECIAL NEEDS
STUDENTS AS BOTH UNIQUELY
CHALLENGING AND REWARDING. WE
SPEAK WE HELP SPECIAL EDUCATION
STUDENTS ACROSS ALL GRADE LEVELS
ACHIEVE THEIR IEP GOALS.
WE PROVIDE THE INSTRUCTIONAL
SUPPORT AND ENCOURAGEMENT
NECESSARY FOR THEIR INCLUSION OF
SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS IN
MAINSTREAM CLASSES. WITHOUT
PARIS SPECIAL NEEDS STUDENTS
COULD NOT BE TAUGHT ALONGSIDE
THEIR GENERAL EDUCATION PEERS.
BEYOND ACADEMIC SKILLS WE WORK
ONE ON ONE WITH STUDENTS TO
TEACH APPROPRIATE WAYS TO
RESPOND TO STRESS AND CONFLICT.
HIS RESPONDED CHALLENGING
BEHAVIORS ON A REGULAR BASIS AND
LEARN EACH STUDENT'S TRIGGERS
AND MOTIVATIONS.
OUR CLOSE RELATIONSHIP WITH
STUDENTS CAN MAKE US A TARGET
FOR FRESH STATION AND AGGRESSIVE
BEHAVIORS.
BUT WE CHOOSE THIS CAREER
BECAUSE WE LOVE THE STUDENTS WE
SERVE AND AND BECAUSE WE BELIEVE
THEY ARE ENTITLED TO THE SAME
EDUCATION. AS EVERY OTHER
STUDENT.
THE POPULATION OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
IS GROWING. IN ELK GROVE SCHOOL
DISTRICT EACH YEAR. THEY EXPAND
THE PRE K. AUTISM SPECTRUM
DISORDER PROGRAM TO OFFER MORE
CLASSES. ONE FULL INCLUSION PERO
TOLD ME THAT DURING ONE CLASS
PERIOD AND. SHE WAS ASSIGNED
SIXTEEN STUDENTS AND THREE
DIFFERENT CLASSROOMS. IT WAS
IMPOSSIBLE FOR HER TO MAKE EACH
STUDENT. TO MAKE SURE EACH
STUDENT WAS WORKING TOWARDS
THEIR I EP GOALS. IT'S COMMON
FOR FULL INCLUSION PARIS TO BE
ASSIGNED MULTIPLE STUDENTS AND
DIFFERENT CLASSROOMS. IF JUST
ONE PARENT IS ABSENT AND A
SCHOOL SITE THEY ARE FORCED TO
MAKE DIFFICULT DECISIONS. ABOUT
WHICH STUDENTS GET THE SUPPORT
FOR THE DAY.
STAFFING SHORTAGES ALSO CREATE
SAFETY RISKS FOR BOTH PARENTS
AND STUDENTS IT IS NOT UNCOMMON
FOR MORE SEVERE STUDENTS TO
ATTEMPT TO HARM THEMSELVES OR
ARE PARENT EDUCATORS. WHEN SMALL
ONE STUDENT EXHIBITS AGGRESSIVE
BEHAVIORS IT MOST LIKELY ALWAYS
TRIGGERS OTHER STUDENTS IN THE
CLASSROOM.
AND LESTER IS APPROPRIATE
STAFFING THIS DISRUPTS THE
ENTIRE CLASS AND STUDENTS MISS
VALUABLE INSTRUCTION TIME.
HOWEVER WITH THE PRO FOR
APPROPRIATE STAFFING A STREET A
TRAINED. CAN IDENTIFY TRIGGERS
AND DE ESCALATE THESE BEHAVIORS.
STAFFING SHORTAGES ARE NOT ONLY
DUE TO THE INABILITY. OF FUNDING
BUT ALSO HIGH TURNOVER AMONG
PARIS.
THE AVERAGE SPECIAL ED PARA
MAKES FOURTEEN DOLLARS AND SIXTY
ONE CENTS AN HOUR.
AND CAN BE ASSIGNED AN
OVERWHELMING NUMBER OF STUDENTS
WORKLOAD FRUSTRATIONS AND
EXPOSURE TO EIGHT AGGRESSIVE
BEHAVIORS CAN CAUSE PEREGRINE
OUT. BUT APPROPRIATE TRAINING
AND SUPPORT CAN INCREASE
RETENTION.
A GROWING POPULATION OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION STUDENTS DEMANDS THE
PARENT EDUCATORS ARE
SUFFICIENTLY TRAINED. THIS YEAR
CSAA'S ANNUAL TWENTY FIRST
DANIEL I MIGHT ADD. EDUCATOR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
CONFERENCE SOLD OUT. DUE TO ITS
OVERWHELMING POPULARITY. THE
DEMAND FOR THIS CONFERENCE GROWS
EVERY YEAR. THE MOST POPULAR
COURSES INCLUDE UNDERSTANDING
ANXIETY AND STUDENTS WITH
AUTISM.
MAXIMIZING STUDENT ENGAGEMENT
MINIMIZING DESTRUCTIVE BEHAVIORS
COMMON CORE. AND. AUTISM
SPECTRUM DISORDERS SAY TO SEE.
THIS YEAR OVER THREE HUNDRED
PARIS ATTENDED THE CLASS OF ON
AUTISM SPECTRUM DISORDERS.
SO IN CONCLUSION PAIR OR ERIC
PARENT EDUCATORS WORK DIRECTLY
WITH THE STUDENTS. AND IF THE
GOAL OF SPECIAL ED IS A MAINSTAY
IS TO MAINSTREAM THE STUDENTS AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE THEN THERE
SIMPLY ARE NOT ENOUGH PARIS TO
ACHIEVE THIS GOAL.
DISTRICTS DO NOT HAVE THE
BUDGETS TO ADEQUATELY STAFFED
TRAIN AND PAY THEIR SPECIAL
EDUCATION PARIS. DESPITE THESE
CHALLENGES PARENT EDUCATORS
DEDICATE THEIR CAREERS TO
HELPING THESE INCREDIBLE
STUDENTS SUCCEED. BY PROVIDING
MORE PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
FOR EDUCATORS AND FINDING
POSITIONS WE CAN BETTER MEET THE
GOALS AND THE NEEDS OF THE
STUDENTS TYPE HE'S. I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING ON SPECIAL EDUCATION
FUNDING AS THE CSEA LEADER I'VE
BEEN INVOLVED IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS FOR MANY YEARS. THIS IS
THE FIRST TIME. I'VE ATTENDED A
HEARING ON THIS CRITICAL ISSUE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PERSPECTIVE
IN YOUR SERVICE.
OKAY WERE NEXT IN HERE FROM THE
CRADLE OF KEEN.
WHO'S A PARENTLEADER IN THE
SPANISH LANGUAGE SPECIAL
EDUCATION PARENT SUPPORT GROUP
IN BUTTE COUNTY.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE MY STORY WITH YOU TO THEY.
MY NAME IS GETTING A LOOK IN AND
NOT AND I AM A MOTHER OF SEVEN
YEAR OLDS I KNOW SOME THE
SPECTRUM FOR UP TO SOME.
LEADER FOR A SPANISH SPEAKING
PARENTS SUPPORT GROUP IN THE
ECONOMY. AND A MIDDLE SCHOOL
TEACHER. DID YOU NEAR THE END OF
IT CLASSES WHEN MY SON WAS ONLY
A YEAR AND A HALF OLD I NOTICE
THE LACE ON HE'S MILESTONES
ESPECIALLY HIS SPEECH AND MOTOR
SKILLS.
AT THE SAME TIME I NOTICED A RED
FLAGS FOR AUTISM. WHICH I SHARE
WITH MY PROJECTION HE INSISTED
THAT THERE WAS NOTHING WRONG
WITH MY SON AND THAT HE THAT HE
EVENTUALLY WILL START TALKING.
AT THAT MOMENT I REALIZED THAT I
WILL HAVE TO DO MORE RESEARCH ON
MY OWN AND TRY TO LOOK FOR
AVAILABLE RESOURCES. TO ADDRESS
HIS NEEDS.
THAT'S HOW I EMBARK ON A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT YOUR NEO UPS AND
DOWNS. I WAS FORTUNATE TO HAVE A
COUSIN WHOSE DAUGHTER WAS
ALREADY RECEIVING A SPEECH
SERVICES THROUGH. FAR NORTHERN
REGIONAL CENTER AND WHO PROVIDED
ME WITH THE PHONE NUMBER TO
REQUEST AN EVOLUTION FOR MY SON.
I CALL THE REGIONAL CENTER ABOUT
FIVE TIMES BEFORE SOMEONE RETURN
MY PHONE CALL T SCHEDULE AN
APPOINTMENT FOR MY SON.
AFTER HIS FORMAL EVALUATION I
FOUND MYSELF WITH A LOT OF
QUESTIONS.
WORD RESOURCES MY SON WILL NEED.
WHAT DO I HAVE TO PAY FOR THOSE
SERVICES? WILL I BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE WORKING. WHAT HE'S DONE
I GIVE A SPEECH OR IP? WHAT DOES
LIST OF RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENT
MEAN FOR MY SON?
MOST OF THESE QUESTIONS WERE
ANSWERED BY THE REGIONAL CENTER
PERSONNEL. THE REGIONAL CENTER
INTRODUCED ME TO A SUPPORT GROUP
FOR SPANISH SPEAKING FAMILIES
THROUGH THE RALPH I'M ONLY
EMPOWERMENT CENTER IN CHICO.
SORRY.
THE FAMILY EMPOWERMENT CENTER
OVER OVER IDEA WERE SHOPS AND
GETTING FAMILIAR WITH THE I. B.
PROCESS AND UNDERSTANDING BUT MY
SON SOME BRANDS RICE WHEN WE
COULD QUESTION MY VACATIONS.
ACCOMMODATIONS FORD.
ON HIS INDIVIDUAL IP PLAN.
IT ALSO PRIMATE OF IS ALSO
PROVIDED THE PLANTS IN THE
SUPPORT GROUP WITH BILINGUAL
SERVICES THROUGH AT LEAST TO
EMPLOYERS TO WORK FOR THE HOME.
FOR THE ORGANIZATION.
AT THE SAME TIME. OF THE
REGIONAL CENTER INTRODUCED TO
US.
SORRY.
THE FAMILY EMPOWERMENT CENTER
HELP ME WITH MY SONS IEP BY
HELPING ME WRITE MODIFICATIONS
ON HIS EDUCATIONAL PLAN. AND
REQUESTING A SPECIAL AS. A
SPECIAL SPEECH SERVICES.
IT ALSO HELPED ME CONNECT WITH
THE DISABILITY RIGHTS OF IS
LOCATED IN CHICO WHO REVISE THE
MODIFICATIONS AND INFORM ME
ABOUT MY CHILD'S RIGHTS. WHICH I
WAS IN THE WATER AT ALL THAT IT
EVER. EXISTED. SOME.
AS I CONTINUE ATTENDING THE
MEETINGS AND SHE GOT REALIZE
OTHER WHERE SPANISH IS BECAME
FRIENDS OR NOT HAVING ACCESS TO
SOME OF THE SERVICES BEING
OFFERED FOR THEIR CHILDREN'S
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF THE
LANGUAGE. AND DID NOT KNOW HOW
TO NAVIGATE THE SYSTEM TO
OBTAIN%
SERVICES. THUS I END UP END UP
BECOMING APPARENT LEADER FOR
SPANISH SPEAKING PARENTS IN THE
TOWN THAT I CURRENTLY RECITE.
WHAT I HAVE COLLECTED THE
FOLLOWING COMMENTS FROM THE
SPANISH IS BEGIN PRESSING MY
SUPPORT GROUP OF OTHERS FRANCIS
AND WOULD LIKE TO SHARE SOME?
I WOULD LIKE TO SHARES.
SOME OF THEM WITH YOU.
NEGATIVE SOMETIMES I WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE MORE AVAILABLE RESOURCES
IN SPANISH OR A PERSON THAT I
WOULD TEACH ME HOW TO NAVIGATE
THE SYSTEM TO YOURSELVES. THE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE FOR MY
CHILD.
MANY TIMES I FIND OVERWHELMING
TRYING TO ASK QUESTIONS FOR
ANYBODY LITTLE RESOURCES FOR MY
CHILD. BECAUSE OF MY LIMITED
ENGLISH THEREFORE I JUST DON'T
EVEN TRY TO ASK QUESTIONS OR
LOOK FOR RESOURCES.
WHEN OUR FAMILIES CALL FOR
NORTHERN REGIONAL CENTER THE
CENTER DOESN'T HAVE A BI LINGUAL
RECEPTIONIST WHO CAN ADDRESS OUR
NEEDS OR CONCERNS WHEN WE CALL
FOR THE FIRST TIME.
POSITIVE. AFTER CONNECTING WITH
OTHER PARENTS THEY WANTED TO
CONTINUE RECEIVING SERVICES FOR
TRANSPORTATION WITHIN OUR
DISTRICT. I REALIZE THAT THE
MORE INFORMED WE ARE THE MORE BY
WHERE WE HAVE TO FIGHT FOR
SERVICES FOR OUR CHILDREN.
HAVING A SUPPORT GROUP HASGIVEN
ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO FIND OUT.
ABOUT RESOURCES AVAILABLE FOR
EACH MY CHILDREN THAT I WASN'T
AWARE OF.
ALSO HE HAS GIVEN ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LISTEN TO
DIFFERENT PRESENTERS. DRESSED UP
BOOKS FOR CHILDREN WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS. MORE SO IT HAS HELPED
UNDERSTAND ME IT HAS HLPED ME
UNDERSTAND BETTER WHAT A NIGHT
BE IS AND MY RICE HAS A BRAIN
WITH A CHILD WITH SPECIAL NEEDS.
I KNOW THAT NOT EVERYBODY HAS
ACCESS TO A FAMILY EMPOWERMENT
CENTER BECAUSE WHILE THE THE LAW
CALLS FOR THIRTY TWO CENTERS WE
ONLY HAVE FOURTEEN THE I FUNDED
RIGHT NOW.
EVERYBODY IN THE SERVICE ACCESS
TO FAMILY TO A FAMILY
EMPOWERMENT CENTER SERVICES IN
THEIR COMMUNITY. WE NEED MORE OF
THEM WHERE THERE ARE PARENTS WHO
GO ON.
I'M SORRY IF THERE NEEDS TO BE
ENOUGH FUNDING TO ENSURE ALL
PARENTS INCLUDING THOSE WITH
SPEAKER LANGUAGE OTHER THAN
ENGLISH. HAVE BOXES TO MENTORING
AND ASSISTANCE IN NAVIGATING THE
COMPLEX SYSTEM OF EDUCATION.
I MYSELF LESLIE I WON'T. I AM
AVAILING WANTED TO KEEP HER
MOTHER WITH A CHILD WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS.
I HOPE FIND HER CELL NEEDING
ASSISTANCE ON HOW TO NAVIGATE
THE COMPLEX SYSTEM OF EDUCATION.
AND I BECAME FOR HER SON.
THE FAMILY EMPOWERMENT CENTER
HAS PROVIDED ME WITH SOME
ESSENTIAL TOOLS TOOLS TO
NAVIGATE THE SYSTEM.
AND HELP MY SON BECOME
SUCCESSFUL AT SCHOOL INTO ANY TO
A SOCIETY BUT IT'S STILL THERE
IS A LOT OF FUN BEING.
THAT IS NOT THERE TO EVEN UP
THE DISTRICTS OR.
PROVIDED THROUGH FINE ART AND
REGIONAL WHICH IS WHERE I'M.
WHERE THE SYSTEM IS COMING FROM
FOR MY SON?
?
ADDITIONALLY A FUNDING IS NEEDED
TO HELP OTHER PARENTS MAKE SURE
THAT THEIR CHILDREN ARE GIVEN
ALL THE RESOURCES. NEEDED TO
SUCCEED AND.
TO ACCELERATE THEIR LEARNING IN
THE CLASSROOM.
OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
L
AND UP THE PANEL TO OUR
DISCUSSION AND QUESTIONS ON US
IN A MORE LIFE. LIKE TO OPEN UP.
NO. MATTER WHAT.
YEAH. GO FOR. MISTER CHAIR YOU
AND I SERVED ON.
THE BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE ONE IN ANY FIFTEEN
AND SIXTEEN AND IT WAS GREAT.
INTRODUCTION TO THE SENATE FOR
ME I JUST DELIGHTED THAT YOU'RE
IN.
YOU ARE LEARNING A LOT ABOUT
EDUCATION I WAS THE TREASURER
FOR THE COUNTY OF ORANGE FOR
TWELVE YEARS AND WORK WITH ALL
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE. NOT
UNFAMILIAR. BY TOM.
I DON'T SEE ON THE ON THE PANEL
MISTER CHAIR I DON'T SEE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AND I'M JUST CURIOUS IF I COULD
ASK YOU.
WHY IS THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS NOT ON THE AGENDA?
WHAT A GREAT QUESTION ARE
CERTAINLY WHY DON'T WE MAKE
ARRANGEMENTS TO? WHAT WINS THE
BUDGETS ARE GOING TO BE TAKING
THIS UP THIS SPECIAL ED FINANCE
ISSUE OF TINA?
OKAY LET'S FIND ONE THAT'S GOING
TO BE IN THE SPRING AND DEAL
LEFT PERSON IN ALL COME TO THE
HEARING AS WELL AND LET'S ASK
HIM SOME QUESTIONS AND OPEN UP
TO EVERYONE IN THE HEARING.
BECAUSE A WE KNOW.
WELL WE KNOW FROM JUST PRIOR
DISCUSSIONS THAT AUTISM. IS
RISING DRAMATICALLY IN THIS
COUNTRY WE STILL DON'T. HAVE
AGREEMENT ON WHY THAT'S
HAPPENING YOU AND I HAD THAT
DEBATE.
BUT I GOT HERE WITH SP TWO SEVEN
SEVEN. ARM AND SO I'M SITTING
HERE WATCHING THIS PROP NINETY
EIGHT TUG OF WAR.
BUT IT'S THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE SORDID IS IT'S MAYBE
THAT I'M JUST TRYING THINK HOW.
EVEN AFTER BEING HERE FOR THREE
YEARS HOW DO WE GET THERE HERE.
TO PAY ATTENTION TO SOME OF
THESE RISING NEEDS AND. AND SO I
GUESS THE QUESTION TO THE PANEL
MAYBE I'LL START WITH.
.
SUPERINTENDENT ESCOBEDO.
I DO YOU HAVE THE GOVERNORS
HERE.
I HAD LUNCH WITH HIM ONCE.
THAT'S.
HE'S A DELIGHTFUL FELLOW BUT.
NO I I WOULD LOVE THE
OPPORTUNITY YOU KNOW TO
COMMUNICATE WITH HIM.
I I. CAN SPEAK THROUGH ACSA.
HOWEVER.
YOU KNOW THERE'S NOTHING BETTER
THAN PERSONAL CONTACT BUT ID BE
MORE THAN HAPPY TO COME BACK
AND.
HAVE MORE OF A THOROUGH
CONVERSATION THIS TOPIC BECAUSE
IT IS SOMETHING THAT WE REALLY
ARE AT A AT A CRITICAL LEVEL. AT
THAT YOU KNOW AN AND WE HAVE
THE RESEARCH THAT WE CAN MAKE A
DIFFERENCE RATTLING THAT THAT'S
THE THING IT'S NOT THE DATA
SERVICE AND MORE CHOOSE. SO I'M
JUST TAKING OVER AND I APOLOGIZE
FOR MAYBE.
ASKING THESE QUESTIONS BECAUSE
THERE'S THERE IS AN INTENT FOR
THIS. HEARING TODAY COURSE AND
AND THAT IS TO GET YOU MORE
FUNDING WHICH RIGHT IS NOT A
HARD CASE TO MAKE. THE ISSUE IS.
DATA AND AND TENDER PARTS AND HE
KNOWS THE CHAIR OF SUB ONE.
ANDARE BEEN WORKING WITH HIM THE
LAST YEAR.
A LOT OF WE WE WE IT IT'S ALWAYS
ARGUMENT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND TRYING TO. CUT HEARING AFTER
HEARING SAY HEY WHY AREN'T YOU
THINKING MORE ABOUT THIS OR THAT
IT'S LIKE AN INCREMENTAL BATTLE.
AND SO I'M JUST CURIOUS HOW.
YOU COMBINED ARE WORKING TO.
APPEAL TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE BECAUSE.
THEY PUT OUT THE BUDGET.
AND THEN WE GET TO I DON'T USE
THE WORD GROVEL BUT MAYBE WE GET
TO DEBATE A LITTLE BIT BUT BUT
THEY CALL THE FINAL SHOTS AND
I'M. THE SITE SO I THINK IF IT
HAD A WE HELP YOU AND HOW YOU
HELP US. AND THAT WOULD BE MY
MY.
MY COMMENT THANK YOU MISTER
IDEAS THANK YOU.
I'M DUE TO OUR OTHER VIEW. I AM
AND MISS IT EITHER OF YOU GUYS
IN LEADERSHIP ROLES WITHIN
ACCESS. IS THAT.
BUT I GUESS YOU'RE YOU'RE
ZOOMIES SMALL DISTRICTS YOU'RE
THE CHAIR OFF I'VE ALSO SERVED
ON ACTS AS THE SMALL SCHOOLS ON
DESIGNATE YOUR THEIR
REPRESENTATIVE.
I ALSO. ASSET ON THE.
COMMITTEE ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING I'M THE CHAIR OF
THAT COMMITTEE.
BUT I THINK TO TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION I WOULD LOVE TO BUY THE
GOVERNOR LUNCH I WOULD LIKE TO
BUY ANYONE MIND SHE WOULD BE
WILLING TO LISTEN. THE ISSUE
SOMETIMES IS TRULY ACCESS AND
IT'S ALSO WE IN THE FIELD HAVING
THE TIME TO BE OUT AND ABOUT AND
TO COME UP TO SACRAMENTO AND TO
SHARE BECAUSE WE'RE LEAVING. THE
TROOPS AT HOME WITH WITH NO ONE
TO TO TO HAVE TO LOOK TOO SO I I
THINK THOSE ARE THE ISSUES I
THINK ACCESS VERY WILLING AS IS
SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION. BUT AGAIN IT COMES
TO TO THE POINT OF ARE WE
INVITED TO THE TABLE AND OUR IS
OUR VOICE BEING HEARD ARE
ALLOWED TO AT LEAST BE SHARED SO
I THINK THAT'S.
YEAH WELL I THINK YOUR LINE OF
QUESTIONING IS IS IS GREAT
SENATOR AND I.
I GUESS THE NUMBER OF US ARE
HEARING THIS DISCUSSION WILL
BRING THIS SPIRIT THESE ISSUES
TO THE SUB. HEARING WHEN IT
HAPPENS AND.
MAKE A POINT OF FOLLOWING UP ON
THE THINGS WE'VE BROUGHT UP
TODAY.
I CAN JUST MAKE A COMMENT I MEAN
THAT'S THE POINT OF TODAY.
SET THE TABLE FOR THAT. BUDGET
CONVERSATION AND YOU'VE GOT THE
TWO BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIRS
HERE. LISTENING TO THIS SERIOUS
CONVERSATION AND HIGHLIGHTING
THE DEFICIENCIES WITH THE
CURRENT FORMAT I MEAN THAT'S.
THAT'S THE PROCESS WE'RE
UNDERTAKING I WISH I HAD THE
MEETING SCHEDULE IN MY DOWNLINE
BUT. I DON'T.
BUT AS SOON AS I GET IT I'LL
LET EVERYBODY KNOW AND.
THAT'S AND I'VE BEEN HEARING
FROM VINYL YOU HAVE BEEN HEARING
FROM YOUR DISTRICTS AS WELL. YOU
KNOW THE DISTRICT SEVEN SHARING
THEIR PERSPECTIVE WITH US AND
YOU KNOW THAT'S WHY WE'RE DOING
THIS YEP. YEP OKAY DECEMBER
MCCARTY.
YEAH THAT JUST ON THAT NOTE YES
MISTER POINTY NOSE. STATED I I
MONTHS SIMPLY SIDE OVERSEEING
THAT BUDGET FOR EDUCATION AND
WE'LL BE LOOKING AT SO THAT THE.
PROP NINETY EIGHT EXPENDITURES
AND ELSIE FAST SO THE GOOD NEWS
IS THE GOVERNORS. ALLOCATION.
FULLY FUND SELL CFF THAT THE
BAND IS A WASTE OF A LONG WAY TO
GO IS ART.
SUPERINTENDENT SAID WERE SO
FORTY FIFTH THE NATION IN PER
PUPIL FUNDING AS MR MARTUCCI
SAYS SOME OF THE DISTRICTS.
BASED ALLOCATION DOESN'T KEEP UP
WITH COMMITMENTS THEY HAVE WITH
HIM PLAY COMPENSATION YOU KNOW
RETIREMENT ALL THAT SO. YOU
KNOW.
COMPETING ISSUES WERE LOOKING AT
THIS IS CERTAINLY ONE WHICH I
THINK. WE SHOULD EVALUATE YOU
KNOW WE'RE LOOKING AT.
.
YOU KNOW PRE K. FOR ALL KIDS WHO
ARE INCOME ELIGIBLE WE HAVE A
LONG WAYS TO GO FOR THAT YOU
KNOW CERTAINLY THIS. IS IT ISSUE
AS WELL AS WELL AS TAKING A LOOK
AT THE OVERALL. BASE RATE FOR
DISTRICTS IN THESE LEADERS HERE
ARE SHAKING THEIR HEADS THAT'S
AN IMPORTANT ISSUE SO YES IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO BE ON
OUR. ON OUR LIST TO TAKE
DEVALUATIONS WITH ALL THE
COMPETING ISSUES. BUT I DO WANT
TO ASK SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT WE THAT WE ASK THE LAST
pCOULD STEP IN. ESPECIALLY SOME
OF THE DISTRICT LEVEL.
THE FIRST IS MAYBE CAN FOLLOW UP
ON THE QUESTION THAT THAT
SENATOR ALAN NAST'S FARCE.
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN IT GOD YOU
KNOW TWENTY YEARS AGO WAS A
DIFFERENT LOOK WE HAD THE
CHARTER AUTHORIZATION OF COURSE
TWENTY YEARS AGO BUT THE
DIFFERENT LANDSCAPE AS FAR AS
WHO'S BEING. SERVED IN THE
FUNDING WAS LOCKED IN TWENTY
YEARS AGO AND SO WHAT ARE YOUR.
THOUGHTS ON ON THAT AND THAT
THE FINANCING OF IT AND WHAT
HAPPENS IN A REALISTIC WAY AND.
AND IS THERE. AN INEQUITY AS FAR
AS. YOU KNOW WHO'S THAT WHO'S
PAYING THE FARE SHARE.
NO THEY'RE DIFFERENT SHADES OF
CHARTER SCHOOL SUMMER DEPENDENCE
ARE INDEPENDENT SOME WORK WITH
NETWORKS. I WOULD HAVE TO SAY
I'M LOOKING AT THE ONES THAT
ARE.
INDEPENDENT FROM THE DISTRICT
OKAY SO INDEPENDENT OF THE
DISTRICT AID IS VERY DIFFICULT
JUST BECAUSE OF SCALE. FOR THE
INDEPENDENT CHARTERS TO SUPPORT
SPECIALIST STUDENTS AND
TYPICALLY WE RECEIVE A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER ARE FROM
INDEPENDENCE. SCHOOL STUDENTS
COMING TO THE DISTRICT BECAUSE
OF LACK OF SERVICES OF OUR LACK
OF SYSTEMS IN PLACE YOU KNOW
SPECIFICALLY FOR SPECIAL ED
STUDENTS. WHO?
WE HAVE OF.
AND OUR THIRTEEN CHARTER SCHOOLS
THEIR SPECIAL ED POPULATION
COMPRISES FOUR PERCENT OF THEIR
TOTAL POPULATION WORDS OVER
THIRTEEN PERCENT FOR A DISTRICT
THAT CAN AND DO YOU THINK
THAT'S.
IT'S SAD BY BY CHOICE THAT THAT
THERE'S DECISIONS BEING MADE TO
MAKE TO HAVE THOSE NUMBERS
REFLECT THAT A WORK.
SOMETHING ELSE GOING ON I I
THINK IT'S COMPLICATED I THINK.
SOME FOLKS ALREADY TALKED ABOUT
WHAT I THINK WAS THE LA O. ABOUT
WHAT A DISTRICT CAN PROVIDE
ALTHOUGH WE PROVIDE SERVICES TO
ABOUT HALF OF OUR CHARTER
SCHOOLS. SO I WOULD HAVE TO TALK
TO THE SPECIAL ED FOLKS A LITTLE
MORE TO SEE IF THEY ACTUALLY
HAVE DATA ON THAT.
OKAY. DON'T SEE ANY OTHER.
INTERESTING ANSWER ASKING THIS
QUESTION SO MY MY NEXT ONE IS
THE.
AS FAR AS THAT THAT THAT THE
FUNDING.
THE STRUCTURE AND MODEL.
ARE THERE WAYS IN WHICH OUR
FUNDING MODEL CREATES
DISINCENTIVES TO SERVING SPECIAL
ED STUDENTS IN MAINSTREAM
ENVIRONMENTS.
FROM THE.
FOR INSTANCE THE MAKES IT MORE
CHALLENGING THAN AN AS AND AS A
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC EYE WOULD I
HAVE TO TELL YOU THAT I
ABSOLUTELY NOT I WANT TO SERVE
CHILDREN REGARDLESS OF WHAT THE
FUNDING GAPS ARE. AS IS DISTRICT
SUPERINTENDENT AND I THINK AS A
CEO WE I I THINK THEY WOULD ASK
MY CBO WOULD BE SAYING THE
PROBLEM IS HOW DO WE DO THIS
WITH LIMITED RESOURCES. SO I I
THINK THAT.
ANY HUMAN BEING WHO GOES INTO
EDUCATION THEIR HEART IS IN
SERVING KIDS AND SO THE PROBLEM
BECOMES TRULY THE FUNDING
MECHANISM ON HOW WE BEST DO
THAT.
I HOPE THAT ANSWERS YOUR
QUESTION I THINK IT'S IT'S NOT
AN EASY QUESTION OF SAYING. THAT
IF THIS WERE THE SOLE FIX IT
WITH SOLID.
I THINK.
I'M NOT SURE IF IF.
WE'RE LOOKING MAYBE OUR SPECIAL
IN A DIFFERENT MINDSET ALWAYS
WONDERED WHY. SPECIAL THAT WAS
INCLUDED AS PART OF THE EL CAP
PLAN.
JUST SEEMS LIKE ITSELF YOU KNOW
THINK IT SHOULD BE YES.
ABSOLUTELY THE FLIP SIDE THE
ARGUMENT IS THAT IF IT WAS
PARKED.
SOME PEOPLE THINK THAT IT WOULD
BECOME.
LIKE WE HAD WITH THAT CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION WHERE YOU
KNOW IT'S NOT A PRIORITY SOME
DISTRICTS ARE JUST PUT IT TO THE
BACK BURNER AND THEY YOU KNOW
USE THAT. BASED ALLOCATION TO
FOLKS ON THEIR NEEDS AND AND DO
YOU THINK THAT YOU WOULD. SPEND
THAT. ADEQUATE. AMOUNTS TO TAKE
CARE OF SPECIAL AT.
WELL NOT ONLY THAT BUT THE FOCUS
WILL BE MORE SPECIAL LETTER WE
WOULD HAVE MORE PUBLIC INPUT
PUBLIC STAKE HOLDERS I MEAN.
THAT IS THAT IS OUR OUR PLAN OUR
DISTRICT PLAN BUTTON IN IT OUT
OF. SPECIAL EDUCATION AWAY FROM
THE LIMELIGHT YOU TAKE IT AWAY
FROM THE CONVERSATION. AND
BASICALLY SPECIALIST
HISTORICALLY HAS ALWAYS BEEN IN
THE BACK BURNER.
AND IT CONTINUES TO BE THAT WAY
BY TAKING OUT OF THE EL CAP. SO
I UNDERSTAND YOUR POSITION
HOWEVER AS A DISTRICT WE PUT SO
MUCH ATTENTION ON EL CAP OVER
WE'RE CONFUSING ELF CAPPERS LC
AFFECTS THE DO YOU THINK THAT.
THAT SHOULD BE PART OF THE PLAN
HEATH BUT THAT'S NOT THAT'S THE
PLAN BUT DO YOU THINK THE IT THE
MONEY SHOULD BE. PUT IN WITH LCF
AFTER WE SHOULD STILL HAVE THIS
SEPARATE CATEGORICAL ALBEIT
MAYBE AN EQUALIZED AMOUNT
CATEGORIC RIGHT. I DO BELIEVE WE
SHOULD BE PART OF THE US IF YOU
DO THE THE FUNDING.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
WHAT KINDA ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
IN TERMS OF DISSENT
DISINCENTIVES FOR HAVING
STUDENTS AND LEAST RESTRICTIVE
ENVIRONMENT I WOULD SAY NO? YEAH
I WOULD SAY IT'S A TWO FOLD.
YES THERE CAN BE DISINCENTIVES
BECAUSE AS YOU TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER THE KINDS OF SUPPORTS TO
REALLY MAKE STUDENTS THAT HAVE A
SEVERE MORE OF A SEVERE LEVEL OF
DISABILITY THAT YOU MAY NEED. IN
ORDER FOR THEM TO BE SUCCESSFUL
IN THE GENERAL EDUCATION
CLASSROOM.
THERE MAY NOT BE THE FUNDING TO
SUPPORT THAT DISTRICTS.
FOLKS WANT KIDS IN THAT GENERAL
EDUCATION CATION CLASSROOM THEY
WANT STUDENTS IN THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENT THAT IS
WHAT EVERYONE IS SPECIAL
EDUCATION REALLY STRIVES FOR.
BUT AT WHETHER OR NOT IT IS
SOMETHING THAT IS FEASIBLE
DEPENDING UPON THE KINDS OF
SUPPORTS THAT MIGHT BE NEEDED
FOR AN INDIVIDUAL WITH
SIGNIFICANT DISABILITIES. THAT'S
ANOTHER QUESTION.
IS IT. NINETEEN YEARS AGO MY
CLASSROOM WAS MOSTLY MIDDLE
SCHOOL SIXTH SEVENTH AND EIGHTH
GRADE RESOURCE STUDENTS WITH
LEARNING DISABILITIES AND NOW
WITH THE CHANGES IN FUNDING AND
PROGRAM DELIVERIES AND SERVICES
AVAILABLE. I HAVE LEARNING
DISABILITIES AUTISM EMOTIONALLY
DISTURBED COUNSELING AND RICH
STUDENTS BECAUSE THERE ARE MANY
PROGRAMS AVAILABLE STUDY.
AND THAT YOU KNOW THE ANALOGY OF
A MOTLEY CREW OF STUDENTS IN MY
ROOM WITH THE DIFFERENT GRADE
LEVELS DIFFERENT ABILITIES HAS
CHANGED BECAUSE OF THAT WITH
LIMITED RESOURCES.
OKAY.
SIR MORE LIVE IN A SMALL PLACE
YOU THINK RESEARCHER MISS
CHRISTOPOULOS.
I AM CURIOUS TO.
TEACHERS LIKE MISS CHRIST'S.
DO THEY RECEIVE SPECIAL PAY OR
DIFFERENTIAL PAY.
YOU KNOW THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
AS A STATE WE NEED TO LOOK AT
HOW DO WE ENCOURAGE MORE.
BUT WERE IT IS DISTRICT TO
DISTRICT.
I DON'T KNOW THAT IN MY
DISTRICT I'VE BEEN THIS IS MY
THIRD YEAR AT THE DISTRICT I
DON'T RECALL IF THERE'S ANYTHING
THERE ARE SPECIALTY AREAS THAT
WE PAY HIGHER FOR.
IN SPEECH AND UP I MEAN SOME
POSITIONS ARE SO DIFFICULT TO.
HIGHER BECAUSE.
OTHER AGENCIES CAN PAY THESE
FOLKS A LOT MORE MONEY AND SO
THAT'S A CHALLENGE AS WELL WE
DID PUT ADDITIONAL.
RESOURCES IN OUR NEGOTIATIONS A
YEAR AGO I JUST DON'T HAPPEN IN
FRONT OF ME. FOR SOME OF OUR
SPECIAL ED.
AND LOOKING AT THE CLASS SIZE
TO TRYING TO KEEP THOSE
MANAGEABLE. AM.
BUT. I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT ALL TEACHERS GET
SUPPORT.
AND THAT WERE LOOKING AND THE
FACT THAT ARE GENERALLY TEACHERS
AS WELL SO THEY'RE ABLE TO.
PROVIDE GOOD SUPPORT FOR
STUDENTS THAT ARE IN THEIR
CLASSROOM THAT ARE SPECIAL
NEEDS.
I AM I RECEIVE A STIPEND AS A
SPECIAL ED TEACHER OF FOUR
HUNDRED FORTY FOUR DOLLARS A
YEAR.
HERE I AM.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING TO LOOK AT ANOTHER
DEALIO IS A RECOMMENDED THAT
SOUL. IS JUST AN IDEA THAT JUST
LANGUISHING OUT THERE. I I
TOURED A.
THE PRIVATE SCHOOL JUST AT TWO
MONTHS AGO.
THAT SPECIALIZES IN SPECIAL
NEEDS KIDS AND. WAS QUITE AN EYE
OPENER EYE OPENER FOR ME.
SYSTEM TO MEET SOME OF THE KIDS
THE TEACHERS BUT VERY SMALL
CLASSROOMS.
BUT VERY HIGH TUITION.
SO THESE INSTRUCTORS ON THE
PRIVATE SIDE. I WOULD THINK ARE
ALSO LEAST BEING CONVERTED MAYBE
A LITTLE MORE. TO. ONE OF THE
REASONS I WAS THERE IS YOU KNOW
TO HELP WITH THEIR GALA.
TO RAISE MONEY.
SO. I JUST THINK YOU'RE MISTER
CHAIR WE OUGHT TO BE LOOKING AT
DIFFERENTIAL PAY WE OUGHT TO BE
LOOKING AT SOME INCENTIVES TO
GET.
FOR THESE TEACHERS BECAUSE THIS
AREA IS GROWING.
THE SECOND IS SOME.
MISS A. IF I IF I LOOK CLOSER.
BACK TO JUST A COMMENT ON THE
ISSUE OF OF THE PAY. THE WE AS
AS SMALL DISTRICTS WE VERY OFTEN
OFFERED TO PAY FOR SOMEONE
SPECIAL CREDENTIALING OR
PROGRAMMER TRAINING. BUT THEN
WHAT HAPPENS IS THEY COME BACK
TO OUR SALARY SCHEDULES IN A
DISTRICT THAT WE CAN'T COMPETE
WITH LARGER DISTRICTS AND SO
THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAN OUR
LEARNED AWAY. BY A BETTER SALARY
SO I THINK THAT'S ABSOLUTELY
CRUCIAL THAT WE DO. EIGHT
INDIVIDUALS FOR THEIR.
WHO WHO GOES THROUGH MORE
TRAINING THAN SPECIALIZE I MEAN
THEY THEY THEY REALLY DO HAVE TO
LOVE IT OR THEY WOULDN'T DO IT
BUT AGAIN FOR FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE IS YES I WANT TO PAY
THEM BUT I CAN'T AFFORD TO? AND
WHEN I DON'T I KNOW I'M LOSING
THEM SO I'M CONSTANTLY TRAINING
AND THEN THEY LEAVE. THAT'S THE.
AND I APOLOGIZE FOR INTERRUPTING
NO NO BUT IT'S GREAT I.
PART OF IT.
PART OF THE EDUCATION OF JUST
VISITING THIS CAMPUS. IS THAT
AFTER I'D INTERVIEWS STUDENTS.
.
THE PRINCIPAL WOULD TELL ME.
WHO THE STUDENT WAS RELATED TO?
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT PEOPLE IN MY
COUNTY IN RESERVE.
YOU KNOW JUST KIND OF AN
AMAZING.
I THINK THEY ALSO ADDED I REALLY
FEEL UNDERSTAND THE NEED SO MANY
ASK A REAL NASTY QUESTION TO MS
FILLABLE BELOW. VILLA LOBOS.
YEAH I'M. THE PP I SEE
RECOMMENDED TO DO AWAY WITH SELF
AS.
INTO I'M ALWAYS WORRIED ABOUT
YOU KNOW SOMETHING IN BETWEEN.
YOU KNOW IT IF WE'RE LOOKING FOR
FUNDING COULD YOU. COULD YOU
MAYBE AN.
JUST A BRIEF BRIEFLY DEFENDANT
WHY WE WE STILL HAVE SELF AS.
I THINK THE EXAMPLE THAT I GAVE
YOU FOR EXAMPLE.
I OVERSEE FIVE SELFLESS. AND
TWO SO MY DISTRICTS GET YOU
KNOW.
QUITE A BIT OF.
OF I WOULD SAY. TECHNICAL
SUPPORT AND ASSISTANCE FOR ME.
AT A VERY LOW RATE SINCE I
OVERSEE FIVE DIFFERENT SELF AS
BUT THE REASON WHY IS EXAMPLE I
GAVE YOU WE HAVE. ONE SELFLESS
THAT RECEIVES.
FOUR HUNDRED AND. NINETY SIX
DOLLARS AND ANOTHER WHEN THEY
GET SIX HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX AND
THEY'RE LITERALLY RIGHT BUT UP
AGAINST EACH OTHER. SO.
AND THE ONE THAT RECEIVED SIX
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX DOLLARS
WHAT. WHAT ENDS UP HAPPENING IS
THAT?
THEY RECEIVE A LOT OF MONEY
THAT GOES FOR INFANT FUNDING. SO
AS THE BENEFIT OF THAT THAT.
BECAUSE OF THE DIFFERENT MUTUAL
AGREEMENTS BETWEEN THOSE FIVE
DIFFERENT TOPICS IN THOSE TWENTY
DIFFERENT DISTRICTS THAT INFANT
FUNDING THAT GOES TO THE
REGIONAL PROGRAM TO OUR COUNTY
OFFICE AND HELPS TO SUPPORT
THAT.
IF THAT WASN'T A RANGE THAT WAY
THEN THAT MONEY WOULD GO AND
STAY WITH THAT GROUP IN THOSE
OTHER DISTRICTS THAT DON'T
RECEIVE AS MUCH MONEY WOULD NOT
RECEIVE THE BENEFIT OF THAT FOR
THAT INFANT FUNDING. SO THAT
THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF THIGS OF
THE REASONS WHY SELF HELP EVEN
OUT THINGS FOR EXAMPLE I HAVE
THREE NINE HUNDRED DISTRICTS
SMALL DISTRICTS WITHIN MYSELF
AS.
SO.
BECAUSE OF THE WAY THAT WE OF
THE AGREEMENTS THAT WE HAVE
WITHIN THAT SOUTH OF THE HELP
ALL HAPPEN TO BE WITHIN MY ONE
OF MYSELF AS WHICH IS SOUTH
THREE. THERE ARE CERTAIN THINGS
THAT CAN BE DONE TO SUPPORT
THOSE SMALLER DISTRICTS BECAUSE
THEY SAID FACE SO MANY THE
OBSTACLES THAT MISTER BRAZIL HAS
ALREADY TALKED ABOUT THAT HE
FACES AND KEYS. SO THOSE
ADDITIONAL THOSE FUNDS FROM THE
FRIEND THAT SUPPLICANT AND HELP
THOSE IN ADDITION I HAVE TO
SINGLE DISTRICTS UP A SO I KNOW
WHAT THE FUNDING LOOKS LIKE FOR
THOSE FOR SINGLE DISTRICTS UP.
THE REASON WHY FOR ONE OF THE
MAJOR THINGS THAT I SEE IS ONE
OF THE DISADVANTAGES OF NOT
HAVING A CELL BUT IS THAT THERE
IS IT WHEN A PARENT HAS CONCERNS
IN A SINGLE DISTRICTS ALPHA.
THERE'S NO ONE TO GO TO. YOUR
THAT'S THAT SELL THE THE ADDRESS
THAT NEED AND WHETHER OR NOT
THEY THEY CAN THEY DO ADDRESS
THAT THERE'S NO ONE FOR. ANOTHER
PERSON THEY CAN GO TO ANOTHER
LEVEL WHICH WOULD BE ME IN THAT
IN THAT CASE. SO IN ALL THOSE
CASES I I MEAN NASA IN EXAMPLE
RIGHT THERE IT WITH THIS AT THE
SOUTH REALLY DOES HELP TO EVEN
OUT AND MAKE A RANGE OUT OF
EXPERTISE.
ITSELF AS DIRECTOR GENERALLY
HAVE A YOU KNOW IS IS A AS IT AS
A PRETTY I DON'T BUY ONE BUT IT
TO MY OWN HORN. BUT WE HAVE A
VERY HIGH LEVEL OF EXPERTISE
GENERALLY IN TERMS OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION. SO I MEAN THAT IS
ANOTHER REASON THAT I THAT I
THINK IS THE THE SOUTH BUT
SHOULD NOT BE.
DONE AWAY WITH AND ALSO BECAUSE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE WAY THE
FUNDING MODELS CURRENTLY ARE YOU
KNOW THAT SOMETHING THAT WHEN
THAT SOUTH WHEN THAT REPORT CAME
OUT BASICALLY DISTRICTS WERE NOT
ADDRESSED. AND I HAVE A NUMBER
OF BASIC EIGHT DISTRICTS AND HOW
FUNNY WOULD LOOK FOR THEM WAS
SOMETHING THAT WAS AN
ADJUSTMENT.
IC REPORT EITHER SO MY BASIC
EIGHT DISTRICTS ARE VERY MUCH
CONCERNED WITH THE PP I SEE
REPORT CAME OUT THAT THEY
WEREN'T MENTIONED AND WHAT WOULD
BE HAPPY WITH THEIR FUNDING LOOK
LIKE FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION.
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME HIT A
NERVE.
DOES. DOES ANYONE AROUND THE
TABLE WANT TO TAKE THE OPPOSITE
POSITION AND MAYBE WE HAVE SOME.
DEBATE.
DONNA YOU CHICKENS.
BUT SO EVERYONE SUPPORTS THE
CELL PRESIDENT IN PP I SEE IS
THE OUT LIAR OKAY THANK YOU FOR
THE DELAY THING I WOULD SAY IS
THERE ARE DIFFERENT.
NOT EVERY CELL BUT IS THE SAME
AND SO THE LEVEL OF SERVICE IN
THE EXPERTISE AND SOME OF THEM
DIFFERS GREATLY AND IT DEPENDS
ON THE REGION.
AT AND SO I'M NOT TAKING I WALK
I WOULD NEVER WANT TO SEE MYSELF
WITHOUT A SELF PIE WILL SAY THAT
AS A SUPERINTENDENTHOWEVER.
THAT THERE ARE LEVELS FROM
COUNTY TO COUNTY.
FROM SINGLE. DISTRICT SL PLUS
TWO COUNTIES HELP US AND THEY
ARE TRULY DIFFERENT.
THANK YOU WHAT WHAT IS THE CORE
IT WHAT'S YOUR NURSING AT THE
CORE OF THE PKC IS CRITIQUE OF
THIS UP AS.
WELL I I ALWAYS FIND IT
INTERESTIG EXTERNAL MARKET
BALLS SORRY PRETTY WELL SO. I
WAS KIND OF FIND IT INTERESTING
THAT THEY'RE COMING UP WITH A
PERSPECTIVE THAT'S A LITTLE
DIFFERENT SO. I JUST WANTED TO
KIND OF GET THE. THE FIELD BUT
COULD JUST CONSUMING CRYSTALLIZE
WHAT IS TAKE ME TO PULL ITS
PURPOSE IN THE PACKAGE. OF ONE
I'LL GET BACK TO YOU OKAY OKAY
OKAY.
YEAH I THINK YOU GUYS
CENTERPOINT YOU KNOW. A COUPLE
THINGS SO.
AS FAR AS THE BUDGETS OF
HEARING SCHEDULE IT'S ACTUALLY
GOING TO GET THREE DIFFERENT
PIECES A SPECIAL ED ON THREE
DIFFERENT DAYS. APRIL FIFTH.
CHILDCARE RELATED SPECIAL ED
ISSUES WILL BE DISCUSSED ON MAY
THIRD.
THE SPECIAL ED TEACHER
PROPOSALS ARE GOING TO BE
DISCUSSED ON APRIL TWENTY SIX BE
OUT EVERYTHING THAT WE HAVEN'T
COVERED. RELATED TO SPECIAL AND
OTHER SPECIAL ISSUES ARE GONNA
BE ON APRIL TWENTY SIX SO AGAIN
APRIL FIFTH CHILDCARE APRIL TH
OF MAY THIRD SPECIAL ED TEACHER
PROPOSALS APRIL TWENTY SIX.
OTHER SPECIAL ED ISSUES.
AND I DID HAVE SORT OF ONE SORT
OF. A QUESTION.
AND I WANT TO HAVE AUDIENCE
PARTICIPATION WITH A SHOW OF
HANDS. IF THAT'S OKAY MISTER
CHAIR.
MY DISTRICT'S SORT OF ON.
WEATHER SPECIAL ED FUNDING
SHOULD BE ROLLED INTO ELSEY FF
IT SEEMS TO BE THE PREVAILING
OPINION NOT TO ROLL WITH INTEL
CFF BUT TO.
SOLVE THE FINDING AN ACT
INEQUITIES IN AB SIX OH TWO
SEPARATELY SO WHO THINKS IT
SHOULD BE ROLLED INTO ELSEY FF
RAISE YOUR HAND.
OKAY WHO THINKS WE SHOULD FIND
THE INEQUITIES IN SIX SIX SO TO.
RAISE YOUR HAND.
YOU GUYS HERE CAN RAISE YOUR
HANDS TO IS THAT THE.
OKAY JUST WANT TO SEE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
HAD THAT SOUNDS LIKE A CENTER
MORE LIKE I KNOW CEMETERY WAS
TALKING BUT IT SOUNDS LIKE MAYBE
APRIL TWENTY SIX WILL BE GOOD
OPTION TO ENGAGE FINANCE. ON THE
ISSUES YOU'RE RAISING EARLIER AT
THE BUDGET SUB. ITEMS JUST
ANNOUNCED BY THE CENTER FOR TINA
WE NEXT LOVE TO TURN TO SENATOR
VOCAL.
THANKS FOR THE PROMOTION.
THIS AGAIN.
BACK I'M ACTUALLY SEE SOME OF
ARABS A VERY FAST.
SO.
IT'S GREAT HAVING THIS IS A BY A
CAUCUS THAT. THEY HADN'T DREAMT
MULTI HOUSE A HEARING HERE SO WE
WE WE DO APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE REGARDLESS OF WHICH HOUSE
OR IN.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
I JUST WANTED TO. A GREATLY
WELCOMED.
TO THE BEST ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND.
MR BIZARRO.
I HAD THE HONOR TO BE ASSOCIATED
WITH YOUR SCHOOL DISTRICT FOR
OVER TWENTY SEVEN YEARS AND RISK
MANAGEMENT DEPARTMENT SO. I
KNOW.
THE DISTRICT INSIDE AND OUT.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO ALSO HONOR
EVERYONE GIVING TESTIMONY HERE
TODAY BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH TO
INVESTORS MODELS EACH CHILD AS
AN INDIVIDUAL OF GREAT WORTH I
THINK YOU SHARE THAT. ALL.
AND YOU DON'T DO IT FOR MONEY
YET DO IT FOR LOVE.
.
IN MY DISTRICT WHICH IS EAST
COUNTY SAN DIEGO.
IT'S IT'S URBAN AND A GREAT.
DEAL OF.
RURAL.
TWENTY PERCENT.
OF SYRIAN REFUGEES COME TO MY
DISTRICT.
SO THAT. PUTS A NEW.
SOME SAID INTO SPECIAL NEEDS A
MATCH AND HAVING AN AUTISTIC
CHILD OR SPECIAL NEEDS CHILD.
THAT HAS NEVER GONE TO SCHOOL.
AJ THERE NINE.
AND THEY WON'T.
REACT TO ANY SCHOOL BELLS OR
ANYTHING BECAUSE THAT'S AN ALARM
BELL THEY WON'T LINE UP FOR
CAFETERIA BECAUSE SNIPERS COULD
PICK THEM OFF. ALL RIGHT NOW YOU
TAKE THOSE SPECIAL NEEDS
CHILDREN.
WHOA DOCTOR THAT'S A TOUGH ONE.
OKAY FROM JUST WANTED TO. TO PUT
THAT OUT THERE BECAUSE SPECIAL
NEEDS GOES FROM.
THE BEAUTIFUL TO THE ABSOLUTELY
HELLISH OKAY AND EVERYWHERE IN
BETWEEN. ARM.
I WAS SOMEWHAT OF A. I HAVE A
MILITARY BACKGROUND SO WHEN I
RAISE MY CHILDREN IT WAS PRETTY.
GOOD DISCIPLINE WITH LOVE OKAY.
TRUST ME.
WHEN YOU HAVE AN AUTISTIC CHILD
WHICH I HAVE A GRANDDAUGHTER
THAT SOUGHT TO STAKE.
THEY DON'T GET THAT. THEY'RE
GOING TO DO WHAT THEY'RE GOING
TO DO AND YOU HAVE TO BE ON YOUR
GAME. BIG TIME IN ORDER TO RUN
THAT SO YOUR SPECIAL NEEDS
TEACHERS AND.
SUPERVISORS THEY'RE THE THEY'RE
A CUT ABOVE.
THE SO JUST SO YOU KNOW THAT.
.
I WOULD LIKE TO WRAP MY COMMENTS
UP WITH.
ONCE AGAIN I HAVE.
AN ARTISTIC GRANDDAUGHTER THEIR
PARENTS WERE VERY DISAPPOINTED
IN CALIFORNIA'S SERVICES AND
SUPPORT.
SO THEY ACTUALLY SOLD THEIR
HOUSE AND MOVED TO TEXAS SO THAT
THEY CAN GET A MUCH HIGHER.
LEVEL OF SERVICE IN THE STATE OF
TEXAS.
SO THAT'S WHAT THEY DID.
AND IT IS TREMENDOUS THE STATE
OF TEXAS IS FULLY FUNDED AND
THEY HAVE WONDERFUL PROGRAMS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THE MONEY.
MONEY IS EVERYTHING. THESE FOLKS
ARE GONNA KILL THEMSELVES IN
THIS ARENA BUT WE HAVE TO FUND
THEM THEY HAVE TO HAVE THE MEANS
TO PROVIDE. THE LEVEL OF
SERVICE.
SO THAT'S WHAT I LEAVE YOU WITH
IS THIS IS A REAL DIFFICULT
AREA.
OF HUMAN SERVICE.
AND THEY HAVE TO HAVE SOME KIND
OF MONEY THAT'S IT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR.
SHE DOES COME INTO WHAT. I AM
ITEMS PENDING OUTCOME IS GOING
TO MAKE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I I HAVE
A QUESTION FOR YOU FOR YOU AND I
HOPE I'M NOT OUT OF ORDER.
IF IF YOU RETURN TO YOUR
DISTRICTS.
AND DO YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO VISIT A PUBLIC SCHOOL.
SPECIAL DAY CLASS.
FOR AUTISTIC CHILDREN I HIGHLY
RECOMMEND THAT YOU DO THAT.
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WE CAN SIT HERE
AND TELL YOU THIS. AMP FOR AND
AND LAY EVERYTHING OUT IN FRONT
OF YOU BUT INTEL YOU WITNESS
SET.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT I ENCOURAGE YOU
TO DO THAT PLEASE.
WELL I'M SURE THAT.
DID THE MEMBERS OF THE INNOCENT
OR NOT AND LET'S WORK TOGETHER
TO. GET SOME TOWARDS ME WE CAN
EVEN DO THEM HERE LOCALLY SO
THAT EVANS CLOSE BY AND WE CAN.
I KNOW YOU'RE BASED HERE SO ON
THERE BECAUSE IF YOU WORK WITH
THE COMMITTEE THAT TO GET SOME
OF SET UP.
SUMMARY. OF YOUR PRESENT ABOUT
OKAY I'M.
YEAH WELL I APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION I'M I'M YOU KNOW
CONTINUE TO BE. AN.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THAT I
THINK WE HAVE TO SPEND SOMETIME
LOOKING AT IS THIS ISSUE THAT I
RAISED DURING THE LAST PANEL.
ABOUT.
AND. THE OLD SYSTEM PRETTY
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT. AND
TODAY.
AND HOW WE ENSURE. THAT IF WE'RE
GOING TO MAKE SOME TWEAKS TO THE
SYSTEM.
THAT CREATES A MORE EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION OF FINDS.
IT IS A QUESTION YOU MORE MONEY
THAT'S. CLEAR. ON THE AWESOME
BUT.
DO YOU KNOW IF WE'RE GONNA
FIGURE OUT A MORE EQUITABLE WAY
OF DISTRIBUTING THE FUNDS WITHIN
THE SYSTEM BASED ON. THE NEEDS
OUT THERE HOW DO WE MAKE SURE.
HOW TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T?
THE MISTAKES THAT LED US TO THE
POLICY CHANGES THAT WE JUST THAT
WE MADE BACK IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT I LOVE IF SOMEONE COULD
KIND OF DRILL IN A LITTLE BIT
MAYBE. MAYBE YOU JANE. MARIANNE
MARIE I DON'T KNOW I'D.
YOU'RE BOTH PASSING BACK OF WHAT
I KNOW IT'S A TOUGH QUESTION BUT
IT BUT. YOU KNOW.
THE REASON WHY WE PASSED A BE
SIX OR TWO.
WAS IT SEEMS THAT THERE WAS OF
CONCERN OUT THERE THAT THERE WAS
A. THERE WERE PURSED PERVERSE
DISINCENTIVES.
I WORRY THAT WE MAY HAVE SWUNG
THE OTHER END OF THE PIT.
YOU KNOW PENDULUM.
I'M HOW WOULD WE CRAFT A BETTER
SYSTEM IN TERMS OF EQUITABLE.
DISTRIBUTION OF RESOURCES
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE.
TO REFLECT THE NEEDS THAT ARE
OUT THERE.
I THINK WE NEED A LOT MORE DATA
BEFORE I COULD RESPOND TO THAT
STATEWIDE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT EIGHTY SIX OR
TWO IT'S NOT A LOT SAMMER DINO
IS A LOW FUNDED.
STRICT IN THE EIGHTY SIX SO TO
ONE OF THE LOWEST.
THERE IS SUCH A HUGE.
DISCONNECT IN SUCH A WIDE VERY
ANTS OF THE FUNDING.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE AMOUNT
PER PUSH PEOPLE IT'S NOT A LOT.
I'M NOT COMPLAINING BECAUSE WE
NEED IT.
SO I THINK WE NEED TO STUDY YOU
KNOW REALLY LOOK AT THE DATA
STATE WIDE. AND LOOK AT.
WHAT DROVE THOSE DECISIONS BACK
THEN WHAT'S DIFFERENT NOW
COMPARED TO WHAT WE WERE TRYING
TO ADDRESS BACK THEN AND I THINK
PART OF IT IS HOW DO YOU
CONTINUE TO IMPROVE? WE CAN'T
WAIT TWENTY YEARS TO DO THAT WE
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO LOOK AT WHAT
WE'RE DOING. YOU KNOW ON ONGOING
BASIS SO WE CAN MAKE CHANGES AS
NECESSARY SO I KNOW I DIDN'T
REALLY ANSWER THAT EXCEPT TO SAY
I THINK WE NEED TO STUDY IT A
LITTLE MORE.
OKAY.
I AGREE I THINK WE DO NEED TO
LOOK AT A LITTLE MORE BUT THERE
ARE SOME BASIC AND FUNDAMENTAL
THINGS JUST IN TERMS OF THE WAY
THAT THE CURRENT FUNDING IS DONE
WHERE YOU HAVE YOU HAVE
DECLINING ENROLLMENT. IN GENERAL
EDUCATION IN YOUR TOTAL ADA
POPULATION BUT THEN YOU HAVE AN
INCREASING AROUND ITS SPECIAL
AT.
THAT THAT THAT IT THAT SUIT ON
ONGOING ISSUE AND I AND I'M TEN
OF MY DISTRICTS OF DECLINING
ENROLLMENT. ARE FACING THAT
SITUATION WITH AN INCREASE SO
THERE I AM SO THE FUN THEY
HAPPEN TO YOU.
YOU KNOW SERVICE MORE STUDENTS
WITH A DECREASE IN FNDING SO
THAT THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT REALLY NEEDS TO BE EXAMINED
IN TERMS OF. OF HOW THAT EIGHTY
SIX SO TO FINDING IS.
IS ORGANIZED IN THAT MANNER
THAT'S ONE AREA ANOTHER AREA
REALLY ISN'T ONE MORE TIME I
JUST SECOND. OKAY SO IF YOU HAVE
LET'S SAY YOU HAVE YOU GET AD A.
YOU KNOW LAST YEAR FOR A
THOUSAND STUDENTS AND THEN YOU
GET. TEN DOLLARS IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING FOR EACH ONE
OF THOSE THOUSAND STUDENTS. OKAY
AND AND AND YOU HAVE.
.
TWENTY SPECIAL EDUCATION
STUDENTS. SO THE FOLLOWING YEAR
LET'S SAY THIS YEAR. I HAVE NINE
HUNDRED.
TOTAL STUDENTS BUT I HAVE.
TWENTY FIVE SPECIAL EDUCATION
STUDENTS SO NOW I HAVE LESS
FUNDING. BECAUSE MY TOTAL
ENROLLMENT WENT DOWN BUT I HAVE
AN INCREASED ABOUT A SPECIAL
EDUCATION STUDENTS SO I HAVE
LESS MONEY FOR ME TO WRITE HALF
JUST PROVIDE SERVICES FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS.
THAT'S A REAL ISSUE BECAUSE WE
HAVE DECLINING ROLE IN IN A
STATEWIDE RIGHT BUT WE HAVE
INCREASING SPECIAL EDUCATION
ENROLLMENT. SO SO THE INDIA IS
SO THAT I THINK IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST THINGS HAT REALLY NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED THAT AND JUST
YOU KNOW EQUALIZING THE FUNDING
STATEWIDE YOU KNOW FOR ALL THE
DIFFERENT.
FOR ALL THE DIFFERENT SELFLESS
IS IS REALLY YOU KNOW SOMETHING
THAT REALLY NEEDS TO BE DONE.
AND ALSO WE YOU KNOW WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THIS BEFORE LOOKING
BACKWARD OUT EVEN FUNDED TO WHAT
WE ARE FINDING TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN SO THAT I MEAN YOU KNOW
THAT. SO THERE'S THREE THINGS
RIGHT HERE THAT WE COULD TALK
ABOUT IT COULD BE ADDRESSED ALL
THAT GOES WITHOUT SAYING TOTALLY
AND I THINK. THAT MESSAGE IS
REALLY LOUD AND CLEAR.
BUT TO JUST KIND OF ZERO IN ON
THIS.
ISSUE OF THE NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT REFORMS EIGHTY SIX OR TWO
ON.
YOU KNOW I I I THINK I DO WE
ABSOLUTELY WOULD LOVE TO CREATE
A SYSTEM THAT WOULD.
.
BE MORE REFLECTIVE OF THE TRUE
COSTS.
THAT ARE BORNE BY THE SCHOOLS TO
PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY EDUCATION
FOR THESE STUDENTS.
YOU KNOW HOW DO WE AND AND MAYBE
DON'T HAVE AN ANSWER FOR ME
TODAY BUT IF YOU KNOW. IF YOU
DON'T I LOVE YOU TO GO BACK. TO
YOUR RESPECTIVE ORGANIZATIONS
SMALL DISTRICTS ACCESS CALLASPO
CT A CSE. SUPPER ORGANIZATIONS
WHATEVER ORGANIZATION MAY BE AND
SAY HEY YOU KNOW HOW DO WE HOW
DO WE LEARN.
HOW DO WE HOW WE IMPROVE THE
SYSTEM TO MAKE IT MORE EQUITABLE
WHILE?
UNDERSTANDING AND AVOIDING THE
CHALLENGES THAT LD TO THE
REFORMS IN NINETY EIGHT IN THE
FIRST PLACE FROM BEFORE. SO. I I
THINK BEFORE THE WAY IT WAS
WORKED WAS BASED UPON THE AMOUNT
OF STUDENTS THAT WERE AN STC
CLASSES EVERYONE REALLY IS
PUSHING TOWARDS THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENT RIGHT
NOW. SO THE IDEA ISN'T
NECESSARILY THAT WE'RE GOING TO.
HAVE A FORMULA THAT REFLECTS
THAT WEEK STUDENTS ARE CURRENTLY
BEING FOUND ELIGIBLE FOR AUTISM
AND THERE'S NO INCENTIVE FOR
THAT AND HERE HE FOUND ELIGIBLE
AT A HIGHER LEVEL. YET THE
STUDENTS YOU KNOW HAVE ARE
SEVERELY IMPACTED NEED A HIGHER
LEVEL OF SUPPORT SO KIND OF THAT
ARGUMENT TO ME RIGHT NOW.
DOESN'T REALLY A.
DOESN'T MEAN IT'S NOT REALLY
HOLDING TRUE FOR RIGHT NOW BEGIN
THEN WHY WOULDN'T WE YOU KNOW.
FIVE ANALOGY BELOW SOMETHING
ELSE WHERE WE YOU KNOW WHEN
COSTS AS MUCH MONEY AS YOU KNOW
IT DOESN'T REALLY MAKE SENTENCES
POINT. FOR THE STUDENTS THAT WE
ARE FINE BECAUSE WE'RE FINDING
THAT GROUP OF STUDENTS TO BE
ELIGIBLE SAID AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE NOT GETTING
ANY MORE FUNDING FOR.
SO.
RIGHT IS THAT MAKE DOES THAT
MAKE SENSE WHEN I'M SAYING YES
THE PROBLEM BEFORE I I GUESS WAS
THAT.
I MEAN IF YOU KNOW THE TOTAL
GROSS GENERALIZATION BUT BUT THE
ARGUMENTS WHILE THESE DISTRICTS
ARE JUST.
THEY HAVE SUCH AN INCENTIVE TO
DIAGNOSE EVERYBODY IN THEIR
MOTHER BECAUSE THEY'RE GETTING
ALL THIS EXTRA MONEY ASSOCIATED
WITH IT.
.
NOW YOU KNOW THAT WAS THE J.
FIFTY GOING INTO THIS ALPHA
RIGHT NOW BUT YOU'RE I THOUGHT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT. THE MIDDLE
ONE WHERE IT WAS GETTING RID OF
THEM THE ORIGINAL AND THEN GOING
TO NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT. SO SO.
YOU KNOW I I I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT REALLY NEEDS TO
BE LOOKED AT IN TERMS OF YOU
KNOW. NOT JUST THAT BASE AMOUNT
YOU KNOW FOR STUDENT BUT WE
REALLY DO NEED TO LOOK AT HOW DO
WE FIND.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR STUDENTS
WITH SIGNIFICANT DISABILITIES
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE AS WE KNOW
RIGHT NOW IN INCREASE IN THOSE
STUDENTS JUST OVERALL WITHOUT
LOOKING AT ANYTHING THOUGH. YOU
KNOW I DON'T PUT BY. AND. BY I
REALLY DO YOU ASK FOR INPUT FROM
YOUR FOLKS IN YOU AND YOU KNOW I
UNDERSTAND YOU YOU MAY NOT HAVE
THE ANSWERS RIGHT NOW.
BECAUSE W'RE YOU KNOW AND
REALLY WITH A MIND TOWARD THE
MACRO. CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING HERE TODAY MISS
CHRIST.
I DON'T KNOW THE PROTOCOL THAT
WE JUST CAN'T SAY WITH THE
INCREASES THAT SHE WAS
DESCRIBING EVEN THOUGH IT'S
DECLINING ENROLLMENT I WORK IN A
RAPIDLY FAST GROWING DISTRICT
OPENING IN SCHOOL A YEAR ON
AVERAGE A CAPACITY. AND YOU HAVE
TO HAVE SPECIAL ED TEACHERS TO
WORK IN THE NINETEEN YEARS I
WORKED IN SPECIAL AT. THE
REQUIREMENTS TO BE A SPECIAL ED
TEACHER HAVE CHANGED TENFOLD
EVERYDAY THERE'S A NEW
AUTHORIZATION THERE'S A NEW TEST
THERE'S A NEW. COURSE NOBODY
WANTS TO GO INTO THIS JOB SO I
THINK FIGURING OUT WAYS. TO
FIND.
WAYS TO ANSWER THE TEACHER
SHORTAGE. FOR SPECIAL ED.
IN WITH THE ARM FUNDING.
REQUIREMENTS OUR CHALLENGE AS
WELL THAT I THINK NEED TO BE
BROUGHT INTO THE CONVERSATION
TOTALLY FORGIVE ME IF I'M BIRD
WALKING BUT. I THINK THAT'S A
HUGE CRITERION HUGE FACTOR IN
THIS.
YEAH.
YEAH A LOT OF CHALLENGES YES.
THE ONLY MEMBER MCCARTY YES ME
JUMP IN THIS AS WELL THOUGHT I
KNOW THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF
THAT DISCONNECT SO WHEN MR PORN
TINO ASKED WHO WHAT TO PUT THE
MONEY PEACE AND LCF EFFORT OR
KEEP IT IN SIX OR TWO AND FUNDED
PROPERLY AND. HAVE EQUALIZE THAT
SEEMS TO BE. THE DIRECTION AND
PARTIALLY BECAUSE THERE'S GOOD
POLICY CHANGES. THAT THAT WERE
IN THERE AND. YOU KNOW
MAINSTREAMING THE KIDS AND AND
AND ALL THE OTHER PIECES TO THAT
AND YOU SHAKE YOUR HEAD BUT I
STILL DON'T UNDERSTAND. WHY WE
WOULD KEEP THE FAITH THE SAME
FUNDING MODEL? IN OTHER WORDS
YOU'RE CRACKS IS IT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE IF YOU HAVE A DECLINING
ENROLLMENT. A SCHOOL A SCHOOL
LIKE WE HAVE ALL ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE SHOWING
THERE IS IT INCREASE IN SPECIAL
ED POPULATION THAT THAT'S THE
POT OF DOLLAR GOING TO SERVE
THESE KIDS GOES DOWN.
SO THEN.
WHY WOULDN'T YOU YOU KNOW HAVE
SOME TYPE OF ELSE IF THAT
FUNDING FOR IT AND YOU GIVE THE
DISTRICT'S MONEY BASED UPON WHO
THEY SERVE LIKE WE DO WITH? YOU
KNOW THE UNDUE PLACATE ACCOUNT
WE CAN KEEP THE SAME POLICIES IN
PLACE.
BUT FOCUSING ON THE ACTUAL
DOLLARS TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR
SON FAIRNESS SO WHY WOULDN'T WE
DO THAT IT SEEMS. SO LOGICAL MET
ONE OF MY MISSING HERE.
I THINK WHAT SHE MIGHT HAVE BEEN
SAYING IS A QUICK FIX IS AT
LEAST FUND.
WHEN WE HAVE AN INCREASE IN
SPECIAL ED AND A DECREASE IN
ROME AND WE SHOULD CONTINUE TO
GET THAT EIGHTY SIX SO TO
FUNDING AND LIKE IT A LOT WHAT
WHAT WHAT WE JUST GO ALL THE
WAY.
BY WOULDN'T YOU JUST FIND NOT
BASED UPON HOW MANY STUDENTS YOU
HAVE IN THE DISTRICT BUT HOW
MANY STUDENTS YOU HAVE. IN IN
THIS. DISABILITY BUT THIS
POPULATION IN THE I THINK THAT
IF YOU START FROM SCRATCH IF WE
HAD. STARTED BUILDING OUR SYSTEM
RIGHT HERE ON THIS TABLE I WOULD
THINK YOU WOULD DO IT THAT WAY
RATHER THAN THIS. BACKWARDS WAY
SO WHAT'S A COUPLE WHAT WHY ARE
WE MIGHT MAYBE THIS IS LA ON
FINANCE QUESTION FOR OUR. BUDGET
HEARING BUT WHY ARE WE DOING
THAT.
WELL I THINK.
IF WE LOOK AT THE TRUE COST OF
SPECIAL ED THAT'S THAT'S BIG.
AND SO WE CERTAINLY SHOULD HAVE
THOSE ASPIRATIONAL GOALS TO FUND
THE TRUE COST OF ALL OF THE
DISABILITIES AND HOW THOSE.
CONTINUE TO RISE EACH YEAR BUT
FINDING A FUNDING SOURCE THAT
ADDRESSES THE MORE. EXPENSIVE OR
MORE CHALLENGING MORE.
STAFF INTENSE DISABILITIES AT A
HIGHER LEVEL MEAN I THINK WE'RE
OPEN TO.
MORE FUNDING TO HELP OUR KIDS.
AND WHATEVER THAT TAKES BUT AM I
DO THINK WE NEED A LITTLE MORE
WORK ON PROVIDING. WHAT DOES
THAT?
ASPIRATIONAL FUNDING MODEL LOOK
LIKE.
THE DISSENTING OPINION THE ROOF
FELT LIKE IT SHOULD BE NOW SEE A
FAT BUT I MEAN I AGREE SIX OF
TWO MAY HAVE. POSITION HOWEVER.
AGAIN SPECIAL HAS TO BE PART OF
THE MAINSTREAM AND I WOULD LOOK
AT THE FUNDING FORMULA DIFFERENT
YOU KNOW BE LOOKING AT UNDER PUT
ON DUPLICATE ACCOUNTS. WITH
SPECIAL ED.
I WOULD.
BUT THAT AS A DUPLICATE ACCOUNTS
SO IT IS. ETERNAL LOOK AT THAT
THOSE NUMBERS EVEN YOU HAVE
ENGLISH LEARNERS THEY'RE STILL
THEY WILL RECEIVE AN EXTRA
AMOUNT SO JUST LOOKING AT. THAT
FORMULA DIFFERENTLY UNDER THE
LENS OF SPECIAL LET ME BE
SOMETHING TO LOOK AT. BECAUSE
YOU REALLY I I TRULY BELIEVE IT
NEEDS TO BE INTEGRATED WITHIN
THE WHOLE. INSTRUCTIONAL PROGRAM
YEAH UP TO THIS BUT THERE'S TWO
THERE'S TWO THINGS ARE
EVALUATING YOU KNOW IT. THIS
THIS STUDENT'S NEEDS AND WHAT'S
THE BEST OUTCOMES FOR THE
POPULATION WERE TRYING TO HELP
IN. MAINSTREAM INTEGRATION.
THAT'S HOW FAR CONVERSATION AND
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT WE FIND
YOU FOR THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING IT SOUND DISTRICTS. I HAVE
SOME LEGACY OF PREPARATION THAT
THEY'RE GETTING A LITTLE BUMP
RIGHT NOW AND THINK PROBABLY USE
THAT MONEY TO TAKE CARE OF ALL
THEIR OTHER NEEDS WHICH YOU GUYS
HAVE IN YOUR DISTRICTS AND. BUT
DOESN'T THAT SAY MAKES THE MOST
SENSE FOR STATEWIDE ALLOCATION.
AND.
OKAY THANK YOU.
MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT CALL REALLY
OF NECESSITY.
THANK YOU.
SO WHETHER THINGS THAT THAT
SEEMS TO COME UP A LOT WE HEARD
IT FROM THE ALLEY OF
PRESENTATION WE ALSO.
AND SOME OF THE OTHER POLICY.
IF THEY KEEP SAYING THAT WELL
WHAT WE'RE WORRIED ABOUT IS WE
ACTUALLY PAY FOR THE NEED WE'RE
JUST GONNA SET OF EYES MORE
PEOPLE MARKETS MOVING IN THE
SPECIAL ED AND ALSO IT MEANS IT
WAS LIKE THE MAINSTREAM.
I I I I I WANNA GIVE YOU ENOUGH
TO TO RESPOND TO THAT FREQUENTLY
MADE COMMENTS.
WE ALREADY HEARD IT HERE IN
THIS HEARING AT HER SCENE IN
POLICY PAPERS.
.
MY TWO I'D APPRECIATE YOUR
THOUGHTS AND AND AND AND AND THE
SPONSOR TO TO TO TO THAT
CONCERNED IT SEEMS TO BE RES
FREQUENTLY.
I DON'T SEE FUNDING OF A
DISABILITY. AS AN INCENTIVE TO
KEEP A CHILD IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
EDUCATORS ARE HERE TO ENSURE
THAT OUR STUDENTS ARE SUCCESSFUL
IN THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE
ENVIRONMENT. NOW THAT MAY BE
MORE INTENSIVE CARE AT FIRST AS
WE BEGAN TO.
TRANSITION THEM INTO A LEAST
RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENT.
BUT I DON'T KNOW OF ANY BUSINESS
OR SUPERINTENDENT OR EDUCATOR.
THAT LOOKS TO IDENTIFY STUDENTS
SO THEY CAN GET MORE MONEY.
I'VE SEEN AN INCREASED AND
DIVERSIONS TO SPECIAL ACT
THROUGH THE MTS LASTS ROLLOUT
AND THE. RESPONSE TO
INTERVENTION SIR IN SOME WAYS
OFFSETTING STUDENTS FROM GETTING
THE SERVICES THEY NEED. BUT NOT
THE OF HER IDENTIFYING AND
PAYING FOR THE SERVICES.
ANYONE ELSE WITH HER THOUGHTS.
WELL BEING A MOTHER YOU KNOW MY
SON WAS A GIVEN OUT ELECTRONIC
DEVICE. BECAUSE.
HE IS LEARNING BUT WE DON'T
KNOW HOW MUCH HE'S LEARNING IN
THE CLASSROOM. AND.
.
WE'RE GOING THROUGH THE
TRANSITION OF MAYBE GETTING A
ONE ONE EIGHH WHICH OF THE
DISTRICT IS NOT REALLY WANTING
TO. GIVE ORDER BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE THE FUNDING. AND IT
WILL REQUIRE HE'S MAINSTREAM
THIRTEEN UM AT LEAST TWO HOURS
OF THE DAY. SO HE GOES TO
SPECIAL ED CLASSROOM AND THEN
GOING TO MAINSTREAM.
BUT.
.
SO THAT COMES AGAIN TO DO THIS.
BASICALLY WHAT WE HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSING ABOUT THE FINDING AND
I'M.
HAVING THE ABILITY TO MAYBE.
AS A LIBERATING THEM. LEARNING
FOR THE STUDENT.
FROM.
AND I I THINK THAT THE INCENTIVE
IS SIMPLY NOT THERE IN IN THE
SENSE THAT THE IT PETER RACKS
THAT IT WANTS. GOALS TO BE MET
AND GROWTH TO BE MADE. OUR OWN
DASHBOARD SAYS THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE A SO THAT THERE IS
ABSOLUTELY ZERO INCENTIVE FOR
KEEPING A CHILD.
AT A POOR LEVEL OF FUNCTIONING.
BE IT ACADEMICALLY SOCIALLY AT
ANY LEVEL SO I I DON'T THINK
THAT THAT'S THE.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S A DAY I
WOULD HATE TO THINK THAT THERE
IS A DISTRICT OR.
AND EDUCATOR. TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
I THINK WE'RE MORE PROFESSIONAL
THAN THAT.
WELL I THINK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR SPONSOR A DO SHARE YOUR
CONCERNS AS WELL I THINK.
SOMETIMES I WONDER IF THAT
SIMPLY AN EXCUSE TO PREVENT.
US FROM PUTTING IN THE
RESOURCES WE NEED TO MEET THE
NEEDS SO THANK YOU.
WELL. GREAT DISCRETION LOTS MORE
FOLLOW UP I REALLY DO MEAN IT
WHEN I SAY THAT WE LOVE YOU TO.
GO BACK TO YOUR VARIOUS FOLKS
AND I KNOW WE'VE GOT PEOPLE HERE
ALSO FROM. AS HERE YOU FOLKS
FROM THE CHARTER SCHOOL
CESSATION FOLKS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS.
FOLKS FROM CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BOARDS ASSOCIATION AND SOME OF
THE FOLKS FROM THE FROM THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION ADVOCACY
COMMUNITY AND WE REALLY ARE
LOOKING FOR. HELP IN TRYING TO
GET OUR HEADS AROUND THESE THESE
KIND OF. GREAT CHALLENGES AS WE
TRY TO CRAFT. A MORE EQUITABLE
SYSTEM THAT WORKS BETTER FOR
EVERYBODY SO AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PARTICIPATION TODAY BUT
THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING.
I WILL BE CALLING ON YOU SO
THANK YOU BYE.
ALL RIGHT NOW WE'RE GONNA BE
HEARING A PERSPECTIVE FROM THE
STATE YOU KNOW THE CENTER CENTER
MORE LOCK ASKED ABOUT DIFFERENT
A FINANCE WE WILL BE HEARING.
TODAY FRONT APARTMENT OCCASION.
AND ALSO STATEWIDE SPECIAL
EDUCATION TASK FORCES WE'VE GOT
MAUREEN FOR NASA CO EXECUTOR
ACTOR FOR THE STATEWIDE SPECIAL
EDUCATION TASK FORCE. AND ALSO
KRISTEN WRITERS DIRECTORS
MASOCHISTIC EDUCATION DIVISION.
FROM THE COMFORT OF HER
MEDICATION AND WE WERE VERY MUCH
LOOKING FORWARD TO THEIR
PERSPECTIVES FROM THE STATE. AND
CERTAINLY A FASTER MORE LIKE A
STILL IN THE BUILDING I'M SURE
HE'D ENJOY COMING BACK IN
HEARING FROM. OUTSIDE THESE TWO
STATEWIDE PERSPECTIVE SO WE'LL
START. WITH THAT MISS AMBER
NESS.
SO MUCH.
IN THE IN THE FIRST PLACE I
ABSOLUTELY WANT TO THANK YOU
JUST SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE AND
FOR ACTUALLY TAKING US. US BEING
SPECIAL ED FROM THAT BACK FORTY
TWO THIS LEVEL OF HEARING. IT IS
SO WONDERFUL TO HAVE THIS KIND
OF LOOK AT WHAT A GREAT NEED
THIS IS
MY HOPE.
AND I DO NEED TO SAY THAT VICKY
WAS NOT ABLE TO MAKE IT TODAY
SHE WAS BY ACOG SECT OF DIRECTOR
ON THE TASK FORCE AND HER
HUSBAND HAS BEEN HOSPITALIZED SO
SHE'S VERY SORRY. BUT THE
HANDOUT THAT YOU'LL GET FROM US
HAS BOTH OF OUR CONTACT
INFORMATION AND OUR COMMITMENT
TO YOU IS THAT WE WILL BE ANY
KIND OF FOLLOW UP HELP FOR YOU
IN ANY FURTHER CONVERSATION. OF
WHICH WERE VERY CLEARLY
INDICATED FROM TODAY THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE MORE. JUST
JUST TO HELP CLARIFY SOME
THINGS.
SO I WAS ABLE TO BE PART OF THE
AB SIX OH TWO CONVERSATIONS AND
I THOUGHT A LITTLE BIT OF
HISTORY. GOING INTO THIS US
SPECIAL ED FINANCE WOULD HELP.
IN NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN WHEN AB
SIX OH TWO WAS WRITTEN. IT WAS
TOO ADDI INCENTIVIZE THE THE
PAST AND IT WAS TO EQUALIZE THE
DIFFERENCES SO YOU'VE HEARD SOME
REFERENCE TO THE FACT THAT
DISTRICTS WERE FUNDED SO
DIFFERENTLY AND IT WAS ACTUALLY.
UNITS OF FUNDING TEACHERS AND
AIDES DEPENDING ON HOW IT IS
THAT YOU DID WHAT YOU DID. AND
WHAT YOUR SUPPORT SERVICE RATIO
WAS IT WAS A VERY COMPLEX
FORMULA AND IT DIFFERED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND IT
BECAME SO UNEQUAL THAT DISTRICTS
JUST LIKE YOU'VE HEARD TODAY
WERE TELLING THE LEGISLATURE.
THIS ISN'T FAIR THIS IS A
REASONABLE WE NEED TO CHANGE IT.
AND SO THERE WAS A VERY LONG
CONVOLUTED CONVERSATION TO TRY
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT WOULD BE A
GOOD WAY TO DO THIS. SO WE DID
LOOK AT D. INCENTIVIZING.
AND THE ISSUE WAS THAT IF WE
WENT TO AN EIGHTY EIGHT BASED
MODEL THEN ALL OF THOSE
DIFFERENCES ACROSS THE STATE.
COULD BE KIND OF AVERAGED OUT.
BUT YOU STILL HAD TO DO YOUR
AVERAGING FROM THIS UNEQUAL
POINT.
AND SO THE IDEA OF. COMING TO AN
EIGHTY A BASIS BUT OVER TIME
EQUALIZING THOSE RATES UP WAS
THE SOLUTION AT THE TIME AND SO
SEE THE PROBLEM IS WE'VE STILL
NEVER GOTTEN THERE. AND THAT'S
WHY EQUALIZATION WAS MENTIONED
BY SO MANY PEOPLE NOW BECAUSE IF
MY EIGHTY YEAR RATE IS FOUR
HUNDRED AND SIXTY DOLLARS IN
YEARS IS SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLARS.
IT'S NOT FAIR SO THE
EQUALIZATION ISSUE IS JUST
ABSOLUTELY ONE OF THE MOST
CRITICAL ARM. ISSUES OF
CONTINUATION.
BUT THE OTHER WAS THAT WE DID GO
TO A K. TWELVE EIGHTY A MODEL
AND WE'RE RESPONSIBLE IN SPECIAL
ED FROM BIRTH. TO TWENTY TWO SO
WE HAVE STUDENTS WHO DON'T GET A
REGULAR HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA WHO
NEED TRANSITION SERVICES WHO
NEED SERVICES. TO BECOME THE
MOST PRODUCTIVE CITIZENS THEY
CAN BE AND WE HAVE THIS
BURGEONING PRESCHOOL POPULATION
THAT HAS JUST EXPLODED ACROSS.
THE STATE AND SO OUT OF OUR K.
TWELVE EIGHTY A WERE SUPPOSED TO
BE COVERING THIS ENTIRE RANGE OF
SERVICES.
SO I JUST WANTED TO MAKE THOSE
PARTICULAR POINTS THAT HERE WE
HAVE THESE HUGE INCREASES IN IN
US STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES.
AND REALLY THE ISSUE THAT IS
MOST UNREASONABLE ABOUT EIGHTY
SIX SO TOO IS THAT IT IS ONLY
KATE TWELVE DOESN'T INCLUDE
PRESCHOOL DOESN'T INCLUDE
TRANSITION AGE.
AND IT IS STILL UNEQUAL IN IT
SARAH IN ITS RATES ACROSS THE
DISTRICT.
SO THE THE SHEEP THAT WE HAVE
PROVIDED FOR YOU. ACTUALLY TWO
YEARS THREE YEARS AGO NOW WE
PROVIDED EVERY SINGLE ONE OF YOU
LEGISLATORS SENATOR PAN IS MY
CENTER THANK YOU AND. KEVIN
MCCARTY IS MY ASSEMBLYMAN EACH
OFFICE GOT ONE OF OUR REPORTS
AND SO I KNOW YOU HAVE SOMEWHERE
IN YOUR HISTORY. THE ENTIRE
REPORT AND WHEN DICK AND I
PRESENTED THIS WE SAID WE DON'T
WANT THIS TO BE A REPORT THAT
WILL SIT ON YOUR SHELVES WHAT WE
WANT IS THAT FOR THIS TO BE A
CALL TO ACTION.
AND I AM DELIGHTED TO SAY THAT
SO MANY THINGS HAVE HAPPENED.
SINCE THIS REPORT HAS COME OUT
SO. OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION FOR EXAMPLE HAVE
ESPECIALLY WITH KRISTEN'S
LEADERSHIP THERE AND AND GLENN
PRICE.
AND TOM TRUCKS THAT HAVE REALLY
TAKEN THE WHOLE ISSUE OF ONE'S
SYSTEM AS A MODEL. IN OUR
DISTRICTS ARE FOLLOWING THAT
ISSUE TRYING TO GET KIDS MORE
INCLUDED AND I AM. AND
THAT-WHOLE ONE SYSTEM IDEAS
FABULOUS
ART COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING HAS REVAMPED THE
GENERAL ED ODD CREDENTIAL IN IS
IN THE PROCESS OF REVAMPING THE
SPECIAL ED CREDENTIAL. WE DO
HAVE MORE M. TSS ACROSS THE
STATE WE HAVE GREAT MENTAL%
HEALTH MODELS. OF MEN THAT WERE
RECOMMENDED FROM OUR BEST
PRACTICES A LOT OF THE
ASSESSMENT ACCOUNTABILITY
PIECES.
HAVE BEEN TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT.
BUT. THE LEGISLATURE HAS NOT
SINCE THAT TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
BUDGET CUT. DONE AUGHT ANYTHING
OF SIGNIFICANCE IN THE AREA OF
SPECIAL ED FUNDING. AND I NEED
TO AY THAT WHEN MY CURSED ASKED
US TO START THIS PROCESS WHICH
IS NOW.
SIX YEARS AGO HE SAID WE ARE
JUST BEGINNING L. CFF WE ARE
JUST BEGINNING EL CAP.
DON'T MESS WITH SPECIAL ED
FUNDING IN THE EL CAP YET.
SO THAT'S REALLY WHERE THAT CAME
FROM SO WE LOOKED AT THE WHOLE
PICTURE ABOUT WELL WHAT IS
SPECIAL AND FINDING WHAT CAN WE
RECOMMEND.
TO THE LEGISLATURE SO WE HAVE
THIS WHOLE LIST. OF IDEAS. AND.
AND I WISH THAT SOMEONE MCCARTY
WERE STILL HERE BECAUSE IF YOU
LOOK AT THAT EIGHTY A RATE.
REALLY THE IDEA OF LCF I WAS
THAT EVERYBODY GETS AN EIGHTY A
RATE. AND SO OUR WHOLE POINT IS
THAT ARE ADA RATES IN SPECIAL ED
ARE UNEQUAL. IF YOU WERE TO DO
ANY KIND OF MODEL THAT SAYS
LET'S EQUALIZE THAT'S WHERE THE
FIXES. AND I DO BELIEVE THAT IT
IS IMPORTANT TO CONTINUE TO
PROTECT SPECIAL ED FUNDING AS
SPECIAL ED FUNDING IT'S AN
ENTITLEMENT. FROM FEDERAL LAW IT
IS THAT WHICH GUARANTEES THAT WE
PROVIDE THE SERVICES TO OUR
STUDENTS. AND SO I THINK THAT IS
THE THE BIGGEST SOLUTION AND YOU
WILL SEE. IN OUR LIST OF
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WAS NUMBER
ONE.
IT WAS NUMBER ONE THREE YEARS
AGO IT'S NUMBER ONE. TODAY
BECAUSE IT IS PROBABLY THE MOST
CRITICAL AND IT'S BECAUSE OF
EVERYTHING THAT YOU'VE ALREADY
HEARD THIS MORNING SO I WON'T GO
INTO.
THOSE DIFFERENCES IN RATES
AGAIN. OUT BUT THE SECOND ONE IS
THIS ENSURING THE AVAILABILITY
OF EARLY INTERVENTION PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES AND I'D LIKE TO
THANK YOU SENATOR ALAN FOR ALL
THAT YOU'VE ALREADY DONE IN THAT
REGARD WE APPRECIATE ALL YOUR
EFFORTS.
PRESCHOOL NUMBERS HAVE INCREASED
SO DRAMATICALLY AND THE NEEDS OF
THE STUDENTS HAVE INCREASED AND
THERE ISN'T. ANYWHERE NEAR THE
ADEQUATE FUNDING TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES AND IT DOES COME FROM
THE K. TWELVE FUNDING. IN ORDER
TO PROVIDE IT AT THE PRE SCHOOL
LEVEL.
AND SO THAT IT THAT IS
DEFINITELY OUR SECOND.
THE THIRD RECOMMENDATION ABOUT
FUNDING SELF IS BASED ON EIGHTY
EIGHT GOES BACK TO THE ADVOCACY
ISSUE THAT HAS ALSO BEEN BROUGHT
UP. BY SEVERAL OTHER PEOPLE
HERE.
AND YOU'VE ALSO HEARD DISCUSSION
ALREADY ABOUT THE THE ISSUE OF
GROWTH AND DECLINE SO BY MYSELF
BUT I HAVE ONE OF MY DISTRICTS
LOSES A HUNDREDSTUDENTS. BUT
ANOTHER GROWS A HUNDRED IN
GETTING THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
BUT HERE YOU ARE THIS DISTRICT
WITH ONE HUNDRED MORE STUDENTS
TO SERVE. AND SO THAT THAT HAS
ALWAYS BEEN.
.
AN ISSUE AND HAS CONTINUED TO
BE.
ARE WE REALLY ARE AT NUMBER FIVE
WAS TO ENSURE THAT WE INCREASE
OUR THAT WE CONTINUE. AS SOME
DOLLARS THAT HAVE BEEN PROTECTED
LIKE NECESSARY SMALL SABAS. THE
EDUCATION RELATED MENTAL HEALTH
CARE SERVICES. AND AT THE TIME
WE RECOMMENDED THIS OUT OF HOME
CARE FUNDING FOR FOSTER YOUTH IN
THE MEANTIME THIS LEGISLATURE'S
CHANGE THE WHOLE FOSTER YOUTH
PLACEMENT AND A GROUP HOME
ISSUE.
SO THAT IS AN ISSUE THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO REALLY READ
ADDRESS AS UP FOSTER HOMES AND
STR TEEPEES CHANGE AS WELL. WITH
IN THAT I DIDN'T SPECIFICALLY
NOTE ON YOUR PAPER BUT IN OUR
FAMILY ENGAGEMENT SECTION.
WE HAD RECOMMENDED FULLY FUNDING
FAMILY EMPOWERMENT CENTERS AND I
THINK YOU HEARD A VERY.
IMPASSIONED PLEAS THAT ALL
PARENTS DESERVE THE
OPPORTUNITIES OUGHT TO HAVE A
FAMILY EMPOWERMENT CENTER. AND
SO THAT WAS ALSO ONE OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS.
I WILL SAY THAT OUR
RECOMMENDATION NUMBER SIX ABOUT
UPDATING ELECTRONIC DATA SYSTEMS
HAS IN FACT BEEN WELL ADDRESSED
BY THE DPARTMENT OF EDUCATIONAL
READY WE HAVE MUCH BETTER
COORDINATION. AND A AND THAT IS
CONTINUING. TO BE IMPROVED.
AS LOW INCIDENCE FUNDING WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER AND AND OUR
SEVENTH RECOMMENDATION WAS ABOUT
INCREASING THAT BUT CHANGING THE
DEFINITION TO THE FEDERAL
DEFINITION.
BECAUSE THERE ARE IF YOU USE THE
FEDERAL DEFINITION THERE ARE
MORE STUDENTS. WHO WOULD THEN BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE FUNDING BUT
YOU'VE ALSO HEARD HOW INADEQUATE
THAT LEVEL OF FUNDING AT LESS
THAN FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR
STUDENTS WHO MIGHT REQUIRE? TEN
OR TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS WORTH
OF SERVICES IN A YEAR.
WE ALSO RECOMMENDED THAT.
WORKABILITY B. AN OPPORTUNITY
THAT IS AVAILABLE FOR ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS WHO WERE OF HIGH SCHOOL
AGE. AND GIVEN THAT ONE OF OUR
BIGGEST. ASSIGNMENTS IN THE TASK
FORCE WORK WAS THAT WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO INCREASE
OUTCOMES%
FOR STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
WORKABILITY IS THE ONE PROGRAM
THAT LETS US A DOCUMENT OR
ACCOUNTABILITY AND ALLOWS ALL
STUDENTS AND HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE SOME KIND
OF.
MEANING INTO THE AGE OF TWENTY
TWO.
YOU HEARD FROM ONE OF THE
SUPERINTENDENTS ABOUT
TRANSPORTATION COSTS BEING SO
IMPORTANT THAT IS INCREDIBLY
EXPENSIVE PARTICULARLY IN A
SMALL RURAL OR.
LARGER COUNTIES AND THAT'S IT.
WOULD DEFINITELY RECOMMENDED
THAT THAT BE INCREASED. I WOULD
LIKE TO SAY AND THINK YOU ARE TO
LEGISLATOR FOR NUMBER TEN WE
ASKED THAT ALL SUPPOSED TO HAVE
ADR GRANTS AND IN FACT THAT HAS
BEEN. THE ONE FISCAL.
RESPONSE THAT OUR LEGISLATURE
HAS GIVEN US AT ABOUT FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO EACH CELL BY
THAT THAT IS A GREAT WAY TO HELP
WITH. A WORKING RELATIONS WITH
PARENTS.
AND THEN WE HAVE SEVERAL
DIFFERENT A COUPLE DIFFERENT
IDEAS HERE ABOUT FACILITIES
INCLUDING A SERVICES FOR. FROM
BIRTH ALL THE WAY TO TWENTY TWO.
AND THEN THERE ARE THREE
RECOMMENDATIONS AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL AND TO THE OF THIS ISSUE
OF FORTY PERCENT IS IS ONE THAT
OUR LEGISLATURE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA HAS FREQUENTLY
ACTUALLY ADOPTED A JOINT
RESOLUTION. THAT HAS GONE TO
CONGRESS TO SAY. IT SURE WOULD
HELP IF YOU WOULD COME THROUGH
WITH WHAT YOU SAID IN THE
ORIGINAL ID A. THERE HAVE BEEN
BILLS PASSED AND BROUGHT FORWARD
EVERY YEAR THAT SAY PLEASE GET
THAT FUNDING TO FORTY PERCENT IT
WOULD MAKE SUCH A DIFFERENCE TO
EVERY STATE BUT PARTICULARLY TO
CALIFORNIA. AND.
.
SO THAT'S ONE THING THAT WE
COULD DO IT IS UP TO CONGRESS.
BUT AT LEAST THIS LEGISLATURE
COULD CONSIDER ADOPTING A
RESOLUTION. AND THEN AS YOU HAD
MENTIONED SENATOR PAT ANOTHER OF
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS IS ABOUT.
GETTING RID OF THOSE BARRIERS TO
MEDICAL AND I ELLIE A. FANS.
AND THEN THERE'S ONE OUT ONE
LAST ONE ABOUT ENSURING THAT ALL
OF OUR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES STILL HAVE THE
RIGHTS TO.
FEDERAL SCHOLARSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES AND AND THAT WAS
CHANGED FOR. AN UNREASONABLE.
A CHANGE IN THE PAST.
SO I DID THAT AS QUICKLY AS I
COULD WANTING TO SAY SO MUCH
MOREAND BECKY HAS SENT MORE TO
THAT I'D BE HAPPY TO PASS ON AS
WELL. BUT I ALSO KNOW WE HAVE
LOTS OF INFORMATION FROM KRISTIN
WHO WAS MY LIAISON AT THE STATE
BOARD FOR THE TASK FORCE AND SO.
THANK YOU FOR BEING BAD FOR US.
APPRECIATE HAVING THESE TWO
PERSPECTIVES HERE AT THE PALACE
OF. CHRISTIAN RIGHT.
.
I WOULD LIKE TO ALSO INTRODUCE
HER HEATHER CARLSON WHO IS HERE
TODAY.
WITH THE FISCAL LANDS.
I KNOW DR BARBER COULD NOT BE
WITH US TODAY AND HAVE THEIR
FEARS ABOUT THE KNOWLEDGE THAT
THERE'S QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
SPECIFIC PAPERS THAT YOU RECEIVE
JUST RECENTLY. SO I I JUST WANNA
DO A COUPLE EXCLAMATION MARKS IN
A COUPLE CLARIFICATIONS ONE IS
THAT JUST TO LET YOU KNOW SORT
OF WHAT WERE MAPPING TO AS A
STATE AND WORKING WITH ALL OUR
ELEAZAR AND YOU GOT A GREAT
FLAVOR FROM ALL OF OUR.
SOME LOCALS EARLIER AND I THINK.
WHAT THEY SHARED WITH YOU IS
REALLY WHAT WE'RE HEARING FROM
DISTRICTS AROUND THE STATE SO
VERY CONSISTENT MESSAGES WITH
WHAT WE ALSO HEAR?
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT. AS
A STATE WE ARE LOOKING AT MORE
THAN EVER IS REALLY THAT MAPPING
TO EMPLOYMENT SO WE'RE WORKING
ACROSS SECTORS WITH OUR
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION OUR
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT OUR DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES SOCIAL
SERVICES HEALTH CARE. TO REALLY
TRY TO ENSURE THAT EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF OUR STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS
TO EVERY SINGLE SKILL THAT THEY
WOULD NEED IN ORDER TO GAIN
EMPLOYMENT AND REALLY TO BECOME
AN ACTIVE PRODUCTIVE CITIZEN
WHICH IS. REALLY THE IMPETUS FOR
WHY WE HAVE KIDS IN SCHOOL AND
SO I JUST WANT TO REALLY
HIGHLIGHT AND REITERATE. THE
EARLY EDUCATION PIECE AND SO IF
THERE WAS ONE THING IF THE MAGIC
WAND HAPPEN IF THERE WAS ONE
THING THAT REALLY. WE BELIEVE
WOULD CHANGE THE TRAJECTORY FOR
OUR STUDENTS IT WOULD BE THE
ACCESS TO EARLY PRESCHOOL
INCLUSIVE SETTINGS AND IT'S NOT
JUST BECAUSE WE WANT KIDS HAVING
ACCESS TO EARLY PRESCHOOL
BECAUSE WE DO. IT'S ALSO BECAUSE
OF WHAT HAPPENS AS A COMMUNITY.
IN TERMS OF SETTING A CULTURE
THAT EVERYONE BELONGS IN OUR
SYSTEM AND WHAT WE SEE NOW IS WE
SEE A LOT OF STUDENTS WHO START
OFF IN SEGREGATED PRESCHOOL
SETTINGS AND THEY NEVER LEAVE.
AND SO THERE WAS A QUESTION
EARLIER ABOUT NON PUBLIC SCHOOLS
WERE SERVING ABOUT.
OUT OF OUR SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES IN CALIFORNIA
ABOUT FIFTEEN THOUSAND OF THEM
ARE SERVED IN NON PUBLIC SCHOOLS
I'M TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY SIX.
NON PUBLIC SCHOOLS WHICH SHOULD
BE DELINEATED FROM OR DIFFERENT
YOU DID FROM PRIVATE SCHOOLS. OF
NON PUBLIC SCHOOLS ARE SCHOOLS
THAT ARE CERTIFIED THROUGH THE
STATE TO SERVE STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES AND THEY DO RECEIVE
ID A FUNDS THROUGH THEIR SELF OR
ELLIJAY. AND PUBLIC PRIVATE
SCHOOLS ARE NOT SCHOOLS THAT WE
CERTIFY IN THAT REGARD AND THEY
DO NOT RECEIVE PUBLIC FUNDING.
AND SO.
.
SO IN TERMS OF IF WE'RE LOOKING
AT WHAT THE BIGGEST BANG FOR OUR
BUCK IS IT'S REALLY ENSURING
THAT WE HAVE THOSE EARLY PRE
SCHOOL SETTINGS NOT ONLY ARE
YOU.
CHANGING THE HEARTS AND MINDS OF
THE CHILDREN THAT STARTED IN THE
SETTINGS BUT I WOULD BE REMISS
IF I DID NOT QUOTE MY FRIEND
JOKE SAVIOR WHO'S THE DIRECTOR
OF THE PROBLEM OF REHAB.
WHO SAYS THAT THE BUSINESS
OWNERS OF TOMORROW ARE THE
PRESCHOOLERS OF TODAY THEY'RE
SITTING IN THOSE PRE SCHOOL
CLASSROOMS LEARNING ABOUT THE
STUDENTS THAT THEY'RE WITH? AND
SO WE'RE TRYING TO CREATE THIS
COMMUNITY WHERE EVERYONE BELONGS
BUT WE START SEGREGATING EARLY
AND WE SEND SOME REAL SPECIFIC
MESSAGES SO I KNOW YOU'VE HEARD
A LOT OF THE OTHER LOGISTICS
TODAY THERE'S A COUPLE OTHER
POINTS THAT I WANTED TO MAKE
JUST IN TERMS OF. OUR OWN
RESPONSIBILITIES AS A AS A STATE
AND AS A DEPARTMENT WITH
ACCEPTING THE MORE THAN ONE
BILLION DOLLARS THAT WE ACCEPT
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WERE
ACCEPTING. THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
ENSURE THAT STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES TO GET ACCESS TO. A
FREE APPROPRIATE PUBLIC
EDUCATION THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE
ENVIRONMENT AND WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN THAT REALLY MEANS THAT IT
STARTS AS EVERY STUDENTS IN
GENERAL AT STUDENT LIKE WE HEARD
EARLIER. AND THAT SCHOOL STARTS
WITH THEIR GENERAL ED PEERS AND
YOU DON'T NEED TO TAKE IT TO GET
INTO THAT YOU DON'T HAVE TO EARN
YOUR WAY INTO GENERAL LET EVEN
IN PRESCHOOL. REALLY YOU YOU
HAVE TO EARN A TICKET OUT AND
THAT'S ONLY AFTER EVERY SUPPORT
AND SERVICES BEEN PUT IN PLACE.
THE WORD HOLDING AS A DEPARTMENT
AS WE'RE DOING OUR MONITORING OR
HOLDING DISTRICTS TO A MUCH
HIGHER STANDARD AROUND.
ENSURING THAT STUDENTS DO HAVE
ACCESS TO GENERAL AND WERE BEING
PUSHED IN OUR LAWSUITS FOR THE
SAME THING. SO IF WE'RE GOING TO
DO THAT AND WE TRULY BELIEVE IN
EQUITY WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
FUND OUR DISTRICTS TO BE ABLE TO
SERVE EVERY SINGLE STUDENT IN
THAT LEAST RESTRICTIVE
ENVIRONMENT AND FOR SOME
STUDENTS. IT'S REALLY EXPENSIVE
THAT MIGHT MEAN A STUDENT WITH
SIGNIFICANT DISABILITIES NEEDS
TO HAVE A NURSE IN THE CLASSROOM
OR PARA EDUCATOR OR A LITANY OF
THINGS BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN.
THAT BECAUSE IT'S TOO EXPENSIVE
THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE ACCESS TO
THAT CLASSROOM.
AND SO I THINK WHAT WE'VE SEEN
IS.
ELEAZAR AND AND I DON'T I AGREE
I DON'T KNOW ANYONE WHO WANTS TO
SEGREGATE KIDS AND DOESN'T WANT
THEM TO GET EVERYTHING THEY NEED
BUT AT SOME POINT. YOU HAVE TO
MAKE FISCAL CHOICES AROUND
ECONOMIES OF SCALE AND THEN WE
SEE THINGS LIKE SPECIAL DAY
CLASSES OF KIDS FROM
KINDERGARTEN THROUGH FIFTH
GRADE.
GOING TO SCHOOL TOGETHER WITH
THE SAME TEACHER FOR MANY YEARS
NOW IF WE EXPECT THEM TO BE ABLE
TO.
TO LEARN ALL THEIRS STATE
STANDARDS AND PERFORM ON STATE
LEVEL ASSESSMENTS THEY HAVE TO
HAVE ACCESS TO ALL OF THAT
INFORMATION AND THE STATE
STANDARDS AND SO FOR ONE
TEACHER.
TO TEACH FIVE GRADE LEVELS EVERY
YEAR. WITH ONE OR TWO AIDES AND
A LOT OF KIDS WITH BEHAVIOR AND
OTHER THINGS IS A PRETTY TALL
ORDER. SO YOU KNOW I JUST FEEL
LIKE AS A STATE WE HAVE TO WE
HAVE TO DECIDE WHAT WE WANT FOR
ALL OF OUR STUDENTS. WERE HERE
TODAY AT THE DEPARTMENT AND IN
THE SPECIAL ED DIVISION AND THE
REASON I'M HERE. IS TO SUPPORT
THIS AND IT'S BEEN NICE HAVING
THE BACKBONE OF THE SPECIAL
ATTACKS FORCE AND ALL OF YOUR
SUPPORT FRANKLY ALL THE FOLKS
SITTING UP HERE HAVE BEEN
TREMENDOUS SUPPORTERS AROUND
MAKING THIS HAPPEN.
AND AGAIN IT GOES BACK TO THE
EQUITY ISSUE THE FEW THINGS I'D
LIKE TO ALSO POINT OUT OR THAT.
OUR SUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
ARE NOT JUST STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES THERE'S THE
INTERSECTION AUDI BETWEEN THEM
THERE ENGLISH LEARNERS. STUDENTS
IN POVERTY THEIR FOSTER YOUTH ON
THEIR HOMELESS YOUTH AND THE
MANY OTHER THINGS BUT IN TERMS
OF THE LC FF THEY CROSS OVER ALL
THOSE GROUPS. SO THEY'RE NOT
INDIVIDUAL GROUPS SEVENTY
PERCENT OF OUR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES ARE IN ONE OR MORE
OF THE LCF CATEGORIES. SO WE'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT DIFFERENT KIDS
SO ARE FRAMING OF HOW YOU
SUPPORT WHOLE CHILDREN. IN A
GENERAL ED ENVIRONMENT IS CLOSE
TO GENERAL AS POSSIBLE IS
SOMETHING THAT WILL COST MORE
MONEY. AND IF WE EXPECT EQUITY
FOR ALL OF OUR STUDENTS WE HAVE
TO HAVE EQUITY ACROSS OUR
ELEAZAR TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THOSE SERVICES AND THAT INCLUDES
CHARTER SCHOOLS. AND THAT'S
ANOTHER CLARIFICATION I WANT TO
MAKE IS THAT.
OF ALL OF OUR CHARTER SCHOOLS I
THINK AROUND SIX HUNDRED OF THEM
ARE ONES THAT ARE THEIR OWN
ELLIE IS FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
SO SOME OF THEM ARE DEPENDENT ON
DISTRICTS FOR THEIR SPECIAL ED
SERVICES. BUT THOSE SIX HUNDRED
FULL RESPONSIBILITY OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION SO WE EXPECT THEM TO
SERVE THE FULL RANGE OF STUDENTS
JUST LIKE WITH OUR SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS THE SAME
CONVERSATION. IS THE MICROMETER
SCALE ISSUE YOU ONLY GET. A
CERTAIN AMOUNT FOR YOUR SMALL
NUMBER OF STUDENTS AND THEN
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO DO A LOT OF
THINGS SO WE'RE PUSHING CHARTER
SCHOOLS TO SERVE TRANSITION AGE
YOUTH THEY'VE NEVER DONE THAT
BEFORE. AND BUT THEY GET NO
FUNDING AND THEY HAVE NO ACCESS
TO WORK ABILITY SO HOW DO WE
EXPECT WE WANT EVERYONE TO SERVE
EVERYONE AND TO SERVE EVERYONE
WELL. AND SO THAT EQUITY ACROSS
FISCAL IS REALLY REALLY CRITICAL
AND SO I SEE SO MUCH PROMISE
RIGHT NOW. OLD EVERY SINGLE
PIECES LINED UP IN OUR SYSTEM.
OUR POLICY MAKERS OLIVER STATE
AGENCIES. COLLABORATION IS AN
UNDERSTATEMENT OF WHAT'S
OCCURRING ACROSS EVERYONE WITH
THIS REAL WELL TO WRAP AROUND.
THE REALLY THE HOW AND THE
ABILITY TO DO THAT WORK WITH THE
RIGHT AMOUNT OF OF MONEY IS
GOING TO BE A CRITICAL PIECE OF
IT ALL. SO I THINK YOU FOR
LISTENING.
ONE.
MANY BIG. EMPLOYER ID PRE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS A GREAT
DEAL THANK YOU GUYS ABSENT A
PANT.
THANK YOU.
ACTUALLY DID JUST WANNA TOUCH.
ON BECAUSE ONE OF THINGS WE TALK
ABOUT COURSES RESOURCES AND.
.
SO WHEN AREA BECAUSE I USED TO
CHAIR THE HEALTH COMMITTEE IN
THE STATE ASSEMBLY IN FACT.
A.
CONVENED A MEETING BETWEEN.
DCS AND.
SEVERAL SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE
PART OF EDUCATION LOOKING AT.
ONLY A AND MOM MONEY AND I KNOW
WE WERE AT THAT TIME. DEALING
WITH.
CHALLENGE WITH CMS BUT.
IT IS AS YOUR REPORT NOTED.
AND THEY'VE RELEASES TO
THOUSANDS AWHILE AGO BUT STILL.
I DON'T THINK PRICE THESE
CHANGES ESTIMATE CALIFORNIA
RANKS IN THE BOTTOM QUARTILE.
AND AVERAGE CLAIMS FOR MEDICAID
FOR ELIGIBLE CHILDREN AMONG
STATES WITH SCHOOL BASED
MEDICAID PROGRAMS AND OTHERS ANY
MORE RECENT DATA.
AND WHETHER YOU WANT CONJECTURE
WITH ACTUALLY MOVES FROM THE
BOTTOM QUARTILE TO ANYWHERE ELSE
BUT THE BOTTOM QUARTILE. AND
THEN ASHES INTERESTING IS
THERE'S A LOT OF.
CONCERNED AT THAT BASICALLY
SAYS ONE REASONS ARE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE AVAILING
THEMSELVES OF THESE FUNDS IS
THAT THAT THE UP PAPERWORK.
THE CLEANING PROCESS IS TOO
DIFFICULT AND. MAYBE COMMENT ON
WHAT WE CAN DO TO.
TO PROVE THAT WILL STILL MEETING
THE CMS ENDS OF WHY OTHER STATES
ARE ABLE TO DO THIS AND WHY ARE
WE NOT ABLE TO I MEAN I THINK
THAT.
THERE'S A TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY.
I'VE JUST JUST JUST.
EVEN AT THE BOTTOM QUARTILE WE
ARE. YOU KNOW GETTING ABOUT A
HUNDRED THIRTY TWO HUNDRED FORTY
SEVEN MILLION.
IF YOU'RE IN THE TOP QUARTILE I
DON'T KNOW THAT BECOME LIKE.
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION THE I THINK. I THINK THE
SCHOOLS COULD USE THAT MONEY SO
THE BABY CAN COMMENT ON THAT
WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING TO
ADDRESS.
ARE BELIEVED TO DRAW DOWN
FEDERAL FUNDS THROUGHOUT THE A
AND MA. THROUGH THE MEDICAID
PROGRAM.
BUT I WISH I HAD AN EASY ANSWER
TO THAT ONE OF THE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT I HAVE IS AS A MEMBER OF
THE NATIONAL COUNCIL FOR
ADMINISTRATORS FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION THROUGH THE COUNCIL
FOR EXCEPTIONAL CHILDREN. AND SO
TWICE A MONTH I'M ON A CALL WITH
PEOPLE FROM AROUND THE COUNTRY.
AND EVERY OTHER STATE. USES
THESE MONIES TO FUND CLINICS AND
THEY GET IT AND IT'S JUST PART
OF THE PROCESS BUT THEY DO HAVE
SOME DIFFERENT RULES. AND SO AT
ONE POINT EARLY ON IN THIS
DISCUSSION I REMEMBER US LOOKING
INTO. I'M A COUPLE OF THE OTHER
STATES DISABLED EXACTLY WHAT
WHAT ARE YOUR RULES SO THAT WE
CAN LOOK AT HOW DO WE DIFFER.
AND SO I THINK THAT THERE MIGHT
BE SOME REGULATORY CHANGES THAT
COULD DO THAT BUT THEN WE ALSO
HAVE A COUPLE OF DIFFERENT.
BUSINESSES THAT SOME OF WHICH
HAVE COME AND GONE AND I'M NOT
IN THE FIELD ANYMORE SO I CAN'T
GIVE YOU THE THE LATEST UPDATE.
BUT I KNOW PEOPLE WOULD BE VERY
WILLING TO WORK WITH YOU ON THAT
BECAUSE WE'RE.
EIGHTEEN PERCENT OF THE NATIONAL
SPECIAL ED POPULATION.
AND IN THE BOTTOM QUARTILE.
THAT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE FOR WHAT
WE COULD BE ACCESSING
POTENTIALLY.
WELL I JUST POINT OUT IN
ADDITION TO SERVING ON THE.
EDUCATION COMMITTEE ASKED THE
CHAIR OF THE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
ON HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
THAT OVERSEES THE MEDICAID. OUR
MEDICAL PROGRAM SO AND SO I'M
VERY VERY INTERESTED IN THIS AND
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM.
BE HAPPY TO HELP WORK WITH YOU
ON THAT THANK YOU.
THE QUESTIONS AND.
YEAH YEAH I HAD TO STEP OUTSIDE
APOLOGIZE IF IF YOU IF YOU
MENTION IS WE TALKED OUR LAST
TWO PANELS AS FAR AS THE THE
EQUALIZATION OR. WHATNOT WHICH
IS SOMETHING DIFFERENT YOU KNOW
GOING BACK TO THE TWENTY YEAR
MODEL JUST FINDING IT PER
STUDENT SERVED.
WHAT ARE YOUR IDEAS OF WHAT
CALIFORNIA SHOULD DO FOR REALLY
WANTED? ADDRESS THAT THE FISCAL
ISSUES NOT THE NOT THE POLICY
SIDE.
SO ONE NIGHT. I DID ADDRESS THAT
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE YOU HAD
ASKED THE QUESTION ABOUT WHAT IF
WE JUST WHEN INTEL CFO. AND SO.
THE COMPARISON IS THAT EVERY
DISTRICT THROUGH LCF UP IS NOW
GETTING AN EIGHTY EIGHT RIGHT.
ANDSO WHAT IS EQUALLY TRUE IS
THAT EVERY DISTRICT EVERY CELL
BUT GETS A RATE ALSO FOR SPECIAL
LED THE DIFFERENCE FOR US IS
THAT THOSE RATES DIFFER SO
SIGNIFICANTLY. SO IF YOU WERE TO
SAY THAT LET'S KEEP THIS IN A
SIMILAR MODEL AS LCF HALF. THE
POINT WOULD BE TO EQUALIZE THOSE
DOLLARS SO THAT THE ADA RATE FOR
SPECIAL ED PURPOSES. COULDN'T BE
PART OF THAT CONVERSATION BUT IT
WOULD BE EQUALIZED BUT THE
DIFFERENCE IS FRANKLY THAT
BECAUSE. ID A IS AN ENTITLEMENT
AND SPECIAL ED IS AN ENTITLEMENT
TO PEOPLE.
I BELIEVE AND I'M NOT A PARENT
BUT I BELIEVE THAT THAT
PROTECTION OF HAVING IT BE THE
ONE REMAINING CATEGORICAL IS
IMPORTANT SO THAT WE CAN MONITOR
WE CAN REPORT. IS A LOT OF
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS THAT WE
HAVE TO HAVE THE PROTECTION BUT
SHOULD WE ALSO DO THE
EQUALIZATION OR FUNDED BY THE
STATE THE AMOUNT OF STUDENTS
ACTUALLY SIR SO THEN. SENT
DISTRICTS ARE ARE GETTING A
TRUE.
IT OUT YET COMPENSATION OR
ALLOCATION BASED UPON THE WORK
THAT'S BEING DONE I THINK
THERE'S A COUPLE OF DIFFERENT.
RESPONSES TO THAT DURING THE
EIGHTY SIX SO TO CONVERSATIONS
ONE OF THE REASONS THAT THE
DECISION TO GO TO AN EIGHTY A
RATE ULTIMATELY. WAS BECAUSE IF
YOU LOOK ACROSS THE STATE.
IT LETS THEM IN FREMONT I'M
GONNA HAVE A HIGHER POPULATION
OF KIDS WHO ARE DEAF BECAUSE THE
SCHOOL FOR THE DEAF IS RIGHT
THERE. BUT IF I'M IN MODOC
COUNTY I HAVE A HIGHER
POPULATION OF KIDS WHO REQUIRE
SIGNIFICANT TRANSPORTATION OR
HEALTH OR OTHER DIFFERENT KINDS
OF NEEDS IN. THE RANGE OF NEEDS
IN AT THE SYSTEM AS WIDE AS OURS
WITH SOME WOULD YOU SAY SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS IN. EIGHT STATES ACROSS
THE GEOGRAPHY OF CALIFORNIA. IT
IT FELT LIKE IT WAS THE FAIR
THING TO DO TO AVERAGE OUT THAT
ACROSS ALL THOSE SYSTEMS BECAUSE
OF THE DIFFERING NEEDS. AN
EIGHTY A RATE THAT WOULD GO
ACROSS THOSE NUMBERS SEEM TO BE
THE MOST FAIR THAT THE MISSING
PIECE REALLY WAS INCLUDING PRE
SCHOOL AT THE TIME.
THANK YOU.
YEAH SOON MEMBER MEMBERS CITY SO
I I JUST WANNA FOLLOW UP ON THAT
TO THEM SO ARE YOU SAYING. THAT.
LIKES A.
I MEAN I. MEAN IT IS IT SEEMS TO
MAKE SENSE TO ME THAT THAT THE
DOLLAR'S FALL THE STUDENTS WITH
THE GREATEST NEEDS. JUST LIKE
THE BASIC PRINCIPLE OF LCL PATH
BUT BUT YOU'RE SAYING.
THAT BECAUSE IT'S HARD TO
ACHIEVE LIKE SAY THE ECONOMIES
OF SCALE OF OF PROVIDING
TRANSPORTATION AND REAL
DISTRICTS THAT THAT THAT IS.
THAT THAT IS ONE REASON WHY YOU
WOULDN'T WANT TO HAVE THE
DOLLAR'S FALL IN THE STUDENT IT
WASN'T JUST THAT ABOUT
TRANSPORTATION IT WAS THAT WHEN
YOU TALK TO THE ENTIRE RANGE OF
THOSE SELF REPRESENTATION WHO'S
WHO REPRESENT THEN ALL OF THESE.
KIDS AND WE WORKED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AT THE
TIME TO TO LOOK AT THAT RANGE OF
NEEDS. EVERY PART OF THE STATE
HAS A DIFFERING SET OF DEMANDS
AND SO WHEN YOU TRY TO GET ONE
ANSWER IT'S NOT GOING TO BE AN
ANSWER FOR THIS DISTRICT BUT IT
IS AN ANSWER FOR HERE. BUT IT IS
TRUE THAT MORE STUDENTS WITH
MORE SIGNIFICANT NEEDS HAVE
BECOME PART OF THE SYSTEM. AND
SO I KNOW THAT ONE OF THE IDEAS
THAT HAS BEEN RECENTLY TALKED
ABOUT IS WHAT IF YOU ADD SOME
KIND OF ADDITIVE FACTOR FOR
THOSE STUDENTS WHO ARE THE MOST
EXPENSIVE. BUT THEN I WOULD GO
BACK TO THE MOST EXPENSIVE TO
SERVE. I WOULD GO BACK TO THE
CONVERSATION THAT YOU WOULDN'T
WANT TO HAVE ANY KIND OF
SOLUTION THAT WOULD INCENTIVIZE.
A.
THE.
THAT.
THE DETERMINATION OF ELIGIBILITY
SO WAY BACK WHEN I WAS A SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGIST AND REALLY THE
NUMBER THAT WAS MANIPULATED THE
MOST WAS A SPECIFIC LEARNING
DISABILITY OR HEATHER AND I WERE
JUST TALKING ABOUT WHAT WAS YOUR
UNIT RATE. THAT WOULD BE ONE WAY
THAT YOU COULD MANIPULATE IT YOU
JUST DON'T WANT TO BE REALLY
CAREFUL ABOUT ACTUALLY HAVING TO
FOLLOW SOMETHING THAT IS. AN
IDENTIFIABLE BUT NOT MANIPULATE
A BULL. NUMBER I ANSWER THAT TOO
JUST IN THE SENSE THAT.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THE CDC
IS JUST DONE WITH THE NEW
CREDENTIAL IS CHANGED FROM.
BEING MORE LABELED.
ABOUT THAT THE STUDENT THE
DISABILITY AND CHANGE THAT SORT
OF THE LEVEL OF NEED AND SO ONE
WAY OF RETHINKING THIS
CONVERSATION ACROSS EVERY
DISABILITY
CATEGORY FOR THE MOST PART
THERE'S A FULL RANGE OF SUPPORT
NEEDS. SUMMER VERY MINIMAL AND
SOME ARE VERY EXTENSIVE AND SO.
ONE THOUGHT IS THAT AS WE'RE
LOOKING AT SORT THIS WHOLE SIX
OH TWO EQUALIZATION THAT'S THAT
SOLVES. PART OF THE PROBLEM THE
OTHER PROBLEM REALLY S THE
HIGHER NEED STUDENTS AND THAT
BECOMES A PROBLEM FOR THE FOLKS
THAT HAVE. LESS ECONOMIES OF
SCALE RIGHT BECAUSE ONE STUDENT
WHO HAS TO GO TO A NON PUBLIC
SCHOOL THINKS THE SHIP
ESSENTIALLY. SO HOW DO WE
ACCOUNT FOR THAT HIGH NEEDS HIGH
LEVEL OF SUPPORT POPULATION
ACROSS ALL THE DISABILITY
CATEGORIES IT'S REALLY ABOUT. IF
YOU HAVE A STUDENT WITH REALLY
EXPENSIVE NEEDS HOW ARE YOU
GOING TO MEET THOSE AND SO
PERHAPS THERE'S A TWEENER THERE
SOMEWHERE.
RIGHT AND IT DOESN'T
INCENTIVIZE.
ANY KIND OF ENVIRONMENT OR
ANYTHING ELSE.
I FLESH OUT THESE LAST TWO
COMMENTS DO YOU HAVE. I THINK
WE'RE ALL IDENTIFYING THE NEEDLE
IS BETRAYED DO HAVE PARTICULAR
IDEAS ABOUT HOW TO THREAD THE
NEEDLE.
IN TERMS OF CRAFTING A SYSTEM
THAT WILL. STRIKE THAT BALANCE
THAT YOU TALKED ABOUT IN TERMS
OF MAKING SURE THERE'S SOME
ADDED A FACTOR TO REFLECT THE
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH HIGHER.
NEEDS AS AN EDUCATIONAL
PROVISION WITH WITHOUT
INCENTIVIZING.
YEAH BAD BEHAVIOR FROM A
FINANCIAL PERSPECTIVE.
I THINK THE MOST PART THE
STUDENTS THAT HAVE SIGNIFICANT
SUPPORT NEEDS ARE NOT ONES THAT
THAT CAN BE HIDDEN. AND THEY'RE
NOT ONES THAT PETETHAT FOLKS
ARE GOING TO JUST TRY TO GET
MORE MONEY BECAUSE I THINK MOST
FOLKS MOST PEOPLE WOULD AGREE.
THAT THAT LEVEL OF STUDENT IS
NOT SOMETHING THAT IS GOING TO
BE INCENTIVIZED AND MANY OF
THOSE STUDENTS ARE IDENTIFIED
OUT OF OUR EARLY INTERVENTION.
SO THEY'RE NOT THEY DON'T JUST
POP IN IN LESS THERE'S SOMETHING
THAT HAPPENS TO THEM LATER IN
LIFE SO.
SO I HEAR WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
LIKE WHAT IS THE SOLUTION. I
THINK I THINK IF WE CAN AGREE
THAT THAT THAT'S WHERE WE ARE
THAT WE HAVE LIKE A A. BASED
AGREEMENT ON EQUALIZATION IN
THOSE THINGS COULD BECAUSE
THAT'S KIND OF WHERE WE ARE IN
THE CONVERSATION WE HAVEN'T HAD
THOSE OTHER CONVERSATIONS YET
BUT WE ARE. WE AT WE WERE FULLY
OPEN TO THAT AND WOULD LOVE TO
HAVE ADDITIONAL. BRAINSTORMING
SESSIONS.
AND APPRECIATE THAT WE'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOUR STAFF AS
WELL JUST ABOUT YOU KNOW WHAT
WHAT COULD LOOK LIKE LET'S DO
THAT I MEAN A AND I ATE IN IN IT
AND I GUESS.
YOU KNOW ULTIMATELY MAYBE YOU'RE
RIGHT RIGHT IF IF.
THE REAL COST DRIVER. IS FOR IS
IN THE AREA THE MORE.
HIGH SEVERITY.
I STUDENTS. AND IF THEY'RE YOU
KNOW THEY'RE THERE IS PRESUMABLY
LESS.
OPPORTUNITY FOR A BAD ACTOR TO
MANIPULATE.
THAT SORT OF DIAGNOSIS.
FIVE AND SO MAYBE MAYBE THAT'S
WHERE. MAYBE THAT'S GONNA KIND
OF.
ADDRESS THIS KEY PROBLEM. I
THINK FOR EXAMPLE A MEDICAL
DIAGNOSIS SO. THAT'S WHAT WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THE LOW INCIDENCE
COMMUNITY BEING SUCH AN AD AND
EASILY IDENTIFIABLE POTENTIAL
GROUP BECAUSE EITHER YOUR YOUR
DEATH FOR YOU OR NOT EITHER
YOURS TO GREATLY HARD OF HEARING
OR YOU'RE. BLIND THOSE ARE
EASILY IDENTIFIABLE AND NOT
PARTICULARLY DEBATABLE.
SO THE LOW INCIDENCE
DISABILITIES ARE CLEARLY ONE
THAT COULD BE. COULD BE LOOKED
AT BUT THEN IF YOU LOOK AT
AUTISM WHICH USED TO BE
CONSIDERED A LOW INCIDENCE
DISABILITY AND IS NOW AT. EIGHT
PERCENT OF THE SPECIAL ED
POPULATION IN THE STATE.
KNOWING THAT THAT'S A SPECTRUM
DISORDER AND NOT EVERY CHILD
WITH AUTISM. IS A OF THE LEVEL
OF NEED THAT KRISTEN WAS JUST
ADDRESSING AND SO IT WOULD BE A
MATTER REALLY BEING VERY CAREFUL
ABOUT WHO COULD BE INCLUDED. OUT
RATIONALLY AND AND IN A FAIR WAY
THAT GOES BACK TO NOT HAVE NOT
THE LABEL DRIVING IT BUT RATHER
THE SUPPORT ANY DRIVING AND
RIGHT EXACTLY.
AND HOW TO CRAFT A SYSTEM OF
ACTION AND WORK ON THE STATE
LEVEL IF IT WITH THE SIZE AND
COMPLEXITY OF OUR SYSTEM.
YEAH BUT A VERY IMPORTANT TASK
FORCE TO TAKE ON I THINK BECAUSE
SOME.
RIGHT NOW I'M.
BUT IN CVS ADEQUATE EQUITY.
TERMS OF THE WAY THEY WERE FOR
DISTRIBUTING THE RESOURCES SOME.
OKAY BOB WELL YOU KNOW.
ONCE AGAIN I KIND OF TASK YOU
WITH WITH WITH GOING BACK AND
TALKING YOUR FOLKS WITH WITH
TRYING TO HELP US.
THREAD THE NEEDLE AS BEST WE
CAN.
I'M.
AND AND BE IN TOUCH WITH US IS
WE'RE TRYING TO CROSS SOME
SOLUTIONS COMING OUT OF THIS IN
THE WORD WITH YEAH WELL I'VE
I'VE SAID THE WORDS A. YEAH I
GUESS.
LET'S LET'S WORK ON IT RIGHT NOW
SO MUCH. HAS BEEN SUCH AN
INCREDIBLE MORNING AND I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN GREAT
ALRIGHT THANK YOU GUYS THANK YOU
OKAY. I'M SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
NOT TO TO RUN OPEN UP PUBLIC
COMMENT I'D LIKE TO GIVE THE
OPTION FOR JOHN THING WENGER TO
COME UP AND MAKE A COUPLE
COMMENTS I KNOW THAT HE. HAD
SOME ISSUES RELATED TRICYCLES
WERE RAISED BEFORE AND AND AND
SEES IT AND HAVE THE OPTION TO.
TO SPEAK OUT ON ONE OF THE PANEL
SO AND.
IF YOU LIKE TO MAKE JUST A
COUPLE COMMENTS ON THE THINGS
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED AND THEN.
.
IF WE CAN.
THE FOLKS WHO WANT TO MAKE THIS
A PUBLIC COMMENTS THAT THEY CAN
LINE UP BEHIND THE MICROPHONE
THERE AND WE'LL GET WE'LL GET ON
A PUBLIC COMMENT.
MISTER MAKER.
YEAH THANKS FOR THE TIME.
JOHN WINGER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU FOR THE
HEARING.
THIS BEEN REALLY ENLIGHTENING
AND CCS A DEFINITELY APPLIES THE
COMMITTEE'S FOCUS ON TAKING THE
APPROPRIATE STEPS TO CREATE. ONE
SYSTEM THAT IS PREPARED TO SERVE
FOR EACH AND EVERY STUDENT.
THAT MEANS ENSURING THAT
ELEAZAR OF THE FUNDS NEEDED TO
SERVE.
I THINK IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO
REALLY TALK ABOUT SPECIAL
EDUCATION IN CHARTER SCHOOLS
WITHOUT IDENTIFYING THE TWO
DECISIONS THAT DEFINE WHO
RECEIVED THE MONEY. AND WHO
HOLDS THE RESPONSIBILITY.
WITHOUT THAT CONTEXT AND
DISTINCTION YOU CAN'T REALLY
ACCURATELY DRAW ANY CONCLUSIONS.
SO FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT
HAVE DIRECT ACCESS AND CONTROL
OVER SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDS.
WHICH IS ABOUT FIFTY PERCENT OF
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN THE STATE.
THE PERCENTAGE OF KIDS WITH
DISABILITIES SERVED.
IS VERY CLOSE TO STATE WIDE
AVERAGES IN TRADITIONAL SCHOOLS.
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE DEPENDENT ON
THEIR AUTHORIZING DISTRICTS FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION THERE'S NO
CONTROL OVER SPECIAL EDUCATION
DECISIONS OR ENROLLMENT TRENDS.
IN MANY CASES CHARTER SCHOOLS
ARE PROHIBITED FROM SERVING
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES. WE
BELIEVE THIS IS A.
CRITICAL DISTINCTION THAT NEEDS
TO BE RECOGNIZED.
WHEN EVALUATING THIS ISSUE.
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS DUE TO
AN INCREASE IN OF AVAILABLE
OPTIONS FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION A
TANAMI THROUGH CHARTER SELF
THOSE AND OTHER INNOVATIVE.
ARRANGEMENTS.
CHARTER SCHOOLS HAVE SEEN A
SIGNIFICANT GROWTH IN THE NUMBER
OF STUDENTS ACROSS THE FULL
CONTINUING. CONTINUUM OF NEED.
ALL ELEAZAR MUST HAVE THE FUNDS
AVAILABLE TO ENSURE THAT EACH
AND EVERY CHILD IS ON A PATH TO
SUCCESSFULLY TRANSITION. INTO A
COLLEGE OR CAREER.
THE SYSTEM NEEDS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO ENSURE EQUITY HOWEVER
THE SYSTEM ALSO NEEDS INCREASED
LEVELS OF ACCOUNTABILITY TO
ENSURE WE REACH OUR DESIRED
OUTCOMES.
AND AS WE MOVE FORWARD CCA CCS
A LOOKS FORWARD TO CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS WITH. THE
LEGISLATURE ON HOW WE FIND THE
APPROPRIATE FUNDING TO
ENSURE EQUITY IN THE SYSTEM FOR
ALL STUDENTS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YES SIR.
YES STEVE WARD A LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST FOR CLOSE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND THE SCHOOL FUNDING
COALITION. UP PLEASE NOTE OUR
EMPLOYEES AND OUR PARENTS ARE
TRULY EXCITED THAT OUR
LEGISLATIVE LEADERS. ARE TAKING
ON A HUGE CHALLENGE STATE
ADEQUATELY AND EQUITABLY. FUND
THE REAL COST OF PROVIDING
SERVICES FOR OUR CHILDREN
ADULTS.
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS ON THEIR
BEHALF WE JUST REALLY TRULY
TRULY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WITHOUT.
MY NAME IS JIM ANDERSON I'M THE
SUBDIRECTORY LOS ANGELES COUNTY
COURT SCHOOL SPECIAL EDUCATION
LOCAL PLAN AREA. OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY CHARTER SPECIAL EDUCATION
LOCAL PLAN AREA.
WITHIN THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
AND THE CURRENT CHAIR OF THE
SELF ADMINISTRATORS ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA. REPRESENTING ALL
STUDENTS TO DISABILITIES IN OUR
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA GOT A LOT
ON YOUR PLATE.
YES.
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
PROVIDE INPUT TODAY.
ADDITIONALLY THE ASSOCIATIONAL
BE HAPPILY WILL HAPPILY SEND YOU
A RECENT WHITE PAPER ON THE
IMPORTANT ROLE THE WORK OF SELF
IS ACROSS THE STATE.
IT IS CLEAR THERE IS A
COLLABORATIVE A LINE ACROSS THE
STATE AMONG AGENCIES AND IS
HIGHLIGHTED BY DATA PROVIDED IN
REPORTS TO SPECIAL EDUCATION.
FINANCE INCLUDING THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE THE
STATEWIDE SPECIAL EDUCATION TASK
FORCE IN THE PUBLIC POLICY
THROUGH TO CALIFORNIA.
THE ALIGNMENT RECOMMENDS THE
CRITICAL NEED TO SUPPORTER LEE
INTERVENTION. INCREASE THE
AVAILABILITY OF WELL TRAINED A
PREPARED SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHERS.
AND ADDRESS THE LONGSTANDING
INADEQUACY OF SPECIAL EDUCATION
FUNDING.
PLEASE JOIN THE SIGNIFICANT
COLLABORATIVE ALIGNMENT AN ACT
TO PROPERLY FUND THE EDUCATION
OF STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES.
DEMONSTRATING THE COLLECTIVE
CONCERNING CARE OTHER
EDUCATIONAL NEEDS TOWARD
IMPROVED. ACADEMIC AND POST
SECONDARY OUTCOMES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND HAVE.
WOULD LOVE TO SEE THE REPORT AND
I'M I'M WE SHOULD ALSO PROBABLY
WITHIN A MORE LIKE TO.
YES I I ME LAME LYNN I LIVE HERE
IN THE LOCAL SACRAMENTO AREA AND
I REPRESENT FAMILY VOICES OF
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS AN
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTS
THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES OF
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES. THEY
I WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE YOU A
PARENT PERSPECTIVE I'M I HAVE
TWO CHILDREN WITH SPECIAL NEEDS
AND MY FIFTEEN YEAR OLDS IS HAS
DOWN SYNDROME AND INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITY AND SPEECH AND
LANGUAGE IMPAIRMENTS.
HE ALSO PLAYS THE PIANO HE RIDES
HIS BIKE AND HE KNOWS MORE ABOUT
THE US PRESIDENT'STHAN MOST OF
US I'M SURE DO.
MY HUSBAND ALSO A TEACHER SO I
SEE THAT GLIMPSE OF THINGS AS
WELL.
TOBY HAD REALLY GREAT INTENSIVE
EARLY INTERVENTION SERVICES BUT
WE HAD TO PUT HIM IN PRIVATE
PRESCHOOL SO THAT HE COULD BE
FULLY INCLUDED.
I'M.
HE THEN WENT TO PUBLIC SCHOOL
AND AND LATER LIKE MANY I PULL
TOBY OUT OF OUR DISTRICT TO
ATTEND A CHARTER SCHOOL IN
ANOTHER DISTRICT SO THAT HE
COULD HAVE. A MORE
INDIVIDUALIZED OPPORTUNITY TO
ACHIEVE.
I KNOW FINDING IS A HUGE ISSUE
OBVIOUSLY BUT I WONDER IF
WESHOULD BE TALKING ABOUT. SOME
SORT OF INTEGRATED EDUCATION
FINANCING TRAINING AND SERVICE
DELIVERY. AND STOP SEGREGATING
STUDENTS IN SPECIAL EDUCATION
WHILE KEEPING THOSE PROTECTIONS
THAT WE SO DESPERATELY NEED.
I HAVE FOUND A PRESUMPTION OF
INCOMPETENCE.
I'M IN A LACK OF INDIVIDUALLY
INDIVIDUALITY AND MY SONS IEP.
LIKE ANY PARENT I WANT MY CHILD
TO GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL BUT
JUST TO GIVE YOU AN IDEA I'M
CONSTANTLY QUESTIONED AND
CHALLENGED. ABOUT THIS WHEN I
TOURED MY LOCAL HIGH SCHOOL I
DID NOT SEE ONE CHILD WHO LOOK
LIKE MINE AND THAT WAS VERY
TELLING THAT TOLD ME A LOT ABOUT
THE EXPECTATION. OF STUDENTS
LIKE MINE. THERE'S NO
EXPECTATION OR MECHANISM TO
INCLUDE THESE STUDENTS OFTEN
BECAUSE THE FUNDING.
IT'S EXHAUSTING TO CONSTANTLY
FIGHT. OR WHAT SENATOR WILL
CALLED CIVIL RIGHTS.
I REGULARLY HERE CAN'T WON'T AND
DON'T SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY
HAVEN'T DONE IT BEFORE.
TOBY DREAMS OF GOING TO COLLEGE
LIKE HIS BROTHER AS HE AS HE
SHOULD. AND I FIND IT THE VERY
SYSTEM THAT SHOULD BE PREPARING
HIM IS IS FURTHER DISABLING HIM.
MAYBE IF WE CHANGE OUR MINDSET
AND OUR EXPECTATIONS WE COULD
REDUCE THE LONG TERM NEED FOR
INTENSIVE SERVICES FOR MANY. AND
IDENTIFY EFFICIENCIES THAT COULD
BE REALIZED. THROUGH TRUE
INTEGRATION.
WE SHOULD BE INCENTIVIZING
GROWTH AND ACHIEVEMENT WHEN WE
LOOK AT THOSE GOALS IN THOSE
IP'S THAT MIGHT BE A WAY BEGIN
LOOKING AT THINGS.
THE FINDING AS IT STANDS I THINK
REFLECTS THE WAY THAT WE AS A
SOCIETY STILL THINK OF THESE
CHILDREN. WHO ARE SO OFTEN IN A
SEPARATE CLASSROOM AT THE BACK
OF THE CAMPUS THANK YOU?
YOU THINK YOU'RE MUCH.
YES MA'AM.
IT AFTERNOON I'M CINDY CHANDLER.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE MY EXPERIENCE AS A PARENT
AND A REPRESENTATIVE OF FAMILY
EMPOWERMENT CENTERS.
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
FAMILY SUPER FAMILY EMPOWERMENT
CENTER AND FAMILY RESOURCE
CENTER. RESEARCH SUTTER YUBA AND
COLUSA COUNTIES.
AND FAMILY SOUP WAS ONE OF THE
LAST CENTERS FUNDED AND THAT WAS
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND SIX.
CLOSE TO THIRTY YEARS AGO WHEN
OUR DAUGHTER EMILY LOST THROUGH
LANGUAGE DIDN'T MAKE EYE CONTACT
ONLY EIGHT THREE THINGS HAD
MELTDOWNS AND SENSORY ISSUES.
WE WERE AT A TOTAL LOSS
AND AT THAT TIME MY HUSBAND
CHRIS CHANDLER WAS AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR DISTRICT THREE.
THERE WAS NO RESOURCE FOR
PARENTS. PREPARED TO PARENT
SUPPORT.
NO ONE TO HELP US NAVIGATE THE
SERVICE SYSTEM OR EXPLAIN WHAT
TO DO NEXT.
IT WAS ISOLATING AND TERRIFYING
AND WE WERE LOSING TIME. THAT
WINDOW OF OPPORTUNITY THE WINDOW
FOR LANGUAGE WAS CLOSING.
SO WE KNEW THERE HAD TO BE A
BETTER WAY.
AS PARENTS WE KNEW WE NEEDED TO
HELP WE NEEDED HELP TO GAIN
ACCESS TO THE SPECIAL ED SYSTEM.
WE NEEDED TO KNOW HOW THE
INDIVIDUALIZED EDUCATION PLAN
PROCESS WORKED. AND WE KNEW WE
WANTED TO BE ACTIVE PARTICIPANTS
BUT HOW.
PARENTS ENTER A UNIVERSE OF UP
WITH THE LANGUAGE THEY DIDN'T
CHOOSE.
PRIOR WRITTEN NOTICE FUNCTIONAL
ANALYSIS RTI MTS AS YOU DL
INCLUSION LEAST RESTRICTIVE
ENVIRONMENT LIST GOES ON.
THEY FEEL THEY ARE LOSING
PRECIOUS TIME EACH TIME A DOOR
CLOSES. A FOR SERVICES AND MATCH
THE FULL ARRAY OF RESOURCES IS
NOT SHARED.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT QUESTIONS
TO ASK BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW
WHAT THEY DON'T KNOW.
THEY SUSPECT THEIR CHILD HAS A
DISABILITY THEY KNOW SOMETHING
IS NOT RIGHT AND IT FEELS LIKE
NO ONE WANTS TO ASSESS THEIR
CHILD.
AND PROVIDE THE HELP THEIR CHILD
NEEDS.
WHAT WE WANT THEM TO KNOW THAT
THERE IS A BETTER WAY WE WANT
ALL THE PARENTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO HAVE THAT EQUAL
ACCESS TO THE SUPPORT?
FAMILY EMPOWERMENT CENTERS
PROVIDE THE INFORMATION AND
PARENT TO PARENT SUPPORT TO THE
PARENTS CAN BE THE BEST
ADVOCATES. FOR THEIR CHILD WITH
A DISABILITY.
WE SUPPORT ALL DISABILITY. FEC
SERVICE STUDENTS AGED THREE TO
TWENTY TWO.
WE COLLABORATE WITH SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IEP TEAMS TEACHERS AND
SELF AS.
THOSE ARE OUR PARTNERS.
SCHOOLS MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL
SOCIAL WORKERS THEY ALL REFER
THEIR FAMILIES THE FCC'S OUR
SERVICES ARE RESPECTED AND
VALUED BY OUR PARTNERS.
WE WORK HARD TO HELP RESOLVE
CONFLICT BEFORE IT ESCALATES AND
WE WE DON'T WANT PARENTS TO HAVE
TO GO THROUGH THOSE THOSE
FRUSTRATING MEETINGS AND
FRUSTRATING. YEARS OF LACK OF
SERVICES.
IF A PARENT HAS A CONCERN ABOUT
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THEIR CHILD.
FAMILY EMPOWERMENT CENTERS ARE
THE PERFECT PLACE TO START THE
JOURNEY TOGETHER.
ONE OF OUR PARENTS SAID IT BEST
THE FAMILY EMPOWERMENT CENTER
GAVE US HOPE SHE SAID.
WE HAD LOST OUR HOPE BEFORE WE
MET FAMILY SOUP.
AND I HAVE HOPE AND CONVICTION
THAT THE PROMISE OF SP FIVE
ELEVEN DEFINE THE THIRTY TWO
REGIONAL FEC STATEWIDE IS
FULFILLED. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
YES SIR.
I MY NAME SCRAP PRICE AND THE
CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER FOR THE
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT I'VE BEEN WITH THE
DISTRICT ABOUT EIGHT MONTHS
BEFORE THAT I WAS WITH THE LA
COUNTY FOR FOUR YEARS AS THE
CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER.
WE'RE ALL HERE WE UNDERSTAND
THAT.
AS SPECIAL ED IS UNDER FUNDED
AND WE'RE GLAD THAT YOU
RECOGNIZE THAT ALSO AND WE'RE
GRATEFUL TO BE HERE TODAY.
OTHERS TO WORDS THAT HAVE BEEN
BATTED AROUND EQUAL AND.
EQUITY YET WHAT'S EQUITABLE AND
WHAT'S EQUAL. AND.
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO US
THAT LOS ANGELES UNIFIED. WE
FEEL THAT AN EQUITABLE SYSTEM IS
ONE WHERE THE FUNDS FOLLOWED THE
KIDS THAT ACTUALLY HAVE THE
NEEDS.
AND THAT THE AMOUNT OF FUNDS
THAT FOLLOW THOSE KIDS.
IT DEPENDS ON THE SEVERITY. OF
THEIR NEEDS.
VLC FF IS A GREAT MODEL IT'S AN
EQUITY BASED SYSTEM YOU HAVE A
BASE AND THEN YOU HAVE A
SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT. AND THEN
WHEN THERE'S A CERTAIN
CONCENTRATION OF THOSE
PARTICULAR STUDENTS YOU GET AN
ADDITIONAL FUNDING STREAM. I
WE'RE NOT SUGGESTING THAT.
WE NEED TO BE PART SPECIAL ED
NEEDS TO BE PART OF THAT L. CFL
FORMULA IT WOULD SPECIALLY IT
WOULD BE A BAD THING FOR US TO
BE PART OF THE END DUPLICATED.
COUNT.
BUT THAT SAME TYPE OF EQUITY
SYSTEM NEEDS TO APPLY TO SPECIAL
ED. WHERE IT THE MONEY FOLLOWS
THE STUDENTS AND THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY FOLLOWS THE KNEES? SO
WHAT'S YOUR ARGUMENT TO THE
POINT THAT WENT BEHIND A V. SIX
R. TWO THAT SAID THAT YOU KNOW.
THE OLD SYSTEM WHERE THE MONEY
REALLY FALL THE STUDENTS CREATED
ALL SORTS OF PERVERSE
INCENTIVES.
SO AT THE DETAIL THAT WAS IN
THAT SYSTEM I THINK THAT JUST
LIKE AL CFF THERE ARE CERTAIN
CATEGORIES YOU HAVE MODERATE TO
SEVERE THAT COULD. HAVE A
CERTAIN GRANT MONEY WE HAD OF
VARIOUS FORMULAS THAT WE PUT
TOGETHER.
THAT WE'VE SHARED WITH
DIFFERENT COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND
SPECIAL EDUCATION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THAT WOULD LOVE TO SHARE
WITH YOU. IN IN DETAIL AT
ANOTHER TIME BUT IN REGARDS TO
INCENTIVIZE SCENE.
.
EDUCATORS WHO.
OR SEVERELY RESTRICT OR OR.
CATEGORIZE STUDENTS IN THAT
MORE SEVERE CATEGORY IN ORDER TO
GET FUNDING. I THINK THAT THE.
GROUP THAT WAS AROUND THE TABLE
EARLIER.
REALLY ADDRESS THAT I HAVEN'T
SEEN THAT WITHIN DISTRICTS WE
WANT TO GET THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENT. AND AND
MOVE FORWARD WITH THAT.
AND WE FEEL THAT THE EQUITY
ISSUE IS IS SUCH THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT ENOUGH TO. TO DIRECT
THOSE FUNDS TO THOSE STUDENTS
THAT SAID ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
WE SUPPORTED.
LAST YEAR.
.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARS SU CHI'S
FOURTEEN FORTY NINE.
HE WAS TRYING TO DO THAT SAME
TYPE OF A MODEL.
WHERE THERE WAS?
AN ADDITIONAL AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT WOULD FOLLOW SPECIFIC
STUDENTS WITH THEM.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND.
YES MA'AM OR WASCO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SUBURBAN SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
THE CENTRAL VALLEY EDUCATION
ORGANIZATION.
WE ARE A DIVERSE GROUP OF.
DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WERE IN SUPPORT OF OF NUMBER OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE AND
SPECIAL ED TASK FORCE THE
EQUALIZATION FUNDING. AS WELL AS
PRE SCHOOL. I'M GETTING
PRESCHOOL FUNDING AND IN
ADDITION WE'D LIKE TO BE BACK ON
TOP OF.
SENATOR PANTS COMMENTS FORGET
GUARDING MEDICO AND ADDITIONAL
ACCESS TO MALL LDAP ATI PSP T.
FUNDING. WHICH IS CRITICAL TO
HELP SERVE THE MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS OF STUDENTS COMING INTO
OUR SCHOOLS SO WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU AND THE
COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS THOSE
NEEDS.
THANK YOU.
MR.
THAT AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DAVID
TOSSING I SERVED AS THE
ASSOCIATE SUPERINTENDENT FOR THE
ELDORADO COUNTY SELF AS WELL AS
THE ELDORADO. CHARTER SAGA ALSO
SERVE AS THE CHAIR TO THE
COALITION. I'M FOR ADEQUATE
FUNDING AND SPECIALIZED WHICH
REPRESENTS OVER NINETY FIVE
PERCENT OF THE SELF IS IN THE
MAJORITY OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
I'M THROUGHOUT THE STATE I WOULD
SECOND THE COMMENTS THAT MY
COLLEAGUE. JIM ANDERSON A SHARED
IN TERMS OF OUR SUPPORT OF THE
CONVERSATION. I BELIEVE THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSCORE IT
EVEN IN THE CURRENT FUNDING
MODEL NUMBER FUNDING BASED ON
EIGHTY EIGHT. THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS IN SPECIAL ED HAS GROWN
BACK THE QUAIDS TWO ADDITIONAL
SERVICES FOR STUDENTS SO I
BELIEVE THAT REPRESENTS THAT
EDUCATORS AND FAMILIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. ARE
COMMITTED TO MEETING THE NEEDS
OF STUDENTS EVEN WHEN THERE
ISN'T AN INCENTIVE. AND QUITE
FRANKLY AN ADEQUATE FUNDING AND
SO WE SUPPORT THE CONVERSATION
THAT ALLOWS US TO CONTINUE TO
MOVE FORWARD. AND IN ANSWER TO
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS HOW DO WE
THREAD THAT NEEDLE. I WOULD
HIGHLIGHT THE INCREASE FUNDING
FOR PRESCHOOL I'M EQUALIZING
FUNDING FOR SELF AS I'M AS WELL
AS HAVING THE THE LOW INCIDENCE
RATE AND I WOULD ADD. THE
CONVERSATIONS ARE TAKING PLACE
AROUND INCREASE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
I WOULD NOT GET RID MY CAR IF I
DIDN'T PUT ENOUGH FUEL OIL AND
ARMS SO I WOULD. WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT HAD APPROPRIATE
RESOURCES AND THEN MAKE AN
EVALUATION ABOUT WHAT COMPONENTS
OF THE SYSTEM NEED TO BE REVISED
OR MAINTAIN.
THANK YOU.
AWESOME MIKE DID YOU CAN. TRADE
IT FOR ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
YEAH. OKAY YES MA'AM.
GOOD EVENING THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF MY STUDENTS MY NAME IS
VAL WILLIAMS ON THE
SUPERINTENDENT FOR THE ALBANY
SCHOOL DISTRICT. VERY SMALL
DISTRICT JUST NORTH OF BERKELEY
ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED STUDENTS
WELCOME HERE. I WANNA TAKE LOADS
OF A DIFFERENT.
STANCE TO GIVE A SNAPSHOT OF
WHAT THE INADEQUACY OF FUNDING
FOR SPECIAL ED ACTUALLY LOOKS
LIKE A SMALL DISTRICT LIKE MINE.
OUR NUMBER ONE OBJECTIVE IN OUR
STRATEGIC PLAN IS TO ENSURE THAT
ALL STUDENTS REACH THEIR FULL
POTENTIAL AND SO TO DO SO WE
NEED MORE FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR
SPECIAL ED. LAST YEAR FOR
MILLIONS FORTUNE REFORMING AND
DOLLARS OF OUR GENERAL FUND
MONIES WERE SPENT TOWARDS
SPECIAL EDUCATION.
THIS REPRESENTS SIXTY PERCENT OF
THE TOTAL SPECIAL EDUCATION
EXPENSES THAT ARE NOT FUNDED BY
THE STATE.
SIX SHORT YEARS AGO WE SERVE THE
SAME NUMBER STUDENTS AT ONLY ONE
THIRD OF THE COST OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
EACH YEAR THIS SIXTY PERCENT
MEANS THAT MY DISTRICT DOES NOT
HAVE TO MILLION DOLLARS TO HIRE
MUCH NEEDED COUNSELORS READING
SPECIALISTS MASS SPECIALISTS
NURSES SOCIAL WORKERS AND
QUALITY PARA PROFESSIONALS. WHO
ARE NEXT TO TEACHERS EVERY
SINGLE DAY MEETING WITH MY
STUDENTS?
EACH YEAR THIS MEANS THAT MY
DISTRICT DOES NOT HAVE TO
MILLION DOLLARS TO PROVIDE
HIGHER WAGES FOR MY STAFF TO
LIVE CLOSER TO MY COMMUNITY. TO
MAKE INVESTMENTS IN CLOSING THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP TO MAKING
INVESTMENTS IN GETTING MORE KIDS
TO GRADUATE TO INVESTING IN
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR MY
GENERAL ED SPECIALLY TEACHERS
AND MY POWER PROFESSIONALS. EACH
YEAR THIS MEANS THAT WE DO NOT
HAVE TO MILLION DOLLARS THEIR
PROVE THE SAFETY SECURITY OF MY
SCHOOLS. WE NEED MORE THE STATE
SUPPORT TO ENSURE THAT ALL
STUDENTS REACH OUR POTENTIAL AND
SO I'M ASKING THAT YOU HELP US
COLLECTIVELY ADDRESSES THIS
ISSUE. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME REGINA YOU NICER THAN
THE SCHOOL BOARD FOR. AS ELECTED
TO THIS BODY IN AND. NO NO THOSE
PROBLEMS INTIMATELY.
SO THANK YOU. FOR HAVING THIS
HEARING HERE TODAY YES MA'AM.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
IT'S BEEN A GREAT MORNING.
LISTENING TO EVERYBODY I'M
KATIE BABCOCK DIRECTOR OF NORTH
REGION SALPA SPECIAL EDUCATION
LOCAL PLAN RESENT.
BUT THAT'S ALBANY AREA OKAY OKAY
YEAH THAT'S COMING NORTH REGION
EIGHTY A IS ABOUT TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND AND WE HAVE FIVE
DISTRICTS THAT ACTUALLY PACK A
PUNCH ALBANY'S ONE OF THEM.
BERKELEY PIEDMONT EMORY AND
ALAMEDA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
SO WE'RE A SMALL SELF A BUTTON.
THERE'S A LOT GOING ON. OUR
FEDERAL GRANTS FOR PRESCHOOL
EQUALS ABOUT TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER CHILD. WITH
DISABILITIES AGE THREE AND FOUR
AND WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT IS
OFTEN A NEED FOR A LOW STUDENT
TEACHER RATIO AND OFTEN
ADDITIONAL SPECIALISTS THERE'S A
HUGE. SHORTFALL OUR FIVE
DISTRICTS NO DEEPLY. THAT EARLY
INTERVENTION IS CRITICAL SO WE
ALLOCATE BY POLICY EIGHT POINT
FIVE SEVEN PERCENT OF OUR STATE
APPORTIONMENT. FOR SPECIALIZED
SERVICES FOR PRE SCHOOL STUDENTS
FUNDS THAT WOULD OTHERWISE BE
USED FOR STUDENTS OF ALL AGES
AND THERE'S STILL A SHORTFALL
WITH THOSE ADDITIONAL FUNDS SO
I'M ADVOCATING THAT CALIFORNIA
NEEDS TO BUILD A MECHANISM IN
THE AB SIX SO TO.
FOR PRESCHOOL SPECIAL EDUCATION
SERVICES THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO NAMES INTERNET PELLETS
HERE IN THE SENIOR ADMINISTRATOR
FOR SAM MATTEO COUNTY SELFLESS
SPECIAL EDUCATION LOCAL PLAN WE
SERVE OVER TEN THOUSAND STUDENTS
WITH INDIVIDUAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS. I HAVE THIRTY ELEAZAR
AND BY FIVE OF WHICH ARE CHARTER
SCHOOLS THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
CONVENING THIS HEARING AND IT'S
GREAT TO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE INPUT.
I'D INTENDED TO SPEAK ON THE
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE OF EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AND FUNDING.
BUT INSTEAD I'M GOING TO SPEAK
TO SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT I
RAISED ABOUT RACE ABOUT LOCAL
CONTROL AND ELSIE FF.
SELF IS REALLY REPRESENT THE
ORIGINAL LOCAL CONTROL LOCAL
PLANS OF EVERY SILVA DETERMINE
HOW AB SIX OH TWO DLLARS CAN
BEST MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
REGION IN WHICH IS BEING SERVED
AS KATIE TO SHARE.
SPECIAL EDUCATION AS A FEDERAL
ENTITLEMENT AND KEEPING THOSE
FUNDS IN A SEPARATE ALLOCATION
ENSURES THAT LIMITED FUNDS
PROVIDED FOR THOSE NEEDY
STUDENTS ARE SPENT DIRECTLY ON
THOSE POPULATIONS.
ATTEMPTING TO RESOLVE A CHRONIC
UNDERFUNDING BY AN EMPTINESS
INSUFFICIENT PART OF DOLLARS
INTO ANOTHER INSUFFICIENT PART
OF DOLLARS WITHOUT FIRST
ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS THE
INADEQUACY. ONLY WILL EXACERBATE
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE.
NEITHER LCF NOR AB SIX OH TO
CURRENTLY ADDRESS EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AND
PRESCHOOL FUNDING. NEITHER
ENSURES ADEQUATE OR EQUITABLE
FUNDING FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
AMBLE FOR DEPENDED ON
CALCULATIONS THAT MAY NOT
REFLECT THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF THE
SPECIAL ED POPULATIONS SUCH AS
INCREASING NUMBERS SERVED. AND
I'M THE BEARING LEVELS OF
SUPPORT OR NEED THAT THOSE
STUDENTS A HALF.
RIGHT NOW WE BELIEVE THAT
ADDITIONAL FUNNY IS DESPERATELY
NEEDED ESPECIALLY FOR EARLY
CHILDHOOD AND FREE K.. WE NEED
TO ADDRESS THE NEED FOR
EQUALIZATION ACROSS THE STATE
AND RESOLVING THESE ISSUES FIRST
COULD PROVIDE A FIRM FOUNDATION
FOR FUTURE SPECIAL ED FISCAL
PROBLEM SOLVING AND PLANNING.
THE SUBASSOCIATION AND COALITION
FOR ADEQUATE FUNDING HAVE
DEVELOPED SEVERAL DRAFT
PROPOSALS THAT WE HAVE BEEN
KICKING AROUND OURSELVES WE
WOULD LOOK VERY MUCH FORWARD TO
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO SHARE THAT
INFORMATION WITH MEMBERS OF THE
OF THE OF THE PANEL OR HE'S.
AND WE HAVE ARE REALLY WILLING
TO COME TO THE TABLE AND SPEAK
JUST RECENTLY I HAVE WRITTEN A
PROPOSAL FOR OUT OF HOME. CARE
FUNDING AM ADJUSTMENT SO THERE
ARE DEFINITELY RESOURCES WITHIN
THE COMMUNITY THAT COULD FORWARD
THAT THAT NEED TO THREAD THE
NEEDLE THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU CAN IN THE ORGANIZATIONAL
RETURNED. THE SELF ASSOCIATE
SELF ADMINISTRATORS ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE COALITION
FOR ADEQUATE FUNDING.
THANK YOU.
HI I'M GLAD TO BE HERE TODAY AND
I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS I DIDN'T
EVEN PREPARING THING BECAUSE I
DIDN'T KNOW THAT I WAS. GET UP
AND READ SOMETHING SO BUT I
HEARD SO MANY ISSUES TODAY MY
NAME IS CATAMARANS FIRST AND
FOREMOST.
I'M A PARENT OF CHILDREN WITH
DIVERSE NEEDS.
UP ADHD. ASPERGERS MY YOUNGEST
SON IS DEAF.
I HAVE TWO GRANDCHILDREN ONE OF
WHICH LIVES WITH ME WHO HAS A
LEVEL ONE AUTISM.
AND.
AND THE OTHER ONE IS IN
PORTLAND OREGON AND AND HAS
AUTISM.
I'M I'M LEAVING HERE TODAY TO
FLY TO SANTA ANA WHERE HE'S
GOING TO MEET ME FROM PORTLAND
WE'RE GONNA GO ON A WONDERFUL
JOURNEY THING DISNEY WEDDING
REHEARSAL STUDIO BUT I GAVE YOU
THAT BACKGROUND. MUSCLE UP EARLY
CHILDHOOD SPECIAL EDUCATOR BY
TRADE. SO I WORK IN THAT FIELD
FOR A LONG TIME. THE LAST
SIXTEEN YEARS I'VE BEEN THE
DIRECTOR OF A FAMILY EMPOWERMENT
CENTER.
AND  HAVE TO TELL YOU THIS JOB.
I WAS LED INTO THIS JOB SIMPLY
BECAUSE OF MY OWN EXPERIENCE NOT
KNOWING HOW TO FIRST NAVIGATE
THOSE SYSTEMS WAS SO SCARY I
FELT SO ALONE I HAD NO IDEA.
THAT THERE WERE PEOPLE OUT HERE
WHO HAD DONE THIS BEFORE YOU
KNOW I MEAN I KINDA KNEW A
COUPLE OF PEOPLE BUT I I WAS
MEETING UP WITH ALL KINDS OF
THINGS YOU KNOW DO YOU SIGN DO
YOU TALK WHAT DO YOU DO WITH
THIS KID. I DON'T KNOW WHY IT'S
BEHAVIORS LIKE THIS I SWEAR I'M
DOING EVERYTHING THE SAME WITH
ALL THESE KIDS IN THIS ONE'S.
GOT THIS ISSUE YOU KNOW AT THAT
POINT IN TIME THEY KNOW ABOUT
ASPERGER AUTISM THOUGHT WAS WAS
BEHAVIOR BAD BEHAVIOR. SO I LOVE
THAT I'M ABLE TO NOW SUPPORT
CHILDREN WHO PARENTS WHO HAVE
CHILDREN WITH ALL KINDS OF
NEEDS.
ROCK CURRENTLY.
ROW FAMILY EMPOWERMENT SERVICE
IF YOU PLAN TO HAMMER SHASTA
ASSIST YOU IN TRINITY COUNTY.
AND WE RECEIVE A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR TO DO THAT WE WERE FUNDED
DUE TO SP FIVE ELEVEN WHICH SAID
THERE WOULD BE THIRTY TWO.
FAMILY EMPOWERMENT CENTERS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THERE'S
CURRENTLY FOURTEEN ARE FUNDING
HAS NEVER INCREASED EXCEPT BY
TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS UP OR DOWN
BASED ON OUR POPULATION OF
STUDENTS. SO WHAT HAPPENS TO US
WE LOSE STAFF THAT ARE CRITICAL
WE WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE PEOPLE
FROM HUMBOLDT CALL US BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE A FAMILY
EMPOWERMENT CENTER. AND WEAK
NONE OF MY PEOPLE CAN SAY WE'RE
NOT GOING TO TALK TO YOU. SO SO
I'M HERE TO SAY IT TALK ABOUT
EQUITY IT NEEDS TO BE ECHOED ALL
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IT'S BEEN A LOT OF YEARS SO. I'M
HOPING THAT SOME OF THAT MONEY
CAN GO TO ESTABLISHING NEW ONES
AND MAYBE LOOKING AT MAKING IT
EQUITABLE SO THAT DISTRICTS GET
A RAISE THE YOU CALL THAT I
THINK A COLA.
BUT WE'VE NEVER RECEIVED
ANYTHING LIKE THAT AND SO WE
LOOSE STAFF I HAD THREE TEACHERS
AT ONE POINT THAT WERE WORKING
FOR ME BECAUSE THEY LOVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THIS WORK BUT
THERE ARE. NOW THERE'S A TEACHER
SHORTAGE THEY'VE GOT YOU OFF.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
TOPIC YOU KNOW COULD GET POINTS
THANK YOU.
YES MA'AM.
I AM GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
JACKIE WILLIAMS AND I'M THE
ASSISTANT SUPERINTENDENT OF THE
WEST SAN GABRIEL VALLEY SELL
BACK. AND WE ARE LOCATED IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WOULD BUMP RIGHT
UP TO LOS ANGELES CITY WORK OF A
MULTI DISTRICTS OUT BUT WE CAN
SYSTEM FOURTEEN DISTRICTS. AND
WE HAVE EIGHTY EIGHT THOUSAND
STUDENTS ENROLLED IN THOSE
DISTRICTS OF WHICH WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY NINE THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED STUDENTS WITH ID PIECE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR.
LAMIA ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE
TODAY.
SO I HAVE MORE TONIGHT BUT WHAT
WHAT'S THE TOWN WITH THE. THOUGH
I'M THE WEST SAN GABRIEL VALLEY
SALPA OKAY AND IT'S FOURTEEN
DISTRICT ACTUALLY.
MR REPORTING TINO.
HE IS HAS ALMOST EVERY SINGLE
WITH YOUR LARGEST THIS SCHOOL
DISTRICT MY LARGEST DISTRICT IS
ALHAMBRA UNIFIED YOUR FOURTEEN
DISTRICTS IN THE SUB YES SIR MOM
WHEN THE THE LARGER THAT'S BEEN
ONE IN. YEAH WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
BIG.
IS SO MY S. SUPERINTENDENTS
COUNSEL ASKED ME TO BRING THIS
MESSAGE TO THE COMMITTEE TODAY
AND I THINK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
VERY PROUD OF THE PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES WE PROVIDE OUR STUDENTS
PARENTS AND STAFF
EVEN THEN HERONS INEQUITY OF THE
STATES AB SIX OH TWO FUNDING
MODEL OURSELF AS AB SIX SO TO
BASE RATE IS SET AT FIVE
HUNDRED.
AND. EIGHTEEN DOLLARS FOR THAT'S
THE AT THE.
THE STATEWIDE TARGET RATE IS
FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY DOLLARS
AND NINETY NINE CENTS SO THE
DISPARITY RESULTS IN A YEARLY
DEFICIT OF ONE POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS OF FUNDING FOR STUDENTS.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE AV SIX
SO TO RATE SHOULD BE. EQUALIZED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AM. THAT IS
A LOT OF MONEY WE ARE A BIG
DISTRICT AND.
SPREAD OUT BETWEEN THE FOURTEEN
DISTRICTS IT WOULD MAKE AN
IMPACT AND OF COURSE OUR EARLY.
EDUCATION.
WE HAVE MANY MANY PROGRAMS FOR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES AND.
AND OUR PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS BUT
THEY'RE ALL RUNNING AT AT WITH
NO FUNDING BASICALLY AND THE
DISTRICTS ARE SUPPORTING THAT
FINDING AND THEY'RE ALL
ADVOCATES FOR THE EARLY
EDUCATION PIECE SO.
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING
EQUALIZATION IT WOULD MEAN A LOT
TO OURS MY SUPERINTENDENT SENT
TO MOSTLY OUR PARENTS AND AND
OUR STUDENTS AND OURSELVES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
ABSOLUTELY OKAY THANK YOU.
YES MA'AM.
HIGH. EVELYN ADVERTISING WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
THOUGHT FIRST I'D LIKE TO. THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR A VERY.
.
FRUITFUL CONVERSATION AROUND
VERY COMPLEX ISSUES.
MORE. IMPORTANTLY FROM DRC'S
PERSPECTIVE AS WE LOOK AT
FUNDING GENERALLY IN THE CONTEXT
SPECIAL EDUCATION. WE THINK
REALLY IT'S IMPORTANT TO LOOK
AT.
IDENTIFYING OUTCOMES FOR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES SO
THAT FUNDING ADJUSTMENTS COULD
REALLY BE TIED TO SEEING SOME
PROGRESS FOR STUDENTS WHETHER
IT'S IN EMPLOYMENT I THINK WAS
THE LAST COMMITTEE. MEETING
ABOUT THAT ISSUE UP OR POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION OR ANY
NUMBER OF OUTCOME BUT REALLY
LOOKING AT IS THIS MONEY LEADING
TO.
HOPEFUL OUTCOMES FOR STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES IN THE CONTEXT
OF EMPLOYMENT INTEGRATION.
NOTE WAS SECONDARY EDUCATION AT
SUCH A AND THEN TRYING TO GET
SOME DATA TO SEE IF THAT'S
ACTUALLY HAPPENING. VERSUS A
VERY MUCH A PROPONENT OF THAT
CONCEPT TO REALLY SEE THAT OUR
MONEY IS GOING TO ACTUALLY
IMPROVING OUTCOMES FOR STUDENTS.
YEAH YEAH MAKE SENSE.
THANK YOU.
I. THINK IT IS A CARING ABOUT.
SEIU CALIFORNIA I THINK WE
TOTALLY AGREE WITH THOSE
COMMENTS OF BELIEVE THAT OUR
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES
DESERVED UP ALL OF THEIR NEEDS
MET AND FULLY FUNDED AND WE
THINK THE MONEY. TO FOLLOW THE
STUDENTS AND WOULD LIKE TO THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR.
BRINGING UP THE ROAD THE
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES. PLAY IN
MAKING SURE THAT THEY'RE NOT
OVERLOOK THINGS ONE VERY
IMPORTANT PIECE OF THE PUZZLE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON GETTING AWAY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LINES OF CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES OUR MEMBERS
ARE NONPROFIT PROVIDERS OF
FOSTER CARE IN CHILDREN'S MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. WEEP UP TALK
ABOUT THE WHOLE SPECTRUM FROM
FOSTER YOUTH OR IN GENERAL
EDUCATION ALL THE WAY UP TO
FOSTER YOUTH AND STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES WERE BEING SERVED
AT OUR MOST RESTRICTIVE
SETTINGS.
OUR MEMBERS HAVE BEEN ENGAGING
IN CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION AS WELL AS
FINANCE ALREADY STARTING TO TALK
ABOUT AND THINK THROUGH THOSE
VERY HIGH NEED STUDENTS
INCLUDING THOSE. WITH VERY HIGH
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS AND SOME
CASES ARE I'M HADN'T REQUIRING
RESIDENTIAL CARE AND A NON
PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
WE ALSO ARE REALLY ENGAGING AND
THINK THROUGH THE OUT OF HOME
CARE FORMULA THAT HAS BEEN
BRIEFLY MENTIONED. I'M SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING THESE
GUYS GOT DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
MOVING FORWARD. MAKE YOU THINK
YOU'RE MUCH.
YES.
IT AFTERNOON I'M SUSAN BOBBITT
BOTH I'M FROM THE WEST AND SOUTH
BY. DECEMBER TODAY NO SAMBAR
STUDENTS AND ABOUT THIRTY THREE
DISTRICTS.
A MY SUPERINTENDENT TEXAS ALSO
SERIOUSLY THAT HE BROUGHT A
DELEGATION UP EARLIER THIS WEEK
AND WE MET WITH SEVEN. OF
FIFTEEN DIFFERENT MEMBERS THAT
WAS AN AWESOME OPPORTUNITY SO I
THINK YOU KNOW EIGHT. FOR TAKING
THE TIME TO LISTEN TO ARE VERY
SERIOUS NEEDS I'M WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT AB SIX OR TWO IS TWENTY
YEARS OLD NOW. AND SO IT'S ABOUT
TIME THAT WE DO RETHINK THIS.
I'M.
IN MY CELL BUT. WE DID HAVE A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS WHEN I ARRIVED FIVE
YEARS AGO WE LOST A DISTRICT OF
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND LOST YOUR SO
WE'RE NOW DOWN TO EIGHTY NINE
THOUSAND STUDENTS. ON THE
NATURAL WE WERE STILL DOWN TWO
HUNDRED ELEVEN THOUSAND SO WE
HAD LOST SIX THOUSAND STUDENTS
IN A FIVE YEAR PERIOD. I'M WE'RE
FUNDED IT FIVE TOTAL SOON PART
WAS NOT SPECIAL NEEDS STUDENT.
HOWEVER OUR STAR POPULATION OF
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES HAD
PROBABLY GONE UP ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND IN THAT SAME AMOUNT OF
TIME. WE ARE FUNDED AT FIVE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE DOLLARS
AND FORTY TWO CENTS PER ADA. IF
THE STATE WERE TO COLLIDE
SPENDING TO SIX HUNDRED AND
TWENTY TWO DOLLARS THAT WOULD
MAKE OVER TWELVE MILLION DOLLAR
DIFFERENCE FOR US. EVERY TIME
THAT YOU LOOK HOT BUT
ENCROACHMENT OR GENERAL FUND
CONTRIBUTION IS DOING TO
JANETTE.
WE SO MUCH WHEN THEY HAVE
INCLUSIVE SETTINGS FOR STUDENTS.
BUT AS YOU LOOK A GENERAL FUND
HAVING TO MAKE UP THE DIFFERENCE
AND WERE RIGHT ALONG WITH THE
STATE FIGURE SIXTY TWO PERCENT.
THEN IT TAKES AWAY ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY FOR STUDENTS TO BE
AN JENNETTE OR TAKES WAY BAND OR
TAKES AWAY ARTER ALL THOSE OTHER
THINGS THAT OUR KIDS CAN DO SO
WELL AT.
I'M IN THE LAST TEN YEARS WE'VE
HAD AN INCREASE IN AUTISM IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN WE HAD SIX
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE STUDENTS
WITH AUTISM. IN THE NINE
DISTRICTS I HAVE NOW THAT'S NOT
EVEN INCLUDING THE TENTH
DISTRICT THAT HAD. TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND STUDENTS TOTAL LAST
YEAR WE WERE UP TO SIXTEEN
HUNDRED IT'S A HUGE INCREASE OF
OVER AT THAT ALMOST A THOUSAND
STUDENTS WITH AUTISM. AND AS WE
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER TODAY. YOU
KNOW THERE'S A WHOLE SPECTRUM
SOME OF THEM CAN BE VERY VERY
INTELLIGENT AND DO VERY WELL THE
JANET MAINSTREAM WITH YOU
SERVICES. BUT SEVENTY PERCENT IS
THAT NUMBER THAT I'VE HEARD THAT
ALSO HAVE AN INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITY.
I'M I'M PROUD TO SAY THOUGH WE
HAVE ALSO RETURNED STUDENTS
GENERAL EDUCATION. IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN WE RETURNED
SEVEN HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX
STUDENTS TO GENERAL EDUCATION.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEVEN.
WE HAVE A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
EIGHT STUDENTS IN NON PUBLIC
SCHOOLS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THAT
A LITTLE BIT TODAY. AND WE SPENT
TWELVE MILLION LAST YEAR AND IT
WAS APPROXIMATELY SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLAR PER STUDENT AND
THAT DOESN'T EVEN COST. INCLUDE
THE MENTAL HEALTH COSTS BECAUSE
THOSE ARE ON TOP OF THAT. I'M
JUST TALKING ABOUT STATE AND
FEDERAL FUNDING.
ARE ENCROACHMENT LAST YEAR I
HAVE A CHART AND LEANED OVER HAD
A COPY OF IT I THINK FROM OUR
MEETING EARLIER THIS WEEK WHICH
I CAN LEAVE WITH YOU. THAT SHOWS
OUR ENCROACHMENT DISTRICT BY
DISTRICT. SOMEBODY DINO CITY
SCHOOL TO TALK TO YOU TODAY
EARLIER THIRTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS. AND ALL ACROSS OUR
WHOLE COUNTY. THERE SEVEN
SUPPERS AND IT AMOUNTS TO THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AN
ENCROACHMENT.
DO YOU PROCESS WE ARE HIT HEAVY
BY DUE PROCESS LAST YEAR WE HAD
EIGHTY ONE FILINGS THAT WE
HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT THE COST OF
THAT. THAT COST US ABOUT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS WE HAD TWENTY
OTHER CASES WHERE PARENTS THANK
GOODNESS CAME TO US AND SAID WE
DON'T WANT TO FILE FOR DUE
PROCESS. WE WANT TO USE
ALTERNATIVE DISPUTE RESOLUTION
METHODS AND WE WERE ABLE TO COME
TO AN AGREEMENT WITH THOSE
PARENTS. WE REALLY SEE A SHIFT
IN OUR CULTURE BECAUSE OF THE
GRANTS.
SO IN THE END I WOULD SUGGEST
THAT WE REALLY REALLY DO NEED TO
LOOK AT A GROWTH FACTOR OF SOME
RECENT SHIFT IN OUR CULTURE
BECAUSE OF THE. ADR GRANT EDR
GREEN HAS THE FIVE YEAR ADR
GRANT FOR TWENTY THOUSAND PER
YEAR. WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO BRING
pWITH OUR PARENTS AND OUR OUR
DISTRICTS TO. REALLY MAKE SOME
DIFFERENCES AND DESCENDED
CONFERENCES.
SO I WOULD RECOMMEND.
SOME KIND OF A GROWTH FACTOR
BECAUSE AS YOU SAW ADA IS
DECLINING AND YET OUR STUDENT
POPULATION IT'S SPECIAL IT IS
GROWING. WE DESPERATELY NEED
EQUALIZATION.
PRESCHOOL I HAVE A DAUGHTER WITH
AUTISM WHO'S NOW AN ADULT AND I
KNOW THAT PRESCHOOL MADE A HUGE
HUGE DIFFERENCE FOR HER.
INCLUSION THE MORE THAT WE CAN
INCLUDE OUR KIDS IN GENERAL AD
IN SEVENTY PERCENT OF OUR KIDS
ARE IN GENERAL ADS FIFTY OR MORE
PERCENT OF THE DAY.
SO WE REALLY REALLY NEED TO GIVE
THEM ACCESS TO FIRST BEST
INSTRUCTION.
AND THEN WE REALLY REALLY NEED
TO ADVOCATE FOR THE ID A FUNDS
SO THAT WE CAN GET AN INCREASE
THERE SO WE WON'T JUST HAVE TO
BEAR IT AS THE STATE. AND I KNOW
EARLIER THIS WEEK JEFF BELL MET
WITH US IF YOU DO A LITTLE
PICTURE OF A CIRCLE THAT HERE'S
THE PIE.
HOW DO YOU WANT ME TO CUT
SOMEBODY ELSE'S SPICE MAKE YOURS
LARGER?
SO I WOULD ADVOCATE THAT WE
REALLY NEED TO LOOK AT THAT
ADDITIONAL REVENUES THAT ARE
COMING INTO THE STATE AND SEE
WHERE WE CAN TAKE SOME OF THOSE
AND PUT THEM IN SPECIAL ED.
BECAUSE EVERY TIME YOU GIVE A
DOLLAR TO SPECIAL ED YOU'RE NOT
TAKING IT AWAY FROM GENERAL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CALLIE YOUNG AND I
AM THE PROUD MOTHER OF A TWENTY
ONE YEAR OLD. YOUNG WOMAN WHO
HAPPENS TO BE ON A SPECIAL
EDUCATION. SHE HAS SEVERAL
POLICY AND EPILEPSY SO THIS IS
VERY NEAR AND DEAR TO MY HEART
I'M GRATEFUL THAT MY
REPRESENTATIVES ARE ON.
IN THIS HEARING THEY'RE NOT
HERE RIGHT NOW THOUGH. DOCTOR
PAN AND A MEMBER MCCARTY.
I WANT TO THANK YOU GUYS FIRST
OF ALL FOR YOUR COURAGE TO TAKE
UP THE SUBJECT IT'S HUGE AND A
LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE DONE A LOT OF
WORK ALREADY. AND WHAT REALLY
IMPRESSES ME AS A PARENT. AS A
TAXPAYER THAT WE HAVE ALL THESE
GREAT MINDS. THAT HAVE A LOT OF
INFORMATION AND THAT YOU GUYS
ARE REALLY TAKING THE TIME TO
LISTEN TO THEM. AND AND ASK THE
DIFFICULT QUESTIONS WHICH I
THINK IS GREAT SO SLOW AND
STEADY I DON'T THINK YOU GUYS
CAN.
MAKE THIS OF.
THIS PROBLEM DISAPPEAR QUICKLY.
.
I CAN I CAN I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONTINUE BRING ALL THE VOICES TO
THE TABLE WHAT I'M REALLY
MISSING THOUGH IS THE STUDENT
VOICE THE YOUNG ADULT WHO SPENT
THREE SPECIAL EDUCATION I WOULD
BE REALLY NICE TO SEE THEIR
VOICE.
I'M OF COURSE I THINK EARLY
IDENTIFICATION.
OF. DELAY AND DISABILITIES AND
IN EARLY INTERVENTION IS OUR ONE
OF OUR KEYS TO MAKING SURE THAT
OUR KIDS GET WHAT THEY NEED
ESPECIALLY ON EARLY
INTERVENTION.
INVOLVES THE FAMILY WHICH IS
REALLY IMPORTANT. I'M I ECHO ON
THE DEPARTMENT'S.
.
RECOMMENDATION THAT WE HAVE
MORE INCLUSIVE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PRESCHOOL WHERE INCLUSION
BECOMES THE NORM INSTEAD OF THE
EXCEPTION. OF IN. WHICH IT IS AN
EXCEPTION IN SCHOOL BUT I CAN
TELL YOU AS A PARENT OF A CHILD
OF A YOUNG WOMAN WHO'S TWENTY
ONE AND. BEAUTIFUL AND GORGEOUS
AND. BIG HEART SHE'D SHE'S SHE
DOESN'T HAVE A LOT OF FRIENDS.
I'M SHE HAS A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
OUR LIVES WHICH DOESN'T HAVE A
LOT OF FRIENDS. I'M.
SUPPORT FOR THE DEDICATED
PROFESSIONALS WHO WORK IN
EDUCATION WE'VE HAD AN
INCREDIBLE EXPERIENCE.
FROM GENERAL TEACHERS TO PEOPLE
IN THE OFFICE TO OUR SPECIAL I'D
PEOPLE IT'S BEEN INCREDIBLE. I'M
WE'VE BEEN LUCKY BECAUSE WE WE
BELIEVE IN COLLABORATION WHICH I
THINK IS THE KEY THE OTHER PART
I BELIEVE IN IS PARENTS SHOULD
BE INFORMED AND THEY'RE NOT.
I'M.
BREAKING DOWN THE BARRIERS
BETWEEN GENERAL EDUCATION AND
SPECIAL EDUCATION I THINK IS
SUPER IMPORTANT TO. IT IS KIND
OF A TWO SYSTEM AND IT DOESN'T
ALWAYS WORK. ULTIMATELY WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT THOUGH IS
STUDENT OUTCOMES.
IS THE MEASURE OF OUR OUR
SUCCESS.
OUR CHILDREN HELD A HIGH
STANDARDS.
ARE THEY ROLLING IN COLLEGE.
DO THEY HAVE JOBS I THINK IS
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT. AND
FINALLY AS A PARENT MY OTHER JOB
MY OTHER ROLE IS WHEN LORNE WAS
BORN SHE CHANGED MY LIFE AND I
BECAME I HAD JUST GRADUATED FROM
LAW SCHOOL. AND I CHANGED WHERE
I WAS GOING AND I EVENTUALLY
BECAME THE DIRECTOR OF A WARM
WIND FAMILY RESOURCE CENTER HERE
IN SACRAMENTO AND WE SUPPORT
PARENTS IN UNDERSTANDING. THE
LAWS AND HOW TO NAVIGATE BUT AS
MY COLLEAGUE SAID EARLIER A LOT
OF OUR STATE DOES NOT HAVE A
LOCAL SUPPORT FOR PARENTS AND
THEY'RE DROWNING. AND THEY'RE
CONFUSED AND THEY NEED HELP. AND
THERE'S PEOPLE WONDER WHY THEY
COME TO MEETINGS ANGRY.
THEY'RE CONFUSED AND IF WE HAD
MORE FORM PARENTS WE WOULD HAVE
MORE COLLABORATION SO I WOULD
FULLY SUPPORT FULL FUNDING OF
THE FAMILY EMPOWERMENT CENTERS
THANK YOU FOR THIS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
GOOD. META VISION TO.
YES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
THERESA BRADLEY AND I'M HERE
TODAY TO REPRESENT AT THE CARS
PLUS ORGANIZATION. CARS PLUS IS
A CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
RESOURCE SPECIALISTS PLUS ALL
OTHER SPECIAL EDUCATORS.
OUR MEMBERS ARE NOT TRUSTING
DISTRICTS THESE DAYS. BECAUSE
THE DISTRICTS ARE NOT FOLLOWING
THE AT TWENTY EIGHT. HER
CASELOAD LAW FOR OUR S. P.. AND
I AM HERE TO HAVE YOU LISTEN.
AND HOPEFULLY HELP MAKE SURE
THAT ALL OF THE FUNDING DOES NOT
GET INTO. PUT INTO DISTRICT
HANS.
OUR MEMBERS ARE HELPING STUDENTS
BECAUSE THEY WANT THEM TO BE AN
ADVOCATE AND TO BE THE VOICE OF
THE STUDENTS. AND SOME TEACHERS
ACTUALLY GET IN TROUBLE FOR
ADVOCATING FOR THEIR STUDENTS
WHEN THEY DO NEED MORE SERVICES.
AND IF THE FUNDS WERE SOLELY
BEING HANDED OUT BY THE DISTRICT
THERE WOULD BE A.
SOME PROBLEMS THERE.
THERE ARE THE OTHER THING THAT I
WANTED TO BRING UP IS THAT IT
IS.
WOULD BE WONDERFUL TO HAVE A
SPECIAL DAY CLASS.
CLASS SIZE MAXIMUM.
FOR THE CASE LOAD STC TEACHERS.
THANK YOU.
I CURLING HOLDEN WITH EASTER
SEAL I SHOULD DO. EASTER SEALS
PROVIDER OF CONCRETE PRIMARILY
DISABILITIES HAVING ALMOST A
HUNDRED YEARS OLD SO WE WERE
STARTED BY.
MY PARENTS IN THE ROTARY AND A
HUNDRED YEARS LATER WE'RE STILL
PROVIDING SERVICES TO FAMILIES.
WITH THE DISPELLED INDIVIDUALS
WITH A DISABILITY AND THE WHOLE
FAMILY SO IT IS A YEAH.
INDIVIDUALIZED SUPPORT MODEL.
ARE WE PROVIDE EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION. ZERO FIVE I'VE GOTTA
SAY THAT IT'S THE INTEGRATED
BOTTLE ONLY.
AND.
.
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES ARE
GENERALLY ATTEND OF UP TO FORTY
PERCENT OF CHILDREN WITH A
DISABILITY PARTICIPATING IN WITH
TYPICALLY DEVELOPING CHILDREN
ALL OF OUR CHILDREN GO TO PUBLIC
SCHOOL. AND AND IN INTEGRATED
SETTING WHEN THEY ARE
TRANSITIONING FROM OUR SERVICES
TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
AND I'VE BEEN VERY IMPRESSED
WITH THE MODEL ON AS AN EASTER
SEAL PROVIDER MODEL WE DO A LOT
OF SERVICES FOR DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND REGIONAL CENTER
FUNDED SERVICES.
BUT I THINK THE OF EARLY
CHILDHOOD SERVICES IN THE
INTEGRATED MODEL IS PRODUCING
AWESOME RESULTS I REALLY
ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT.
FOR THAT BECAUSE CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES ARE EXPECTING TO BE
INTEGRATED WHEN THE TRANSITION.
AND THEY ARE BEING INTEGRATED.
I ALSO THINK SOME OF THE
SPECIAL WORKAROUND TRANSITION
AGE.
CHILDREN IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THE BLUEPRINT THAT'S BEEN
DEVELOPED IS PRODUCING CEMEX
GOING TO BE PRODUCING SOME
EXCELLENT ARE.
OUT COMES AS WELL SO LIKE ON
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WHO
IS PROMOTING BETTER LOOK AT.
OUTCOMES BY TO ENCOURAGE YOU TO
REALLY LOOK AT. MEASURABLE
OUTCOMES THAT WE CAN LOOK AT THE
INVESTMENTS THAT WE'RE MAKING
AMTRAK THOSE SO WE CAN CONTINUE
HAVE A CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT
MODEL.
I WOULD IF TIME PERMITS I'D
LIKE TO SHARE A FEW COMMENTS
ALSO NOT AS A PROVIDER BUT AS A
PARENT ABOUT CHILDREN WHO.
HAD.
DISABLING CONDITIONS AND
PARTICIPATED IN SPECIAL ED.
ONE OF WHICH IS THE LEARNING
DISABILITY I HAVE ON. MY OLDEST
DAUGHTER WHO HAS A LEARNING
DISABILITY SHE WAS NEVER
DIAGNOSED.
AND DONT IT CHILDREN SHOULD HAVE
TO WAIT TILL FIFTH GRADE I THINK
WHEN WE STARTED TO WATCH THAT
CURVE COME UP.
BECAUSE BY THEN THEY'VE LOST A
LOT OF LEARNING OPPORTUNITY.
NOW.
HAVING BEEN A PARENT OF A CHILD
WITH A LEARNING DISABILITY I'VE
GOT TO SAY WE COMPENSATED AND
SHE IS NOT GOING TO GET HER PHD.
AND IN IN THAT ENGINE EDUCATOR.
BUT WE'VE COME A LONG WAY HERE
AND OUR ABILITY TO DIAGNOSE INTO
DIAGNOSED EARLIER.
AND SO WHATEVER WE CAN DO ONE
OUT.
HILLARY HAD LIKE TO ENCOURAGE
THAT WE DO THAT SO WE GET
CHILDREN IDENTIFIED IN AN
EARLIER AGE SO THEY DON'T HAVE
TO START GETTING MESSAGES OF NOT
BEING AS COMPETENT LATER.
I ALSO HAD A CHILD WHO
PARTICIPATED IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION. I HE DID HAVE A
INTEGRATED MODEL THEY PULLED HIM
OUT FOR SERVICES. AND DUMB.
HE IS NOW ARM IN CHARGE OF SIGN
LANGUAGE INTERPRETERS CROSS THE
COUNTRY'S WAS WORKING FOR.
EIGHT.
A COMPANY AND HE'S A SUPERVISOR
FOR HUNDREDS OF OF.
INTERPRETERS CROSS COUNTRY BUT
I'M JUST SAYING THE. ABILITY FOR
US TO GET THE SUPPORT EARLY
CHANGE THE WHOLE TRAJECTORY OF
LIFE
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
THANK YOU FOR HAVING THE
HEARING.
YOU ENDED.
BECAUSE AS SAYING THAT I NEARLY
EVERY EDUCATIONAL POLICY
PHENOMENON WE DEAL WITH IN THIS
COMMITTEE. EARLY INTERVENTION
IS.
IS IS CRITICAL IS PART OF WHY I
AM HERE FOR THE LIFE OF ME I
DON'T REALLY UNDERSTAND WHY WERE
THE ONLY.
DEVELOPED NATION THAT SEEMS TO
SO UNDER INVESTING EARLY
CHILDCARE EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION SO.
THERE'S A BROADER PROBLEM WE
ALSO NEED TALK ABOUT SELF YES
ABSOLUTELY FOR FROM YOU BUT
WE'LL HEAR ONE LAST COMMENT
ISN'T. HE AS AT CARDS PLUS
REPRESENTATIVE NOW YOU'RE GONNA
HEAR FROM ME AS A TEACHER OKAY
GREAT WE NEEDED WEAR DIFFERENT
HATS. TOOK OFF ONE SIDE OKAY.
ON MY LITTLE TEACHERS OUT HERE
OKAY.
EACH.
I TEACH A SPECIAL DAY CLASS
FIFTH THROUGH EIGHTH GRADERS AND
I HAVE MODERATE SEVERE STUDENTS.
I. I HAVE INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITY AUTISM SPECIAL.
.
SPECIFIC LEARNING DISABILITY IN
THE PAST I'VE HAD AWAY TRY AND
ALSO ADHD.
THIS IS MY SEVENTH YEAR BEING IN
THE CLASSROOM.
AND I'M HERE TO BE THE VOICE OF
MY STUDENTS WHO ARE NON VERBAL
AND OTHERWISE.
THE MORE MINUTES.
ON ON MY CAMPUS THE STUDENTS
HAVE MORE CERTAIN MINUTES PER
SCHOOL DATE THAN ANY OTHER
SCHOOL ON OUR CAMPUS.
I MEAN IN OUR DISTRICT. I WANTED
TO INVITE EVERY SINGLE PERSON TO
COME AND VISIT MY CLASSROOM AND
SEE MY STUDENTS I THINK THAT IT
WOULD BE VERY. OFFICIAL.
FOR THE POLICY MAKERS TO SEE
WHAT ACTUALLY HAPPENS IN THE
CLASSROOM AND I CAN BE A
CONNECTION. BETWEEN YOU AND THEM
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO VISIT MY
CLASSROOM I CAN MAKE
ARRANGEMENTS FOR YOU TO SEE
SOMEBODY ELSE'S.
I'M ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE THAT
GETS THE MEDICAL PAPERWORK
SIGNED BY THE FAMILIES.
AND SOMETIMES IT GETS SIGNED
THREE TIMES FOR ONE MEETING.
I'M ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE THAT NO
I DON'T GET PAID MORE MONEY WHEN
I'M WAITING TEN TO FORTY MINUTES
AFTER SCHOOL LETS OUT. FOR
TRANSPORTATION TO COME AND PICK
UPTHE STUDENTS TO CARRY THEM
HOME.
I'M ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE THAT.
COACHES SPECIAL OLYMPICS NOT WE
HAVE FOUR SPORTS THAT I
CURRENTLY COACH AND I DON'T GET
PAID ANY MORE MONEY TO BE A
SPECIAL OLYMPIC COACH.
FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS I HAVE
PARTICIPATED IN FOUR AND
NATIONAL I EAT PEAS FOR REFUGEES
THAT HAVE BEEN ON OUR CAMPUS.
AND I'LL TELL YOU THAT THE ONLY
ONE THAT WAS PUT IN THE. MY
CLASS IS THE ONE THAT HAD DOWN
SYNDROME AND WE COULD SEE THE.
OBVIOUSLY HAD A DISABILITY
BECAUSE OF HOW HE LOOKED BECAUSE
ITS CHROMOSOMES BUT THE OTHER
THREE.
THE STAFF ON CAMPUS HAVE TO
GO-THROUGH A LOT OF WORK AND A
LOT
OF.
THINGS NEED TO BE IN PLACE IN
ORDER FOR THIS SPEECH AND THE
TRANSLATORS AND THE TEACHERS TO
SAY THIS CHILD NEEDS HELP LET'S
GET THEM THE HELP THAT THEY NEED
THE OTHER THING THAT I WANTED TO
ADDRESS IS THE PARENT EDUCATOR
HOURS I HAD TO PARE
PROFESSIONALS THAT WORK WITH ME.
AND THE STUDENTS ARE ON CAMPUS
LONGER THAN EITHER OF THOSE
LADIES ARE. SO I HAVE TO HAVE
ONE COME IN EARLIER IN THE
MORNING AND ONE STAY LATER IN
THE AFTERNOON.
AND I BROUGHT A COLOR VISUAL TO
ACTUALLY SHOW HOW MUCH TIME PER
DAY IN MY CLASSROOM. THREE
ADULTS ARE ABLE TO GIVE ACADEMIC
INSTRUCTION TO OUR STUDENTS IF
ANYBODY'S INTERESTED IN LOOKING
AT THAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING
THIS HEARING BECAUSE I LEARNED
SO MUCH STARTING OFF LISTENING
TO RYAN TALK. AND.
THERE WERE SO MANY MORE YEARS UP
THERE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE DAY I
WISH I WOULD HAVE TAKEN A
PICTURE SO I CAN HAVE A. VISUAL
OF A FACE AND A NAME IN CASE I
EVER MEET ANYBODY IN THE FUTURE
AS I. WILL TELL YOU NOW I WON'T
REMEMBER WHO YOU ARE.
PLEASE.
COME TALK TO ME.
AND INCLUDE ME IN FUTURE THINGS
THANK YOU OKAY IF YOU COULD
SHARE INFORMATION WITH THE
COMMITTEE. STAFF OF THE GREAT.
OKAY THANK EVERYBODY.
FOREVER FOR STAYING.
THROUGH TO THE BITTER END I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE IT AND AND.
LOTS AND LOTS OF ISSUES RAISED
TODAY. REALLY WANT TO SEND A
VERY SPECIAL THINGS OUT TO THE
STAFF OF ALL OF THE FOUR
COMMITTEES INVOLVED. FOR THEIR
DILIGENCE AND ENGAGEMENT AND FOR
HELPING TO PULL TOGETHER SUCH
FANTASTIC PANELS THAT FROM WHICH
WE LEARN SO MUCH. SO REALLY DO
APPRECIATE YOU.
PLANS TOGETHER AND ALSO FOR THE
PACKET THAT'S HERE WITH SOME
REALLY GOOD INFORMATION.
AND OBVIOUSLY THIS IS THE START
OF A LONGER CONVERSATION AND AND
WE REALLY DO APPRECIATE IT RUNS
AND SOMETHING EVERYONE AND WITH
THAT THIS HEARING IS YOUR MA